FIRST MEETING OF- BUDGET
SUBPREFECTURE CALENDAR YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY IT'S AN HONOR FOR
ME TO BE BACK. CHAIRING THIS UP
VERY IMPORTANT BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE- FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO OF UP AND COMING TO THIS
MEETING SO FOR THE LONG HAUL
IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE- I'VE I'VE
HAD THE HONOR OF CHAIRING. THIS
COMMITTEE NOW FOR A WHILE
ENSURING CUT MY EIGHT YEAR IT
IS- PROBABLY THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT- SINGLE MOST
SIGNIFICANT THING THAT I DO
HERE IN THE CAPITAL WE AS YOU
ALL KNOW COVER- ISSUES OF
EXTRAORDINARY IMPORTANCE. TO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA- I
APOLOGIZE FOR- THE- HAVING TO A
POSTPONED RESCHEDULE LAST
WEEK'S MEETING MAKING THIS THE
FIRST WEEK- THAT- THAT WE HAVE
TO DO OUR WORK THERE WERE SOME
MISTER. AND IT JUST BECAME
NECESSARY TO- A TO RESCHEDULE
AT THE LAST MINUTE SO I%
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT. BUT WE'RE
GOING TO DO- I BEGIN THIS
MORNING WITH- WE'RE GONNA PASS
OVER THE VOTE ONLY CALENDAR-
UNTIL LATR WE'RE GOING TO
BEGIN WITH A REPORT FROM THE
NATURAL RESOURCES AGE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY WE HAVE MISTER
CRAWFORD HERE. TO GIVE US AN
OVERVIEW OF- OF THE BUDGET.
THANK THE RESOURCES BUDGET YEAH
YOU DON'T HAVE TO EVERYBODY ALL
THING WAS IT YEAH IF YOU WANT
TO. WELL THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO OVERVIEW OUR
BUDGET AND I CAN SAY THAT I'M
REALLY EXCITED TO BE HERE
TODAY. TO SHARE SOME CONTEXT AS
YOU BEGIN YOUR WORK. FOR IN
COMING WEEKS- FIRST OF ALL LET
ME SAY THANK YOU- CHAIR BLOOM
IT YOU KNOW YOU YOU MENTIONED
ARE YOU NOTED THAT YOU'VE BEEN.
LEADING THE SUBCOMMITTEE FOR
THE LAST EIGHT YEARS AND THIS
IS MY FIRST FULL YEAR OF
BUILDING- THE BUDGET WITH OUR
TEAM AT THE AGENCY AND I HAVE
TO SAY. WE ARE BUILDING UP A
REALLY STRONG FOUNDATION AND
THAT IS THANKS TO THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE- SECRETARY LAYERED
OF COURSE A LOT OF FOLKS. WHO
HAVE WHO HAVE YOU KNOW YEAR IN
YEAR OUT IMPROVED OUR BUDGET.
ARM LET ME ALSO SAY THANK YOU
TO STAFF. ABOUT YOUR STAFF AND
OUR STAFF BRIAN CASSIAN AMANDA
MARTIN AND THEIR COUNTERPARTS
AT THE DEPARTMENT'S. WILL LIKE
ME THERE ARE HERE IN SOUTH AYE
AYES ALL THE HARD WORK THAT
GETS DONE FOR MONTH. THE GIVE
AWAY ALL OF SECRETS PLEASE. AT
I'LL SAY IT BECAUSE THIS IS THE
FOR TIME THAT WERE WERE
TOGETHER THROUGH THE SUB.
PROCESS I REALLY DO VIEW THIS A
PARTNER. BOB YOU ALL HAVE
IMPORTANT TO. MAINTAIN
ACCOUNTABILITY. OF OUR
EXECUTIVE BRANCH WITH THE
BUDGET THAT WE PROPOSE AND THAT
WE WANT TO HELP YOU IN THAT
ROLE SO. I WANT TO BE
PERSONALLY INVOLVED HOWEVER IS
HELPFUL IN COMING WEEKS
RECOGNIZING THEIR A WHOLE LOT.
OF PEOPLE THAT ARE MUCH MORE
EXPERT THAN ME AND THE DETAILS
THAT YOU'LL BE ASKING ABOUT. SO
OUR AGENCY AS YOU KNOW AND
OTHERS IN THE ROOM NO AS A BIG
BROAD AGENCY ARE TWENTY SIX
DIFFERENT ENTITIES. A PROPOSED-
BUDGET OF ALMOST SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS OF SPENDING. YOU'LL
SPEND WEEKS OBVIOUSLY COMING
THROUGH THESE PROPOSALS- AND
ASKING A LOT OF QUESTIONS SO
WHAT I'LL DO OVER THE NEXT FEW
MINUTES IS SIMPLY. IDENTIFY AS
WITH A HIGH LEVEL PRIORITIES IN
KEY THEMES THAT RUN THROUGH OUR
BUDGET AND- GIVE YOU A SENSE
FROM FROM MY ROLE AS SECRETARY-
WHAT I AM EXCITED ABOUT. SO
FIRST AND FOREMOST- AS IT
RELATES TO PRIORITIES IS OF
COURSE CLIMATE RESILIENCE- WHAT
I CALL PROTECTING PEOPLE AND
NATURE FROM THE IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE. WERE IN
CALIFORNIA WORLD LEADERS ON
REDUCING CARBON POLLUTION- THAT
IS TACKLING PLANETARY CLIMATE
CHANGE BUT WE KNOW THAT WE CAN
AVOID THE IMPACTS THAT CLIMATE
DRIVES THAT ARE ALREADY HERE.
CONSIDER THESE FACTS 3% OF THE
STATE'S LAND MASS BURNED UP IN
THE LAST FEW YEARS. THE STATE'S
WORST DROUGHT ON RECORD IN THE
LAST DECADE AND- ONE AND A
FLOODING EMERGENCY OF A VERY
LARGE PROPORTIONS THAT OR A
VILLAIN IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE
KNOW THESE IMPACTS ARE HERE.
ARE RESOURCES AGENCY PLAYS A
CENTRAL ROLE- ON PROTECTING
COMMUNITIES AND NATURAL PLACES
FROM THOSE IMPACTS. WE ARE
ECITED THAT THE GOVERNOR IN
PROPOSING HIS BOND IN JANUARY I
CALLED FOR A CLIMATE RESILIENCE
BOND- TO BE DISCUSSED BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND IF THERE'S
AGREEMENT NOT TO BE CONSIDERED
BY THE VOTERS IN NOVEMBER.
THAT'S REALLY BUILDS ON OUR
LEADERSHIP IN WITHIN THE
LEGISLATURE AND PROPOSALS- OVER
THE LAST YEAR I KNOW THAT ONE
THAT WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
THE CLIMATE RESILIENCE BOND
TODAY BUT I LOOK FORWARD TO-
TALKING ABOUT THAT WITH YOU AND
YOUR COLLEAGUES IN COMING WEEKS.
ONE IMPORTANT ELEMENT I PRIMARY.
IS OBVIOUSLY A CONTINUE
INVESTMENTS IN- OUT WILD FIRE
PROTECTION. YOU KNOW THAT IN
THAT LAST- IT LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET THE GOVERNOR AND
LEGISLATURE APPROPRIATED OVER A
BILLION DOLLARS. OF FUNDING
BOTH TO EMERGENCY RESPONSE
THROUGH OUR- CAL FIRE- ENTITY
BUT THEN ALSO A SIGNIFICANT
PREVENTATIVE WORK. THIS YEAR WE
CONTINUE TO BUILD ON THOSE
INVESTMENTS INCLUDING A
SIGNIFICANT PROPOSED INVESTMENT
IN. INCREASING THE PERSON
POWER- WITHIN WITHIN CAL FIRE.
NOT ONE HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS ARE GENERAL FUND
SPENDING ALMOST SEVEN HUNDRED
POSITIONS TO BE PHASED IN OVER
THE NEXT FIVE YEARS. TO REALLY
BUILD THAT- CORE BASE OF FIRE
FIGHTING CAPACITY AND BUILD OUR
OPERATIONAL FLEXIBILITY. WE
HAVE NEW FUNDING FOR A PROPOSED
WILDFIRE FORECAST CENTER WHICH
WILL INCREASE THE INTELLIGENCE
AND THE FORECASTING ABILITIES
THAT WE BRING TO- THE FIRE
FIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA. AND
WE ARE CALLING FOR SIGNIFICANT
FUNDING. FOR A MAJOR HARM HOME
HARDENING- PROGRAM RECOGNIZING
THAT- REDUCING THE THREAT OF
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES IS NOT
JUST ABOUT YOUR FUEL BREAKS IN
YOUR FOREST MANAGEMENT WE HAVE
TO DO MORE WITHIN COMMUNITIES-
TO PROTECT OUR OUR OUR PEOPLE
FROM. A WILDFIRE. ANOTHER KEY
ELEMENT OF CLIMATE RESILIENCE
IS OBVIOUSLY PROTECTING AGAINST
DROUGHT AND FLOOD. ARE GOVERNOR.
DIRECTED OUR AGENCY IN OTHERS
BACK IN APRIL TO DEVELOP WATER
RESILIENCE PORTFOLIO. WHICH IS
A REALLY PUMP. PUBLICLY
TRANSPARENT- ROAD MAP FOR OUR
OWN INVESTMENTS WITHIN THE NEW
CIVIC MINISTRATION ON WATER IN
COMING YEARS. I SO YOU'LL SEE
IN THIS BUDGET WHEN YOU TALK TO
THE DEPARTMENT. RESORT IS AN
ENTITY. HOW THOSE PRIORITIES
MANTA. HOW ALL. A PORTION OF
OUR PROPOSED BILLIONS IS
FOCUSED ON BUILDING AND RESULT
IMPORT TO MEMBERS OF THIS CAN
WE ARE SUGGEST SIGNIFICANT
FUNDING ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
TO HELP LOCAL COMMUNITIES
IMPACT- SHOULD SORRY IMPLEMENT
THE SUSTAINABLE GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT ACT OR STIGMA- WE
KNOW THAT SIGMA IS NECESSARY TO
PROTECT GROUNDWATER SUPPLIES-
ACROSS THE STATE FOR DECADES TO
COME BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT IT
WILL HAVE REAL IMPACTS IN
COMMUNITIES AND SO BELIEVE THAT
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THE STATE TO
CONTINUE TO INVEST TO REALLY
POOR THAT LOCAL LEADERSHIP
MANAGING THEIR OWN GROUND WATER
BASE. SO CLIMATE RESILIENCE
MAJOR PRIORITY ANOTHER. MAJOR
PRIORITY IS PROTECTING WHAT WE
CALL OUR BIO DIVERSITY IN THE
STATE. CALIFORNIA IS BLESSED TO
BE- AN AREA OF TREMENDOUS
NATURAL RICHNESS KNOWN AS ONE
OF THE BIO DIVERSE HOT SPOTS IN
THE WORLD WE HAVE A GREATER
VARIETY OF PLANTS AND ANIMALS
THAN ALMOST ANYWHERE ON THE
PLANET. WE OBVIOUSLY IT DO A
GOOD JOB PROTECTING ANIMALS ON
THE BRINK OF EXTINCTION THROUGH
ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT OUR
PROTECTIONS BUT FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE AND I THINK OUR
PERSPECTIVE WE WANT TO DO MORE
TO KEEP THOSE PLANTS AND
ANIMALS- FROM ACTUALLY FACING
EXTINCTION. I LIKEN IT TO
HEALTHCARE POLICY I WORK WE
ALWAYS NEED TO KEEP THE PATIENT
ALIVE IN THE EMERGENCY ROOM AND
WILL CONTINUE TO DO THAT BUT IF
THAT'S THE ENTIRETY OF YOUR
HEALTH CARE POLICY I YOU HAVE A
SEVERELY LIMITED APPROACH AND
SO LIKE WISE WE ARE EXCITED
ABOUT MAKING SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS TO APP PROTECT AND
RESTORE NATURE- PRIOR TO IT AND
SO THREAT. AND I INCLUDES
SIGNET. FUNDING POLLS ALL OF
FOR THE TECH. THAT ACTUALLY BE
A CRITICAL TOOL TO MANAGE THIS
PILOT. AND THEN SIGNIFICANT ONE
TIME FUNDING- THAT WILL HELP
THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE BE MORE EFFECTIVE AND
EFFICIENT I DOING THINGS LIKE-
PROTECTING MIGRATION CORRIDORS
AND THE LIKE AND FISH
HATCHERIES ETCETERA RELATE. TO
THIS WORK ON BIODIVERSITY WE
ARE CONTINUINGOUR INVESTMENT
IN STRENGTHENING THE DEPARTMENT
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE.
RECOGNIZING IS YOU KNOW CHAIR
BLOOM THAT DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION AND- HISTORICALLY IT
HAS LOST- GENERAL FUND. AND ITS
CAPACITY HAS BEEN REDUCED-
WHILE ITS STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS CONTINUE TO
INCREASE. SO ONE OF THE THINGS
YOU'LL SEE FROM ME OVER THE
NEXT FEW YEARS IS A REAL
PRIORITY TO CONTINUE TO
REINVEST IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE TO BUILD ITS
CAPACITY. AB SO WE CALL FOR THE
PERMIT EXTENSION OF THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS OF GENERAL FUND
THAT WAS TIME LIMITED- OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS. AS WELL AS-
SIGNIFICANT NEW CAPACITY WITHIN
THE AGENCY. TO IMPLEMENT THE
CALIFORNIA ENDANGERED SPECIES
ACT- AND HELP OUR ECOLOGICAL
RESTORATION ROJECTS HAPPEN
MORE QUICKLY WE CALL THIS
CUTTING GREEN TAPE. REMARKABLY
SOME OF THESE PROJECTS THAT WE
FIND THROUGH OUR BONDS IN OUR
INVESTMENTS FULLY A THIRD OF
THE PROJECT BUDGET IS PLANNING
AND PERMITTING. AND IF YOU
THINK ABOUT THE THREATS THAT WE
EXPERIENCE FROM CLIMATE CHANGE
BIODIVERSITY THREATS WE NEED TO
DO THIS ECOLOGICAL RESTORATION
MORE COST EFFECTIVELY AND MORE
EFFICIENTLY. SO PART OF OUR
INVESTMENTS ARE ACTUALLY TO
BUILD- SORT OF A MULTI
FUNCTIONAL TEAM WITHIN FISH AND
WILDLIFE TO GET THESE PROJECTS
PERMITTED AND PROVE MORE
QUICKLY. THE CLIMATE RESULT
DIVERSE. A THIRD PER PRY. IS X.
ACCESS. OF ALL CALIFORNIANS TO
OUR PARKS ARE OUTDOORS AND OUR
NATURAL PLACES. THIS REALLY
DRIVES WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
COMMITMENT OF A CALIFORNIA FOR
ALL. YOU'LL NOTICE THAT REALLY
THE ANCHOR OF THIS PRIORITY IS
IT IS A PROPOSED- SET OF FUND
OF- A FUNDING ACTIONS WITHIN
OUR DEPARTMENT STATE PARKS. ARE
SPECIFICALLY SIXTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS THAT WE PACKAGE INTO
WHAT WE'RE CALLING A PARKS FOR
ALL INITIATIVE- WITCHING WHICH
INCLUDES OUR PROPOSED FUNDING
FOR ACQUISITION. OF A NEW STATE
PARK. AS WELL AS THE
ACQUISITION OF CERTAIN IN
HOLDINGS THAT SIMPLY MAKES
SENSE TO EXPAND PARK OFFERINGS.
IMPORTANTLY WE ARE PROPOSING
FUNDING FOR AN OUTDOOR EQUITY
GRANTS PROGRAM. WHICH WAS A
PROGRAM ESTABLISHED- THROUGH
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO OH NINE
AUTHORED ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE
MON. THE NOTION IS WE HAVE WHAT
CLASS PARKS WORLD CLASS STATE
PARKS BUT IN A LOT OF CASES
SOME OF OUR COMMUNITIES CAN'T
ACCESS THOSE PARKS. SO HOW CAN
WE ACTUALLY HELP THAT THIS
COMMUNITIES IN THOSE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS ACTUALLY ACTS PARKS SO
YOU HEAR FROM STATE PARK. ABOUT
THIS AFTER WE REALLY THINK THAT
THIS PART FOR ALL OF US IN THE-
IN. THE IS GOING TO BE THE
BEGINNING. OF A MULTI IN THIS
TO IN OUR- TO A PARKS AND HOPE.
SO I JUST THOSE THE THREE PER
PRIOR CLIMATE RESILIENCE BY. AN
AXE. LET ME MENTION A FEW OTHER
IMPORTANT I IN OUR BUDGET NOT
ONE IS OIL AND GAS OVER. SO AS
YOU KNOW. OUR GOVERNOR HOW BEEN
PH<c.cyan>N. TO AND OVERSIGHT OF</c>
OILING PRODUCTION PRODUCTION IN
THE STATE- THAT HAS INCLUDED
OVERHAULING THE DIVISION THAT
REGULATES THAT ACTIVITY. A WHAT
WE USED TO KNOW AS THE DIVISION
OF OIL GAS AND GEOTHERMAL
RESOURCES OUR DOG- HAS BEEN
TRANSFORMED. WITH AN UPDATED
MICHIGAN AND A NEW NAME WHICH
WERE FOR REFERRING TO CAL
JAMMER THE CALIFORNIA GEOLOGIC
ENERGY MANAGEMENT DIVISION- FOR
THE NEW ACKERMAN. IN THE NEW
ACRONYM WOULD BE MEAN BUT
ACTUALLY DIDN'T I WASN'T PART
OF A BROADER MISSION AND- IN
REALLY REINVIGORATED INVESTMENT
IN FOCUS AND THAT'S WHAT THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE EXCITED TO. TO TALK
ABOUT HERE IN COMING WEEKS-
WITHIN THIS BUDGET WE'RE
PROPOSING. TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR FUNDING INCREASE-
THROUGH THE US DOES THE OIL AND
GAS SPECIAL FUND FOR A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY EIGHT NEW POSITIONS
TO BE PHASED IN OVER THREE
YEARS SPECIFICALLY FOCUSED ON
THREE AREAS ONE IS TO EXPAND-
THE FIELD PRESENCE OF CAL JAM
INSPECTORS- WORKING IN A FULL
AND FAIR WAY WITH OUR OIL AND
GAS OPERATORS. TO ENSURE
ENFORCEMENT OF EXISTING LAWS
AND REGULATIONS THE SECOND
IMPORTANTLY IS TO VALIDATE
EXISTING- BONDING REQUIREMENTS
FOR PRIVATE OPERATORS TO REDUCE
OUT YOUR FINANCIAL LIABILITY
FROM THE STATE. AND THE THIRD
IS THE BASICALLY TO PROVIDE
MORE PUBLIC TRANSPARENCY OF CAL
GEMS ACTIVITIES BOTH FOR
INDUSTRY OPERATORS AND FOR
OTHER INTERESTED STAKEHOLDERS.
ANOTHER IMPORTANT AREA OF
INVESTMENT RELATES TO OUR
GROWING PARTNERSHIPS WITH-
CALIFORNIA TRIBES AND WE
INCLUDE IN THIS PROPOSAL-
FUNDING FOR A TRUTH AND HEALING
COUNCIL- WHICH WAS CALLED FOR
IN- GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER
LAST YEAR. I'M ALSO VERY
EXCITED TO PROPOSE FUNDING FOR
A NEW POSITION WITHIN OUR
AGENCY EXECUTIVE TEAM ARE
CALLED ASSISTANT SECRETARY FOR
TRIBAL AFFAIRS. WHAT I'VE WHAT
I'VE LEARNED IN MY FIRST YEAR
PLUS ON THIS JOB IS WE HAVE A
LOT TO LEARN FROM OUR TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA ABOUT
STEWARDING OUR ENVIRONMENT-
THESE PEOPLE'S OF STEWART AT
OUR ENVIRONMENT FOR MILLENNIA.
AND SO WE WANT TO DEEPEN OUR
PARTNERSHIP WITH TRIBES- MOVING
FORWARD ON THE CALL MANAGEMENT
OF NATURAL RESOURCES AND THIS
POSITION WILL BE KEY. LIKEWISE
I'M ALSO EXCITED TO PROPOSE AN
ASSISTANT SECRETARY FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE- THAT
WILL REALLY- SPEAR HAD A AGENCY
WIDE PROGRAM TO ENSURE. EQUITY
ACROSS ALL OF OUR INVESTMENTS
IN PROGRAMS OUR SISTER AGENCY
CALLIE PA IS REALLY A MODEL. OF
THE INSTITUTIONALIZATION OF A
REALLY STRONG ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE POLICY THAT RUNS
THROUGHOUT- THE WORK OF THAT
AGENCY. AND SO WE- SEEK TO
EMULATE THAT TYPE OF PROGRAM
AND IT BEGINS WITH ACTUALLY
HAVING A LEADER AT THE
EXECUTIVE LEVEL TO DRIVE THIS.
SO THAT'S A GLIMPSE- OR A
SNAPSHOT OF OUR HIGH LEVEL
PRIORITIES. AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
THE WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE IN
THE WORK THAT YOU WILL DO TO
HELP US- INSURE THAT WE HAVE AS
EFFECTIVE A BUDGET AS POSSIBLE.
AND CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR I'D BE
GLAD TO ENTERTAIN ANY QUESTIONS
OR THOUGHT THAT YOU HAVE. THANK
OU- I APPRECIATE THE OVERVIEW
A LOT OF- VERY IMPORTANT
UPRIGHT PRIORITIES UP PERSONAL
PRIORITY- THAT YOU DIDN'T HAVE
A CHANCE TO TALK CONDUCT A CAME
UP DURING THE- THE INTERIM WHEN
I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO- TAKE
A SYRUP BUST MEN'S HOLIDAY AND
A TRAVEL ALONG THE COAST FROM-
THE CENTRAL COAST ALL THE WAY
UP TO THE- NORTH COAST BUT- AND
IN ADDITION. AND IN THE- SB THE-
THAT IS SO. COASTAL RESOURCE. I
HAD THE UP TO A TO A NUMBER OF
PARKS. AND YOU. ONE OF THEIR
TOP CA WAS THE DETERIORATION OF
THE KELP FOREST- ALONG THE
COAST AND THIS STRIKES ME AS
BEING A- MAYBE NOT EVEN A SLOW
MOVING A RAPIDLY MOVING TO-
DISASTER IN THE MAKING AND I'M
WONDERING IF- YOU HAVE PLANS TO
ADDRESS THAT IF THE DEPARTMENT
HAS PLANTS YEAH WELL LET ME
FIRST AGREE WITH YOU THIS IS
NOT AN AIR IF CONCERNED THAT A
FULL BLOWN ECOLOGICAL CRISIS.
SO ARE FOR ARE POTENTIALLY LIKE
THE OCEAN THERE BIG- I CON
PLANTS THAT FORM THE FOR OF
THIS OFF SHORE ECOSYSTEM IN RE
YEARS WE'VE LAW 97% OF OUR KELP
FOREST IN THE UPPER HALF OFF
THE UPPER HALF OF OUR STATE.
AND IT HAS TO DO WITH A VARIETY
OF CHANGING CONDITIONS IN OUR
OCEAN INCLUDING OCEAN WARMING-
THAT KILLED OFF AT C. STARTS
SPECIES THAT WAS A PRIMARY
PREDATOR. OF A PURPLE URCHIN.
NOW THIS GETS PRETTY
INTERESTING BECAUSE OUR RED
URCHIN OFF OUR COAST ARE
COMMERCIALLY CAN BE
COMMERCIALIZED AND ARE
HARVESTED. OFFER SALE FOR
SEAFOOD PURPLE URCHIN CANNOT BE
COMMERCIALIZED AND WHEN THOSE
OCEAN CONDITIONS CHANGED AND WE
LOST THE PRIMARY PREDATOR THE
PURPLE URCHINS. THE PURPLE
ORIGINS MOVED IN AND I'VE
CREATED BROAD BEHRENS THAT RUN
FOR HUNDREDS OF MILES AND IT
KILLED OFF OUR KELP FOREST.
HUGE CRISIS GOOD NEWS IS OUR
THANKS TO RESOURCES ALREADY
PROVIDED BY THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE WE ACTUALLY ARE
DOING SOMETHING ABOUT THIS
CRISIS. THROUGH OUR OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL ACTUALLY
THIS MONTH WE APPROVED ARE UP
FOR OF TWO THIRDS OF A MILLION
DOLLARS OR A POT PROGRAM. TO
ADD. BE IN. ARE UNEMPLOYED OUR
DIVERS ON THE DOOR COAST. TO
OUR- THESE PURPLE URCHIN IN.
BUT AREA. AND PARTNER WITH THE
NONPROFIT TO SCIENTIFIC THE
MONITOR HOW THE REMOVAL OF
EARTH AND- I COOLEY PERFORM IN
THE- BRINGING BACK OUR SEEK
HELP. CHALLENGE CHAIR WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT ANSWER IS WE HAVE
SOME VERY CANCER AROUND HOW TO
BRING BACK THE THAT THE KELP
FORESTS BUT- WE ARE FOCUSED
RIGHT NOW I'M GETTING IN THE
WATER. REMOVING THESE IN
CERTAIN AREAS AND THEN LEARNING
FROM THAT I THINK IF THERE WAS
AN AREA WHERE THE LEGISLATURE
COULD BE HELPFUL IT WOULD BE TO
IDENTIFY POTENTIALLY RESOURCES
TO EXPAND THAT WORK. HI INDOOR
TO BRING TOGETHER A OR AN
ACADEMIC COUNSELOR AN ACADEMIC-
ADVISORY BODY OF THE BEST
SCIENTISTS FROM ACROSS THE
WORLD TO REALLY INFORM US HOW
WE REVERSE THIS CRISIS. WE ARE
OFTEN I THINK. ABOUT AN ADDRESS
THE HEALTH OF OUR LAND BASE FOR
US- BUT WE DON'T THINK MUCH
ABOUT THE- THE FORCE THAT LIES
BENEATH THE SURFACE OF THE- OF
THE OCEAN- CAN YOU REMIND US.
OF WHY THE CAL FORCES
IMPORTANT. YEAH I MEAN IT'S
FUNDAMENTAL IF ANYONE'S BEEN OF
THE MONTEREY BAY AQUARIUM YOU
KNOW YOU KNOW THESE ARE THESE
THESE BIG TALL PLANTS THAT
REALLY GO UP TO THE SURFACE IT
WOULD BE LIKE LOSING. THE
REDWOOD FOREST ON OUR COAST AND
A NEW TING THAT AND INSTEAD OF
LOOKING UP AND SEEING THESE
THESE BIG ICONIC TREES YOU SEE
NOTHING- THAT'S REALLY WHAT IT
IS RIGHT NOW OFF OUR COAST IT
IS BEARING. AND WHAT THAT MEANS
IS ALL OF THOSE ANIMALS THAT
EXIST IN THAT FOR IT ARE GONE
IMAGINE. THE ENEMY YEAH WE'RE
ANIMALS LIVE IF YOU COMPLETELY
LOST A FOR AND IT DENUDED. SO
THE CHILD IT'S IN A- CRISIS
THAT'S YOU SAY SO NOT A LOT OF
CALIFORNIA X. THAT. BUT THOSE
WHO DO KNOW THE IMPORTANCE OF
THIS CRISIS. OF THANK YOU FOR
HELPING ME DRAW A LITTLE BIT OF
ATTENTION TO THAT IMPORTANT
ISSUE TO DID YOU SEE. THAT THE
AMOUNT OF FUNDING. FOR THE YOUR
CHIN PROJECT WAS. A MILLION
DOLLARS YES. OKAY SO YOU KNOW
VERY OPEN TO AUG THAT IN POINT
THOUGH YOU KNOW WE DON'T IF
WHAT WORKS AND SO. THEY IS AN
APPROACH INSTANCE AND WE OUR
PILOTS ARE PERFORMED FAIRLY
SMALL SCALE PILOTS WHERE WITHIN
A PLOT WERE READING YOU KNOW
PAYING PAYING DIVERSE TO REMOVE
THE URGENT BUT THEN
UNDERSTANDING WHETHER THEY COME
BACK. HE QUICKLY OR WHETHER IT
IS ACTUALLY EFFECTIVE TOWARDS
REBUILDING THE KELP FORESTS AND
WHAT I WOULD SAY IS BEFORE WE
INVEST- YOU KNOW. SIZEABLE A
SCALED UP RESOURCES IN THAT WE
HAVE TO UNDERSTAND WHAT WORKS.
INDEED OF THE OTHER- ISSUE I
WANTED TO ASK YOU ABOUT- A IS
ONE THAT'S BEEN IN THE NEWS
LATELY AND THAT HAS TO DO WITH
THE- A CONTINUING STRING. THEM
OUTLINED POPULATION- A IN MY
DISTRICT AND IN OTHER PLACES
AROUND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
CAN YOU- ADDRESS THAT YEAH LOS
ANGELES AND BOM BOM MUMBAI
INDIA HAVE THE DISTINCTION OF
BEING THE LARGEST METROPOLITAN
AREAS IN THE WORLD IN WHICH
PEOPLE ARE CO EXISTING WITH AN
APEX PREDATOR. IN MUMBAI IT'S
AT BENGAL TIGER IN GREATER LOS
ANGELES IT'S ONLINE AND IT'S
REMARKABLE YOU ALWAYS HAVE
INTERESTING. DATA POINTS- TO IT
TO ME IF YOU KNOW OUR ABILITY
TO THESE MOUNTAIN LIONS IN THIS
ANIMAL MY AND IN THE IN THE
MOUNTAINS AROUND LOS ANGELES IS
ISRAEL TEST I CAN WE CONTINUE
TO GROW AS A AT THE FORTY
MILLION PEOPLE AND PROTECT OUR
BY. THESE MOUNTAIN LIONS AS YOU
KNOW CHAIR IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ARE THREATENED I'M
BY L. GENETIC WALL AND OTHER
LOW AND THIS THE AND THE LOSS
OF. SO WE HAVE THESE POP THAT
ARE- THAT HAVE SOME GENETIC
DISTINCTION AND IF THEY CAN'T
ACTUALLY HAVE A LARGE ENOUGH
HABITAT AND MAINTAIN IT DIVERT
BE THROUGH MEETING THE FROM
OUTLAW THAN ULTIMATELY I.
THREAT GLAD TO REPORT THAT OUR
DEPARTMENT OF FISH WILDLIFE IS
CONSIDERED A PETITION TO LAST-
THIS OP POPULATION MOUNTAIN
LIONS IN SOUTHERN. UNDER
CALIFORNIA ENDANGERED SPECIES
ACT AS A GENETICALLY DISTINCT
SUBSPECIES OF MOUNTAIN LION
THAT WILL BE A SCIENCE BASED
DECISION MAKING PROCESS BUT WE
CAMPUS PRINCE PRESUME WHAT WILL
HAPPEN THERE BUT IT IS BEING
CONSIDERED BY THE DEPARTMENT OR
THE CAT FOOD FISHING GAME
COMMISSION. THIS SPRING. BUT
ALSO IN TO FOCUS ON THREE AREAS
OUT OF NOT LIONS AND CALIFORNIA
THAT FIRST DEAF. PERMITS AND
BEEN WORKING CLOSELY THE RECTOR
BONHAM TO REALLY UNDERSTAND HOW
DEPREDATION PERMITS WHICH IS
THE PERMISSION TO KILL A
PREDATOR THAT'S- KILLING
LIVESTOCK ETCETERA. HOW THOSE
ARE TRULY THE LAST RESORT AND
HOW WE AS A STATE CAN DO MORE.
TO AVOID THAT THE NEED TO ISSUE
THOSE DEPREDATION PERMITS
NUMBER ONE THE SECOND IS
RODENTICIDE WHICH IS AN ISSUE
YOU'VE LET ON I WHICH IS A LOT
OF OUR HOUSEHOLD- POISONS TO
KILL OFF ROUTE THAT CETERA. ARE
FINDING THEIR WAY INTO THE FOOD
SOURCES OF THESE OP OF THESE
MOUNTAIN LIONS AND SO OBVIOUSLY
WE COULD TALK MORE ABOUT WHAT
NEEDS TO HAPPEN BUT IT'S
PARTNERING- ARE- AGENCIES WITH
YOUR LEADERSHIP TO ACTUALLY.
REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF IDENTIFIED
THAT GET IN THE WILD POPULATION
AND THEN THE THIRD. IS TRAFFIC
A MAJOR- MORTALITY THREAT FOR
THESE MOUNTAIN LIONS IS HIGHWAY
ONE A NE WE'RE REALLY EXCITED
WITH THIS OVER PASS THAT'S
BEING CONSTRUCTED OVER HIGHWAY
ONE A ONE WHICH WILL PROVIDE
RECREATIONAL ACCESS BUT ALSO
LINK THAT TO HABITATS OF THESE
MOUNTAIN LION POPULATIONS. BUT
CHAIR WEEK WE CAN DO MORE TO
ACTUALLY PROTECT- THE LAND ARE
JOINING OR THAT'S CONNECTED BY
THAT OVER PASS I'M SO THERE MAY
BE OPPORTUNITIES TO EXT AND-
OUR OUR OUR- NATURE PRESERVES-
IN. THAT SORT OF NORTH. AREA OF
THIS ABOUT A IN ORDER TO.
REALLY IN THAT. CROSSING TO
BRING TO HELP BRING BACK THE
POPULATION. THANK YOU- I
APPRECIATE YOUR OPTIMISM ON THE
WILDLIFE OVER PASSED TO- SAID
THAT IT'S BEING CONSTRUCTED
WELL IT'S NOT QUITE UNDER
CONSTRUCTION SORRY BUT IF THE
PLANET THAT OPTIMISM WILL HELP
US GET THERE YEAH. WELL I SAY
THIS WHERE WE KNOW WE IN THE
GOV ROUTE YOU KNOW HIM REAL
WANNA. THAT THAT OVER ACROSS
HAPPEN AND HE ACTUALLY. THE
SITE LAST YEAR AND THIS HAS
BEEN A PARTNERSHIP OF THE STATE
WITH PHILANTHROPIC LEADERS AND
I KNOW THE ONE AREA OF FOCUS IS
REALLY ENSURING THAT WE CAN GET
THAT PHILANTHROPIC MATCH- BUT
WE STAND READY TO DO ALL THAT
WE CAN TO ACTUALLY- HELP THAT.
MATERIALIZE WELL LET'S- DO SOME
GOOD WORK TOGETHER ON ALL OF
THE OF THE BULLET POINTS THAT
YOU'VE IDENTIFIED FOR US AND
LET ME CALL NOW ON MISTER FUNK
A AND IF THE REST OF YOU HAVE
QUESTIONS IT. WILL TAKE THOSE
TWO I THINK IT WAS A OF BEING
EVERY DON'T WANT WHILE TO ALL
THE MEMBERS IF IN SINCE BE AN-
MORE. JGB HERE NEW HAVE A
HEADACHE SENSE OF CALM. ABOUT I
GUESS. CAL GAGA JIM NOW. YOU
KNOW YOUR VIEW OF THIS NEW. AT
THE HUNDRED TWENTY NEW
POSITIONS THAT YOU. THAT YOU'RE
REQUESTING A THAT DID. RICK A
YOU. WE HAD X. COVER. ABOUT THE
PERMIT BACK THAT IS A- THAT. I
BELIEVE IS STIFLING. THE OF
ENERGY BUT- AND OUR STATE. DO
ANY OF A- THE HARD WAY NEW
POSITION. DO OF IT ADDRESS THE
BACK. THE GOOD. LET ME ANSWER
DIRECTLY LET ME JUST GIVE A
LITTLE CON. WE IS THAT YOU
WE'VE BEEN. WE'VE BEEN CLEAR
THAT. AS WE IMPROVE REGULATORY
OVERSIGHT WE NEED TO PROVIDE
SORT OF FULL AND FAIR OVERSIGHT
WHICH MEANS HAVING A CLEAR
LINES OF COMMUNICATION WITH
INDUSTRY OPERATORS- WHICH WE
DO- AND WE LEARN FROM INDUSTRY
OPERATORS THAT THEY REALLY.
DESIRE TWO THINGS- ONE IS
CLARITY ON THE RULES THAT
GOVERN THEIR OPERATIONS AND THE
SECOND IS CERTAINTY- AS
BUSINESSES THEY NEED TO PLAN
AND REALLY NEED TO UNDERSTAND-
WHAT IT YOU KNOW WHAT TIME
LINES ARE REQUIRED IN
PERMITTING AN OVERSIGHT. SO
WE'VE BEEN WORKING TO ONE BE
VERY CLEAR- AROUND THE
OVERSIGHT WE NEED TO PROVIDE
AND THEN TO BUILD CERTAINTY SO
THAT AT LEAST THERE'S AN
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT'S WHAT'S
HAPPENED. THERE ARE A COUPLE OF
AREAS ARE COUPLE TYPES OF
PERMITS- THAT HAVE SLOWED DOWN
RECENTLY. ONE IS HYDRAULIC
FRACTURING PERMITS- AND THE
OTHER IS PERMITS RELATED TO A
PRACTICE CALLED I HIGH PRESSURE
STEAM INJECTIONS. EACH HAS A
DIFFERENT REASON FOR BEING- FOR
SLOWING DOWN- THE FIRST
HYDRAULIC FRACTURING. ARE
UNDERGOING PERMIT BY PERMIT
REVIEWS BY AN INDEPENDENT-
OUTSIDE ENTITY LAWRENCE
LIVERMORE NATIONAL LABS WHILE-
THE THAT PERMITTING PROCESS-
RECEIVES AN AUDIT FROM THE
OFFICE OF STATE AUDITS AND
EVALUATIONS. THIS WAS IN
RESPONSE TO CONCERNS LAST
SUMMER ABOUT- CAL GEMS
PERMITTING PROCESS FROM WHERE
WE SET WE NEED TO BUILD PUBLIC
CONFIDENCE OF THAT THE
PERMITTING PROCESS THAT CAL JAM
HAS IN PLACE. IS FULLY
ADEQUATE- TOWARD PROTECTING-
YOU DON'T ALL THAT WE NEED TO
PROTECT WHEN GIVING A PERMIT.
THE SECOND IS- THAT OTHER
PRACTICEHIGH PRESSURE STEAM
INJECTIONS. AND THAT. WE WILL
CONTINUE WAS RAISED ABOUT THE
SO CALLED SURFACE EXPRESSION
FOR THESE OIL LEAKS AT THE
SURFACE OVER THE SUMMER AND THE
CORRELATION BETWEEN THAT
PRACTICE AND THOSE OIL LEAKS.
SO WHAT WE WHAT WE ARE CALTRAIN
ANNOUNCED IN NOVEMBER WAS-
PLACING A MORATORIUM
SPECIFICALLY ON THAT PRACTICE
UNTIL A STUDY IS COMPLETED TO
REALLY UNDERSTAND THE
CORRELATION OF THAT PRACTICE TO
BE SURFACE EXPRESSIONS. SO IN
CASES THAT'S BEEN A POINT
STRAIGHT XIN FOR THE INDUSTRY
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT SEEING
PERMITS COME THROUGH. AND WE'VE
BEEN VERY CLEAR WITH THEM THAT
THIS INDEPENDENT REVIEW IS
TAKING PLACE AND WE DO
ANTICIPATE IT ACTUALLY MOVING
FORWARD AND ENABLING PERMITS TO
BE ISSUED- AS IT RELATES TO THE
HYDRAULIC FRACTURING AND THEN
AS IT RELATES TO THE MORATORIUM
THE HIGH PRESSURE STEAM
PRACTICE- WE NEED TO ENSURE
THAT LAWRENCE LIVERMORE. AND
CAL JIM CAN ACTUALLY PARTNER ON
THAT STUDY WHICH WE ANTICIPATE
pIN THAT THAT STUDY IS POISED TO
BEGIN WITH AND APART THE
FEDERAL DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY
APPROVED A CONTRACT FOR
LAWRENCE LIVERMORE. I'M IN SO
WE ANTICIPATE THAT CONTRACT TO
BE. PROVED ANY DATE NOW. SO IN
DIRECT ANSWER TO QUESTION THESE
ARE ONE AND TWENTY EIGHT
POSITIONS DON'T FOCUS ON YEAH I
INCREASING SPEED OF PERMITTING
THEY- FOCUS ON ONE HAVING OUT
MORE INSPECTORS IN THE FIELD TO
WIN. YES ACTIVITY WITH THE OF
INDUSTRY OPERATORS RIGHT NOW
ARE WITNESSING RATES ARE LOWER
THAN THEY NEED TO BE- I THINK
YOU'LL IT WHEN YOU ASKED
INDUSTRY OPERATORS THEY'LL TELL
YOU THAT IT'S ACTUALLY. CAN BE
CONSTRUCTIVE AND HELPFUL TO
HAVE. A CAL JIM EMPLOYEE WITH
THEM- TOO AGAIN SOME EYES
CLARITY IN COMMUNICATION SO
THAT THAT'S NUMBER ONE. NUMBER
TWO IS ACTUALLY INCREASED
NUMBER PEOPLE SPECIFIC FOCUSED
ON THAT I'VE FOUGHT WHAT ARE
THE BONDING. THAT THESE
OPERATORS NEED IN OTHER WORDS
WHAT MONEY DO THEY NEED TO PUT
UP TO ENSURE THE STATE DOESN'T
GET LEFT WITH THE BILL. IF THEY
ULTIMATELY I GO OUT OF BUSINESS
OR- OR SHUT DOWN. THAT SECOND
AND THEN THE THIRD IS. OF
MODEST INVEST AND MORE P. TO
ACTUALLY COME. ARE THE ACTIONS
THAT CAL GEMMA'S TAKING BOTH TO
THE OPERATORS THE INDUSTRY AS
WELL AS STAKEHOLDERS WE HAVE A
REALLY POWERFUL INFORMATION
SYSTEM WITHIN CAL JAM CALLED
THE WELL STARK PERMIT TRACKING
SYSTEM AND IT DOES PROVIDE
INFORMATION ON PERMITS TO
OPERATORS AND- ON THE PUBLIC
BUT WE NEED- WE NEED TO-
SLIGHTLY LARGER INVESTMENTS TO
ACTUALLY TRANSLATE THAT. VERY
POWERFUL INFORMATION SYSTEM IN
TWO. INFORMATION THAT WERE
REGULAR PEOPLE CAN UNDERSTAND.
SO I'VE I SO I UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE THERE IS A BALANCE AND
I'D I'D BEEN IN THE WITNESS-
WITNESSING OF THE OPERATIONS I
GUESS MY CONCERN IS THAT BUT
THAT WHILE ALL THESE THINGS ARE
HAPPENING WE'VE CREATED A DE
FACTO MORATORIUM OF PRODUCTION
IN IN THE CITY CALIFORNIA AT A
TIME WHEN OUR ENERGY NEEDS ARE
GROWING AND WE PROBABLY DO NEED
TO PRODUCE- MORE- MORE ENERGY
SO YOU ARE THE DEMANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS DON'T GO AWAY. AND
SO AS SO THE ONLY THING LEFT
FOR CALIFORNIA IS TO IMPORT OIL
FROM OVERSEAS AND SO IF WE
DON'T PRODUCE OIL IN CALIFORNIA
BY CALIFORNIANS AND WE HAVE NO
CHOICE AS AS AS POLICY MAKERS
TO FIGURE OUT A WAY HOW DO WE
MAKE UP THAT DIFFERENCE AND
RIGHT NOW THE ONLY WAY WE'RE
GONNA SATISFIED THE ENERGY
DEMANDS OF CALIFORNIA. IF WE
DON'T PRODUCE IN CALIFORNIA IS
SAID TO IT TO IMPORTED SO. IS
THERE A RECOGNITION THAT THAT
THE PERMIT BACKLOG. IS A
TREMENDOUS CHALLENGE AND IN
SOME WAYS IS THERE ANY
DIRECTION THAT YOU'RE GIVING TO
ADDRESS. TORY I'M ON PRODUCTION
IN CALIFORNIA AND THERE'S NO
DOUBT AND I DON'T SAY THAT I
WANT TO SAY THAT THAT. THE
AFFECT IS A DE FACTO ME NO MORE
TRADE WE CANNOT GET IF WE CAN'T
GET PERMITS WELL I THINK IT.
YOU KNOW I THINK IT WOULD BE
HELPFUL TO SIT DOWN AND SORT OF
WORK THROUGH THE NUMBERS- WITH
YOUR OFFICE AND OTHER THAT ARE
INTERESTED BECAUSE- WE'VE WE'VE
IDENTIFIED A WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
TO VERY SPECIFIC PERMITS FOR
HYDRAULIC FRACTURING IN FOR A-
FOR A VERY SPECIFIED IN SECTION
PRACTICE. WHAT YOU'LL NOTICE
THERE YOU GO IF YOU IF YOU. AT
DACHAU GEMS WEBSITE WHICH
PROVIDES MONTHLY DATA ON
PERMITTING IS PERMITTED FOR
EXAMPLE ON. THE WELLS NEW WELL
WITHIN EXISTING FIELD ON A
REVIEW. OR ABANDONED INS ARE
CONTINUING- SO I CAN UNDERSTAND
THAT THE INDUSTRY IS FRUSTRATED
ABOUT THESE ASPECTS OR THESE
THESE TYPES OF PERMITS BUT I
WANT TO JUST BE CLEAR BECAUSE-
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME. IN THE
MEDIA THAT. WHILE WE'RE FOCUSED
ON IN. OVERSIGHT IN THOSE.
AREAS THAT THAT PERMITTED IN
THE PERMITTING PROCESS-
CONTINUES I IN THOSE. AREAS BUT
LET ME JUST BE CLEAR THAT AGAIN
IN A WORLD WE WANT TO THE OF.
ALL AND THERE ARE. REGULATORY
OVERSIGHT BY. AND IN FACT. ARE
INS ARM PROVIDE AS MUCH CERTAIN
THE AT CAN AROUND THE TIME
FRAME. FOR YOU HAVE MIGHT HAVE
MEANT THAT WE KNOW. IN OUR- THE-
IS THAT WE'RE THING OUT ONE GUY.
I'M I DO WANT WANT TO HELP
OPERATE I'M THE TO UNDERSTAND
AND HAVE. OTHER RELATES TO OUR
PROCESS AND AVOID THAT
SITUATION AND WHERE THEY GREAT
ON SIR WHY AT AS WAS ACT YOU
BEING THERE TO- TO ANSWER MY
QUESTIONS AND TO WORK THROUGH
THESE ISSUES AND I WANT TO
PARTNER WITH YOU ON THAT AND I
CERTAINLY AGREE WITH YOU THAT
CERTAINTY IN THE IS WE NEED TO.
ADDRESS IS IT TOO AND SO WE CAN
CREATE A FRAMEWORK THAT ALLOWS-
YOU KNOW RESPONSIBLE FOR
PERMITS TO MOVE FORWARD I THAT
I THINK THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR AND I THINK THAT
WOULD BE THE BEST THING FOR
CALIFORNIA SO I APPRECIATE YOU
BEING HERE AND ANSWERING THE
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU LOOK FOR
TO WORKING TOGETHER.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RIVAS THANK YOU
SECRETARY CROW FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION- I JUST HAVE A FEW
COMMENTS I'M MOST EXCITED BY-
YOUR AXIS INEQUITY INITIATIVES-
YOU KNOW YOUR- YOU KNOW MAKING
SURE THAT STATE PARKS ARE
ACCESSIBLE TO ALL THAT
SOMETHING THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT
TO ME YOU KNOW I'M FROM LOS
ANGELES- WE NEED ACCESS TO
PARKS ESPECIALLY OUR STATE
PARKS AND A LOT OF TIMES IT'S
TRANSPORTATION- SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING MORE ABOUT
THE OUTDOOR EQUITY PROGRAM AND
OTHER THINGS THAT YOU'RE
WORKING ON. IN THAT AREA- AND
ALSO- THE ELEVATION OF
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE IN YOUR
AGENCY WITH THIS NEW EXECUTIVE
LEVEL POSITION I ALSO LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING WHAT THIS
PERSON WILL DO AND I HOPE
EVERYTHING YOU IN YOUR AGENCY
YOU'RE LOOKING AT AND ACCESS
ADEQUATE PLAN. FOR EVERY
PROGRAM THERE IS IN YOUR E. SO
THANK THANK YOU TO QUIT COMMA
ONE IS AYE AYE I SHOULD
RECOGNIZE PARTNER JENNIFER
SIEBEL NEWSOM AS A REAL DRIVER
OF THIS ACCESS THAT INTO I AND
SHE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY IN LAS
CLASS TO REALLY ALRP THIS
PRIORITY TO THE
ADMINISTRATION'S YOU YOU'LL
HEAR MORE IN SHE'S GOT QUITE A
STRONG PARTNER US AT THE AGENCY
AND IN SACKS OF THE JACK. AND
THAT'S IT REALLY THE
ENVIRONMENT JUSTICE PROGRAM
IMPORTANT A POINT THAT WHAT
WE'RE NOT GOING TO DO IS HIRE
SOME THE AND CREATE AN
ENVIRONMENT OF THIS PROGRAM
INTO. WITHOUT BLOCK GAUGE I
WITHIN POLDERS OUR GOAL IS TO
BUILD A REALLY STRONG BROAD E.
J. PROGRAM ACROSS OUR IN THE
NEXT YEAR THE ONE PERSON CA ON
BOARD WITH A WHOLE LOT OF PUT
FROM COMMUNITY GROUPS OKAY
THANK YOU. THIS GARCIA. BUT
THANK YOU HEALTH ON A MY
COLLEAGUES COME ON THE EACH
EIGHT PIECE- IT AND THE NEED
FOR OPEN SPACE AND PARKS IN MY
DISTRICT AND EXCITED ABOUT THE
WORK WE'VE BEEN DOING IN THE
EXAM AND ABOUT THE WALKWAYS
ACROSS PLACE FOR OUR WILD LIFE-
AND IN PLACES LIKE OUR
MOUNTAINS- I HAVE AREAS THAT
WHERE CONSTITUENTS HAVE A HARD
TIME CROSSING OVER TO PLACES
LIKE THAT EVER BAD YEAH HI ANN
ARBOR BECAUSE WE HAVE TO CROSS
MULTIPLE FREEWAY ENTRANCES
SINCE I HOPE WE- RIGHT SIZE
THOSE WALKWAY SYSTEMS AS WE'RE
DOING. SELECT WE SHOULD NOT
SEEN ONE OR THE OTHER BUT
EQUALLY IMPORTANT. YEAH AND I
THINK I MET SAID AS THE YOU
COME IN BUT WE'RE REALLY.
EXCITED TO PARTNER WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ON DEVELOPING A
CLIMATE RESILIENCE BOND
POTENTIALLY FOR CONSIDERATION
IN NOVEMBER AND YOU'VE BEEN A
REALLY ACT CLEAR STRONG
ADVOCATE OF ENSURING THAT.
WHILE OUR INVESTMENTS DO YOU
HAVE TO PROTECT NATURE AND
THAT'S IMPORTANT THEY NEED TO
ALSO GET INTO COMMUNITIES THAT
REALLY LACKED THAT ACCESS- TO
HELP SORT OF BRING NATURE TO
COMMUNITIES TO. CERTAINLY
MISTER PATTERSON. ARE YOU ARE
YOU FAMILIAR WITH THE-
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY- ECONOMIC ANALYSIS OF
THE WATER POLICY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND ITS EFFECT ON
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA I SURE AM
AND THAT KIND OF MIST- WAS ABLE
TO BRIEF MYSELF AND GOVERNOR
NEW SOME AND THAT AND A HIGH
LEVEL CABINET GROUP- UP. ON THE
STUDY ABOUT A MONTH AGO. HOW
WOULD YOU CHARACTERIZE THE
RESULT OF THAT STUDY. I'M
LOOKING FOR AN ADJECTIVE HERE
YEAH. WELL I WOULD SAY. I'M I'M
TRYING TO HONOR YOUR REQUEST
FOR ONE ADDITIVE. HOW BOUT
CATASTROPHIC. THAT COULD BE ONE
I WOULD SAY TROUBLING- AND I'LL
TELL YOU WHY SO. WE UNDERSTAND
THAT- WATER RELIABILITY IS ALL
IT IS THE LIFE BLOOD THE
AGRICULTURE AND AGRICULTURE IS
THE LIFEBLOOD OF THE CENTRAL
VALLEY SO THEREFORE- WATER
SUPPLY WATER RELIABILITY IS
CRITICAL THE ECONOMIC VITALITY
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY. AND MY
INTERPRETATION OF THAT STUDY IS
IT IDENTIFIED- SIGNIFICANT
IMPACTS- TO THAT WATER SUPPLY-
BOTH PRESENT AND- AND SORT OF
POTENTIAL IN THE FUTURE- WHICH
ONE WOULD YOU AGREE THAT THOSE
ARE POLICY. CONSEQUENCES IN
OTHER WORDS PEOPLE ARE MAKING
THE DECISIONS THAT ARE
CREATING. THE PROBLEM. ARM WELL
I WOULD SAY THAT THOSE
DECISIONS STARTED YOU KNOW IN
YOU KNOW. WHAT LOOK I DON'T I'M
NOT GOOD. I WOULD SAY THAT WELL
PART OF. WHAT IS DRIVING THOUGH
IT THAT IMPACT HAS BEEN THE
DECADE- DEPLETION OF OUR
GROUNDWATER AQUIFERS AND THE
BROAD NEED THAT WE ALL
RECOGNIZE TO BRING THOSE
AQUIFERS BACK INTO BALANCE. I
THINK- EVERYONE FROM
CONGRESSMAN COST ON DOWN HAS
HAS INDICATED THAT.
IMPLEMENTING SIGMA IS
ULTIMATELY IMPORTANT TO
SECURING THOSE WATER SUPPLIES
FOR FUTURE GENERATIONS OF
FARMERS AND WE NEED TO DO THAT.
BUT WE RECOGNIZE THAT THAT HAS
REAL ECONOMIC IMPACT INCLUDING-
FOLLOWING- IN IN LITTLE
PORTIONS OF THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY. AND IT'S WHY- THE STATE
HAS INVESTED AT THIS POINT
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
INTO SUPPORTING LOCAL
COMMUNITIES BUILDING THEIR OWN
PLANS TO MANAGE THOSE
GROUNDWATER BASINS. OB AND THEN
SUPPORTING IMPLEMENTATION OF
THOSE PLANS IT'S WHY WE
RECOMMEND SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS
A ONE TIME GENERAL FUND INTO
THIS BUDGET THAT CAN GET BACK
INTO THOSE COMMUNITIES VERY
QUICKLY TO IMPLEMENT CIGNA.
ALSO I RECOMMEND THAT FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN A
NOVEMBER OBLIGATION BOND
DEDICATED TO SEGMENT
IMPLEMENTATION GET INTO
COMMUNITY. SO NUMBER ONE IS
ABSOLUTELY THAT THE- BRINGING
GROUND WATER BASE THEN THE
BALANCE WILL HAVE YOU CAN MAKE.
IT IMPACTS. AND YET THAT WAS A
POLICY DECISION ALL I THINK
APOLLO DECISION THAT EVERYONE
RECOGNIZES. WHICH IS TOP WATER
FOR SENT COMMUNITY FOR DECADES
TO COME. SEC AREA OF. COPPER
THAT IS IN IS THAT LEAST AS
WITH WHAT WHY. AND HOW DO WE
BALANCE. THE NEED TO OF THE
EXTINCTION OF OUR SAN AND WHY
MAX. WATER SUPPLY REAL
RELIABILITY FOR THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. AND THAT'S WHY ARE OUR
ADMINISTRATION HAS INVESTED A
LOT OF TIME AND ENERGY IN THE
LAST YEAR ON DEVELOPING THE SO
CALLED VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS.
THAT MEET STATE AND FEDERAL
LAWS TO IMPROVE ENVIRONMENTAL
CONDITIONS TO ALLOW THOSE FISH
TO SURVIVE BUT IN WAYS THAT
ACTUALLY WORK WITH WATER
AGENCIES- IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
AND OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE.
TO REDUCE UNCERTAINTY OF WATER
SUPPLY. SO I CAN TELL YOU THAT
pANXIETY AND THE CONCERN ABOUT
THE WATER SUPPLY RELY
ABILITIES- ISSUE COULD YOU KNOW
IT IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY. AND
I'M FOCUSED MYSELF PERSONALLY
THROUGH THE JOB ON TRYING TO
REDUCE THAT THAT WATER BY
RELIABILITY. WE HAVE TO BALANCE
AND GOVERNOR NEWS HIMSELF HAS
BEEN VERY CLEAR ABOUT THE NEED
BALLOT. OUR WATER SUPPLY I
POLICY NOT LEAVE CENTRAL VALLEY
BEHIND. I'M. YOU MUST OF READ A
DIFFERENT REPORT THAN I DID.
THE BASIC FUNDAMENTAL ANALYSIS
HERE IS BASED ON WHAT CAN ONLY
BE DESCRIBED AS A SCHIZOPHRENIC
POLICY ON THE ONE HAND THE
STATE IS SAYING IF YOU PUMP THE
WATER OUT YOU'VE GOT TO PUT IT
BACK. AND OUT OF THE OTHER.
SIDE OF THEIR MOUTH THEY'RE
SAYING WE'RE GOING TO REDUCE
SUBSTANTIALLY AND SIGNIFICANTLY
THE SURFACE WATER THAT IS
NECESSARY. TO PUT THE WATER
BACK IN THE UNDERGROUND AT
THAT'S NUMBER ONE THAT'S THE
FUNDAMENTAL CORE POLICY THAT AS
ANALYSIS AT AT THE HEART OF
THIS THAT. THE IDEA THAT YOU'VE
GOT TO PUT THE WATER BACK BUT
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GIVE YOU
ENOUGH WATER TO PUT IT BACK.
ARE ARE YOU NOT CONCERNED THAT
THE CONCLUSIONS OF THIS FROM
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY. THAT A MILLION ACRE
FEET WILL FALLOW. THAT
SOMETHING LIKE SIXTY FIVE
THOUSAND JOBS WILL DISAPPEAR
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF
CROP VALUE. HALF HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS WORTH OF LOST TAX
REVENUE THAT THERE'S A REAL
POTENTIAL FOR THE- AND
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE IN CERTAIN
AREAS OF THE OF OUR- CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA. TO DOUBLE AND WITH
RESPECT TO THE. IN OTHER
COMMUNITIES THE AND THE
INDIVIDUALS HURT BY THIS THE
MOST I'M SURE YOU SAW THAT THIS
IS A HIGHLY REGRESSIVE.
CONSEQUENCE IN OTHER WORDS THE
POOR ARE HURT MORE THAN ANYBODY
ELSE. AND THAT THE COMMUNITIES
THE PLACES THAT THESE ARE HURT
THE MOST ARE THOSE WHO NEED THE
CLEAN WATER WHO NEED THE FLOWS
TO GET. INTO THE UNDERGROUND
RIGHT. LOOK WE ALL UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE'S GOING TO BE SOME
FOLLOWING. WHAT WE'RE SAYING IS
PLEASE WILL YOU LISTEN TO US A
MILLION ACRE FEET IS UTTERLY
CATASTROPHIC. WE'VE GOT TO HAVE
THE GOVERNOR ENGAGED. AND HE'S
BASICALLY GONNA HAVE TO SAY. I
SERIOUSLY CARE ABOUT CENTER
CALIFORNIA AND I'M GOING TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT HE HAS TO
ENGAGE IN MANAGING YOUR VERY
BUREAUCRACY BECAUSE IF YOU
CONTINUE DOWN THIS PATH
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY SAID YOU'RE GONNA BE
RESPONSIBLE. FOR A MILLION
ACRES BALLOT NOW YOU THINK WE
COULD GET TO A COUPLE HUNDRED
THOUSAND FALLOW. IT IS ANYBODY
HAVING A SERIOUS CONVERSATION
WITH US ABOUT WHAT IT IS NOT
THAT NOT WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO
SAY ABOUT IT. BUT WHAT YOU ARE
GOING TO DO. TO TURN THAT ARC
AROUND FROM A MILLION ACRE FEET
DRIVE IT DOWN TO SOMETHING.
THAT WE CAN LIVE WITH AND I
REMIND EVERYBODY HERE THIS
HURTS THOSE MOST VULNERABLE THE
MOST AND THAT'S THE STUDY. AND
I HAD HOUR LIMIT KEEP YOUR
ANSWER YEAH RELATIVELY
CONSTRAINT YEAH WE DON'T HAVE
TIME THIS MORNING ONLY FULL
HEARING ON THIS ON THIS ISSUE
AND IT DOES COME UP LATER IN
THE BUDGET. YEAH LET ME JUST
SAY I REGISTER YOU KNOW YOUR
INTENSITY. I ON THIS FOR WHAT
IT'S WORTH. YOU KNOW I BELIEVE
THAT I AND WE SHARE THE
INTENSITY AND WERE REALLY
FOCUSED ON CONSTRUCTIVE
SOLUTIONS SO FOR EXAMPLE AS IT
RELATES TO THE AMOUNT OF LAND
THAT FOLLOWED. I HAVE READ
EVERY WORD OF THE PUBLIC POLICY
INSTITUTE OF CALIFORNIA STUDY
ON THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY THAT
WOULD BE ISSUED OVER A YEAR AND
A HALF AGO. IDENTIFIES A
SIGNIFICANT DELTA. MOUNT A LAND
THAT NEEDS TO BE. BASED ON- IF
THE STATE CAN SUPPORT LOCAL
AGENCIES DOING A FEW THINGS SO
THOSE FEW THINGS ARE WHAT WE'RE
PROPOSING TO FIND. IN THIS ONE
TIME I- INVESTMENT OF GENERAL
FUND THIS YEAR. SO I WOULD I
WOULD LOVE TO SIT DOWN WITH
YOUR STAFF AND GET INTO THE
WEEDS A LITTLE BIT MORE. AND I
CAN TELL YOU WE ARE VERY
FOCUSED ON ADDRESSING THIS
ISSUE. WE'RE NOT GOING TO GET
INTO A IS THE P. PICK ACCURATE
AND IS THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA ACCURATE. YOU TO GO
BACK AND TAKE A LOOK AT THE
TWENTY FOURTEEN DATA WHAT HE
PUT DOWN HIS CREDENTIALS. AND
HE'S PAYING A MILLION ACRE
FIAT. TO GET INTO AN ARGUMENT
WELL IT'S NOT REALLY A MILLION
ACRES SIR WELL JUST LET US LET
US. SAY AND WHEN I AM TOLD FIND
IT WORK WITH YOU CONSTRUCTIVELY
DETERMINES THE ONLY TIME I CAN
GET IN FRONT OF PEOPLE LIKE
THIS THEY DON'T GO TO MY OFFICE
TO GO TO YOUR- OFFICE. THEY
DON'T RESPOND THE WAY THEY
RESPOND TO YOU. WILL AND SO
THERE I THE ONLY TIME I HAVE TO
BE ABLE TO DO THIS. I HAVE A
JUNIOR SAY LOOK WHAT DO IN
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA YOU'VE GOT
TO BE WILLING TO SAY WE'RE
GOING TO STEP BACK ON THE SIGMA
AND GOING TO INCREASE THE FLOW.
OR BALLOTS. THIS PATERSON ME TO
SAVE. ON THE NIGHT THIS TOOK.
AND I HAT. I WILL SAY PUBLICLY
THE MIKE A- YOU YOU'RE OFF.
ONCE TO MEET WITH ME AND MY
TEAM ON THIS OR ANY OTHER
MATTER. I STAND READY AND IF I
FEEL IN THAT COMMITMENT YOU CAN
CALL ME OUT IN THE NEXT PUBLIC
SESSION AND YOU CAN CALL ME TOO
IF- ANY OF YOU FEEL LIKE YOU'RE
NOT GETTING. PROPER ATTENTION
FROM ANY OF OUR DEPARTMENTS.
THAT'S SOMETHING I'D LIKE TO
HEAR ABOUT. IT'S NOT THE. SO IF
THERE ARE NO ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS SIR. I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION THIS
MORNING THANK YOU THERE'S LESS
TO HAVE BEEN AN OVERVIEW BUT WE
KIND OF DEVOLVED INTO A NUMBER
OF- VERY SPECIFIC QUESTIONS
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUES THAT WE
COVERED- AT THE ONLY THING I
WANTED TO MENTION TO YOU. OF A
MISTER CRAWFORD IS SOME I AGREE
WITH MY COLLEAGUES ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF FOR ACCESS AND
THE- PARKS FOR ALL PROGRAM I
THINK IS GOING TO BE. A GREAT
SUCCESS AND- ALLOW- MANY MORE
PEOPLE FROM AROUND THE STATE TO
ACCESS- A- ARE INCREDIBLE STATE
PARK SYSTEM- IN THE BUDGET IS A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF MONEY FOR
A NEW. STATE PARK AND WE HAVE.
BASICALLY NO INFORMATION OF
ABOUT THAT. I CAN'T IN GOOD
CONSCIENCE MOVE A BUDGET ITEM
FOR WOULD WITHOUT HAVING DETAIL
ABOUT IT SO PLEASE KEEP THAT IN
MIND. WE UNDERSTAND THAT AND
JUST BECAUSE SOME- MEMBERS
DIDN'T COME IN- WHEN I WAS
WOOD. SHARE THIS WHICH AS YOU
CAN HEAR A LOT OF DETAILS IN
COMING WEEKS FROM OUR
DEPARTMENTS- AND- THE- THE
PROGRAM LEADERS IN THOSE
DEPARTMENTS. IF IT'S HELPFUL
FOR ME TO GET ENGAGED ANY OF
THE DISCUSSIONS JUST PLEASE
REACH OUT I WANT TO BE AS
INVOLVED AS YOU WANT ME TO BE
PLEASE BEAR IN MIND THAT WE
NEED TO HEAR THAT DETAIL. IN
TIME TO PROVIDE APPROPRIATE FOR
SITE- AND ANALYSIS AND IF IT
COMES TO US- YOU KNOW IT MAY
REVISE OR OR OR LATE IN THE
GAME. IT'S A GOOD SITUATION.
UNDERSTOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
WELL WE HAVEN'T EVEN-
ESTABLISHED A QUORUM SO
PLENTIFULLY BUT WE DO THAT.
BLOOM HERE FONG GARCIA MULLIN
PATTERSON RAY YES RIVAS HERE.
ALL RIGHT- ARE WE READY TO MOVE
THE BUT ONLY CALENDAR. I'LL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO APPROVE
THE VOTER ONLY CALENDAR. YOU
GUYS WILL HAVE TO COLLECT. I
DON'T KNOW WHAT OKAY LET SET
TABLE THAT FOR A FEW MOMENTS
WE'LL GET ORGANIZED NO PROBLEM.
YEAH THE MUSIC IS TOO MANY
TABLES. YEAH THERE THESE FOLKS
ARE READY TO PROCEED MORE RUN A
LITTLE BIT BEHIND SCHEDULE SO-
LET'S THE PROCEED HERE FROM THE
AND- NATURAL SOURCES AGENCY ON
A LOT MORE DETAIL ON A COUPLE
OF ITEMS OKAY THANK YOU AND
WELCOME. THEM BRING CASH FROM
THE NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY-
HERE TO PRESENT ON OUR LIGHT
OUR PROPOSAL IS MARK GOLD WHO
IS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL
AND NATHAN ROCKS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION.
WELCOME THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
BLOOM HONOR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE HERE ON
THE TH ANNUAL ROTH THE
GEOGRAPHIC INFORMATION OFFICER
FOR THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF CONSERVATION I'M HERE TO
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT LEAD
DETECTION AND RANGING OR
LIGHTER WHICH IS THE PREFERRED
METHOD FOR DETAILED MAPPING OF
A LANDSCAPE IN THREE DIMENSIONS
IT HAS WIDE APPLICABILITY TO
MAPPING VEGETATION PARTICULARLY
FORESTRY GEOLOGY HYDROLOGY AND
HUMAN STRUCTURES FOR PLANNING
MONITORING AND EMERGENCY
RESPONSE. PRODUCTS WITH
IMMEDIATE UTILITY INCLUDE THE
TOPOGRAPHY ENTRY IN BUILDING
HEIGHTS OTHER DERIVED PRODUCTS.
THAT WILL BE PREPARED MAY
INCLUDE BUILDING SIZE AND A
VARIETY OF VEGETATION METRICS.
WHILE USING RAW LIDAR DATA WILL
REQUIRE TRAINING FOR STAFF.
MOST ANALYSTS WILL USE DERIVED
PRODUCTS THAT CAN BE USED
DIRECTLY IN EXISTING MAPPING
AND ANALYTICAL TOOLS WITH
MINIMAL TRAINING. THE EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS REQUESTED WILL
BE SUFFICIENT TO COMPLETE
COVERAGE OF CALIFORNIA ONE. IF
THE IF FUNDS FROM FEDERAL
AGENCIES OR OTHER PARTNERS
ALLOW COMPLETING THE COLLECTION
AT A LOWER COST TO THE STATE
THE EXCESS FUNDS ARE INTENDED
TO BE USED TO IMPROVE THE
DELIVER PRODUCTS. SELECT
SUPPORTING DATA PROVIDE
TRAINING AND EXPAND OUR
ANALYTICAL AND DATA
DISTRIBUTION INFRASTRUCTURE.
THE US GEOLOGICAL SURVEY
GENERALLY TARGETED EIGHT YEAR
REPEAT CYCLE FOR COLLECTIONS.
IN REALITY THAT UPDATE
FREQUENCY SHOULD BE DRIVEN. BY
THE UNDERLYING LANDSCAPE AND
ITS NEEDS. TOTAL COST REPEAT
COVERAGE OF THE FULL STATE WILL
LIKELY BE STE WOULD LIKELY BE
SIMILAR TO AN INITIAL
COLLECTION. THE PROBABLY PHASED
OUT OVER TIME. THE COLLECTION
WILL BE GOVERNED BY AN
EXECUTIVE BOARD WITH MEMBERSHIP
FROM LIGHT ARE USING
DEPARTMENTS ACROSS THE STATE.
AND THE TECHNICAL WORKING
GROUP. THAT WILL COMPLETE
DETAILED PLANNING AND EXECUTION
UPON APPROVAL BY THE BOARD.
THANK YOU AND ALLOW LIKE TO
PASS THE UP TO THE PODIUM TO
MARK GOLD. DEPUTY SECRETARY FOR
OCEANS AND COASTAL POLICY. GOOD
MORNING ON THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
BLOOM AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I
AM THRILLED TO BE HERE TODAY TO
TALK ABOUT ANOTHER CRITICAL
APPROACH TO MODERNIZING
CALIFORNIA'S NOW TO RESOURCE
MANAGEMENT. LIGHT ARE. LIGHTER
IS ESSENTIAL FOR BETTER
PROTECTING LIFE AND PROPERTY
THE INFORMATION ABLE TO US TO
BETTER ASSESS FUEL AND FIRE
RISK POTENTIAL AND FORCE AND
pUNDERSTAND HOW WATERSHEDS
CHANGE OVER TIME EROSION AND
SUBSIDENCE. AN ESSENTIAL NEED
FOR BETTER PROTECTING
STRUCTURES FROM FLOODING. IN
FOR BETTER MANAGING OUR WATER
SUPPLIES. LIGHT ARE HELPS US
MAP LANDSLIDES AND DETERMINE
WHICH COASTLINES AND BEACHES
ARE MOST AT RISK FROM COASTAL
ROADS AND SEA LEVEL RISE. LIGHT
ARE PROVIDE THIS ESSENTIAL
INFORMATION FOR IDENTIFYING
VEGETATION TYPES AND HOW TO
BEST RESTORE WETLANDS AND
STREAMS. AND IN CITIES LIDAR
DATA CAN DETERMINE TREE CANOPY
SOLAR POTENTIAL EFFICACY OF
TURF FOR PLACEMENT PROGRAMS AND
THE LOCATION OF HEAT ISLANDS.
AND WITH THE POTENTIAL GENEROUS
MATCH FROM U. S. G. S. WE HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET LAW A
LOT MORE BANG FOR OUR BUCK.
WITH THE EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN THE BUDGET IF USGS MATCHES
CALIFORNIA'S CONTRIBUTION AT
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR
EXAMPLE. THAT MEANS THERE COULD
BE UP TO FORTY MILLION DOLLARS
THAT COULD BE USED FOR
ADDITIONAL REMOTE SENSING FROM
SATELLITES AND AIRCRAFT.
SATELLITE DATA THAT PROVIDES US
WITH MULTI SPECTRAL ARE
HYPERSPECTRAL ANALYSIS CAN BE
OF GREAT BENEFIT COUPLED WITH
LIDAR DATA. FOR EXAMPLE.
LIGHTER WILL TELL US ABOUT THE
THREE DIMENSIONAL VEGETATION
COVERAGE IN OUR FORESTS
CHAPARRAL WOODLANDS OR
GRASSLANDS. BUT AND DVI THE
NORMALIZED DIFFERENCE
VEGETATION INDEX WHICH IS
VISIBLE LIGHT AND INFRARED
SPECTRUM LIGHT WAY BLANKS. ON
MEASUREMENTS FROM SATELLITES
ENABLE US TO COMBINE THE DATA
TO DETERMINE DROUGHT IMPACTS.
ON POTENTIAL FIRE RISK AREAS TO
PRIORITIZE BY THOSE FIRE RISK
AREAS. AND EVEN ON MAKE FIRE
BEHAVIOR PREDICTIONS. ANOTHER
EXAMPLE IS THE USE OF LIDAR IN
INDIA V. I. IN CITIES TO HELP
US DETERMINE HOW DROUGHT IS
IMPACTING TREE CANOPY. AND
LANDSCAPE VEGETATION. LIGHTER
WITH SATELLITE TEMPERATURE
MEASUREMENTS CAN ENABLE US TO
KEEP CLOSER TRACK OF POTENTIAL
HEAT ISLAND HOT SPOTS THAT POSE
HEALTH RISKS TO THE PUBLIC AND
HOW INTERVENTIONS LIKE INCREASE
TREE CANOPY COOL ROOFS AND COAL
PAYMENTS CAN REDUCE THE IMPACTS
OF THESE HEAT ISLANDS. REMOTE
SENSING FROM SATELLITES DOESN'T
PROVIDE THE RESOLUTION OR
NECESSARILY MEASURE THE SAME
THINGS AS LIGHT ARE. BUT
PROVIDES US WITH MORE FREQUENT
MEASUREMENTS UP TO MULTIPLE
TIMES PER DAY FREQUENTLY WEEKLY.
OF A LARGE VARIETY OF
PARAMETERS INCLUDING KELP
CANOPY WHICH- THE SECRETARY
TALKED ABOUT EARLIER HORIZONTAL
BEACH PROFILE CHANGES GREENNESS
MEAN IT OUT WHICH IS IMPORTANT
FOR DROUGHT ASSESSMENT.
LOCATIONS OF HARMFUL ALGAL
BLOOMS THE TRANSPORT OF
POLLUTED RUNOFF AND SENTIMENT
PLANS IN THE OCEAN. LAND
SURFACE TEMPERATURES AT A
THIRTY METER SCALE. SERVICE
MINERAL TYPES AND MINE WASTE
IMPACTS AND MORE. ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING- WITH OUR FELLOW STAFF
WITH JPL NASA U. S. YES THE UC
SYSTEM NATIONAL LABS AND OTHERS
TO MAKE SURE THAT CALIFORNIA'S
GETTING THE BEST AVAILABLE DATA
TO HELP US MANAGE CALIFORNIA'S
NATURAL RESOURCES AND BETTER
PROTECT LIFE AND PROPERTY.
THESE DATA SOURCES AND WORKING
RELATIONSHIPS WILL ENABLE
CALIFORNIA TO DO A MUCH BETTER
JOB OF PROTECTING OUR NATURAL
RESOURCES WHILE COAST AND
COASTAL WATERS YOU CAN LIVE AND
PRETTY AND HAVE ANSWER QUESTION
YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU. THANK
I DID WANT TO ASK. IF BUT-
THERE'RE IS PRECEDENCE ANYWHERE
ELSE IN THE WORLD FOR
INSTALLATION OF LIGHT ARE ON
THE SCALE THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE IN CALIFORNIA. THERE
IS- THE MAJORITY OF THE EAST
COAST OF THE U. S. HAS COVERED
LARGE PORTIONS OF THAT WERE
HEAVILY FUNDED- POST DISASTER.
LOST SEVERAL OTHER STATES ARE
WELL IN PROGRESS TOWARDS
COMPLETING STATEWIDE LIGHTER
COVERAGE. INDIANA IN PARTICULAR
HAS COMPLETED IT. LAW AND IS
STARTING TO CONSIDER- REPEAT
COVERAGE FLORIDA IS ABOUT TO
COMPLETE- COVERAGE AND THERE IS
AND THERE ARE A NUMBER OF OTHER
STATES- QUITE LITERALLY I WAS
TALKING WITH THAT. IT'S
ACTUALLY MY PEERS ACROSS OTHER
STATES- MONDAY AND TUESDAY THAT
ARE IN A VERY PARALLEL PLANNING
PROCESS FOR THE COLLECTION OF
THIS DATA FOR STATES ACROSS THE
US. AND THE A DO WE HAVE AN
AGREEMENT IN PLACE WITH USGS
OR- IS IT PRESUME THAT THEY'LL
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL FUNDING. WE
HAVE- A HISTORY OF WORKING OUT
AGREEMENTS WITH THEM THROUGH
THEIR THREE D. ELEVATION
PROGRAM TO FIND- ASSORTMENTS OF
SMALLER. DATA COLLECTIONS WE
HAVE A COUPLE PROJECTS IN
PROGRESS RIGHT NOW THAT WOULD
NOT BE NEED AND WHAT NOT NEED
TO BE RE COLLECTED- AT. ALL OF
THESE WORKING THROUGH THEIR
ESTABLISHED PRIDE AGENCY
ANNOUNCEMENT PROCESS FOR
COLLECTING AND DRESSED. FROM
STATES OR OTHER PARTNERS- TO
COLLECT FEDERAL. BUNDLED
INTERESTED IN IN COMPLETING
THIS PART PROJECTS. THANK YOU-
LA- I KNOW YOU WANT 2% ON THIS.
JUST THE COMPUTERS WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
AND IT'S SO IN REVIEWING THE
PROPOSAL AND WE DO FIND THAT
THAT CONCEPT OF- COLLECTING
LIDAR DATA ON THE STATE ON
APPEARS POMISING- AS AND THAT
THE AGENCY REPRESENTATIVES HAVE
TESTIFIED. AND THERE'S A LOT OF
POTENTIAL AND IT REALLY
INTERESTING AND INNOVATIVE
USES- OF FOR THIS DATA AND
HOWEVER AND WE RAISED SOME
CONCERNS THAT THE PROPOSAL
MIGHT BE PREMATURE AND IS SO AS
WAS TESTIFIED TO PREVIOUSLY
THERE IS A WORKING GROUP THAT
THAT AGENCY IS DEVELOPING. ON
TO LOOK AT EXACTLY HOW THE DATA
WOULD BE HUGHES WE FEEL THAT
INFORMATION IS ACTUALLY REALLY
NECESSARY BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE MOVES FORWARD IT
WITH ACTUALLY APPROVING A
SPENDING EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR A ONE TIME DATA COLLECTION
AND IS SORT OF A HIGH COST. AND
IT'S SORT OF UNCLEAR AT THIS
POINT EXACTLY HOW THE VARIOUS
DEPARTMENTS IN THE STATE OR
LOCAL PARTNERS OR JUST MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC COULD HAVE ACCESS
TO THIS DATA WOULD REALLY
UTILIZE. ON THIS COULD REQUIRES
CERTAIN PROGRAMMATIC SHIFT
CHANGES WITHIN VARIOUS STATE
DEPARTMENTS. IN TERMS OF HOW
THEY'RE ACTUALLY GOING TO AND
TAKE THE DATE AND CHANGE THE
WAY THEY MAKE DECISIONS ON. FOR
EXAMPLE WHICH EXPENSE WE FIND
FOR FOREST HEALTH PROJECTS- OR
HOW THEY'RE MAKING CERTAIN
PLANNING DECISIONS ON FOR
FUTURE PROJECTS AND SO WITHOUT
HAVING A GOOD IMPLEMENTATION
STRATEGY WE FEEL THAT THEPROPOSAL'S PRETEND POTENTIALLY
PREMATURE. GIVEN THE HIGH COST
I THINK AND IT WAS TESTIFIED TO
THAT U. S. G. S. TYPICALLY
LIKES TO SEE AN EIGHT YEAR
CYCLE OF RE COLLECTING THE DATA
IN OUR DISCUSSION WITH THE
AGENCY IT SOUND LIKE. THIS
INITIAL PASSIVE DATA WILL TAKE
THE FIVE. SO BY THE TIME YOU
GET TO THE END OF THE AND
COLLECTION OF DATA YOU'RE GOING
TO BE COMING UP ON THIS CYCLE
OF NEEDING TO REFRESH THAT DATA.
AND SO IT'S GOING TO BE. WEAK
THANKS FOR THE AGENCY. TO
PRESENT INFORMATION TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON WHAT ARE THE
SPECIFIC USES SOME OF THOSE
USES AND THAT HE COULDN'T
REQUIRE KNEADING THE DATA TO BE
REFRESHED VERY FREQUENTLY-
OTHERS MAYBE THEY DATA DOESN'T
NEED TO BE REFRESHED AS OFTEN.
BUT BEFORE YOU COMMIT TO DOING
THIS YOU'RE GOING TO WANT TO
HAVE A SENSE OF WHAT EXACTLY ON
IS THIS GOING TO BE USED FOR
HOW IS THIS GOING TO FILTER
DOWN INTO PROGRAMMATIC CHANGES.
AND BETTER DECISION MAKING ON
THE PART OF STATE ENTITIES AND
FOR THOSE PROGRAMS THAT REALLY
HAVE A PROCESS IN PLACE TO
UTILIZE THIS BETTER DATA. HOW
OFTEN IS THAT GOING TO HAVE TO
BE REFRESHED IS THIS GOING TO
BE SOMETHING WHERE THE
LEGISLATURE IS REALLY GOING TO
NEED TO APPROVE ANOTHER EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE NEXT
FIVE TO TEN YEARS TO CONTINUE
THE DATA- OR THEIR
OPPORTUNITIES TO MAYBE. FOCUS
IT ON HIGH JUST SORT OF HIGH
PRIORITY AREAS WHERE THAT THE
STATE IS ALREADY MORE GEARED UP
TO BE ABLE TO USE THE DATA. SO
BECAUSE OF ALL THAT WE
RECOMMEND WITHHOLDING ACTION ON
THIS I BELIEVE IT COME AND PULL
THIS THEM OPEN TO A- I'M AND- I
COMMEND. YOU SEE REPORT BACK
WITHOUT MORE ROBUST
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN THEY'RE IN
THE PROCESS OF MOVING TO THE X.
THAT THEY ARE ABLE TO PROVIDE
ROBUST IMPLEMENT. A PLAN TO
YOU. IS BY CYCLE THEN WITH
COLLECTION REJECTING PULLS UP
AND ASKING THEM TO COME BACK IN
A WHEN THEY HAVE A MORE FULLY
DEVELOPED PROPOSAL. SO THINK
THE DOCTOR PREPARE TO RE. TO
MAKE. UNDERSTAND THE ORIGINAL
FROM THE PRESENTATION THAT YOU
MADE DR GOLD TO THAT YOU WERE.
RATHER SPECIFIC ABOUT THE A
VARIETY OF USES THAT- THAT THE
LIGHT ARE- CAN CAN BE HELPFUL
WITH. I HINK WHAT I'M HEARING
FROM LA- WHAT WE'RE HEARING
FROM LA- IS THAT IT WOULD ALSO
BE HELPFUL TO HAVE A BREAK DOWN
ON WHEN THE REFRESH DATES FOR
EACH OF THOSE USES- WOULD BE AT
THAT WOULD BE IN ORDER. AND
JUST PROGRAMMATIC LEE HOW THIS
PROGRAM IT IS A CONSIDERABLE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT'S BEING
ASKED FOR. IT IS A NEW PROGRAM
SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE IT GETS
OFF THE OFF THE GROUND TO A
SUCCESSFULLY. OF HOW WOULD YOU
SUGGEST WE GO ABOUT DOING THAT
AND- YOU. WILL HAVE PLENTY OF
TIME BETWEEN NOW AND A REVISED-
TO- COME BACK WITH MORE
DETAILED INFORMATION BUT- GIVE
US AN OVERVIEW ON THAT NOW THAT
WOULD BE GREAT. SO OUR ALL STAR
DONE EMPLOYED PASSING OVER BET
ON BREAK IT UP INTO A WALL JACK
LIFE. ON SO- THANK YOU I HE
MIGHT MY REMARKS ARE ACTUALLY
MADE ON. KNOWING WHAT THE LA
KNOWS- COMMENTS WERE IN IN SO I
REALLY WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT
THOSE USES AND THAT THESE ARE
YOU SAYS. THAT ON. THE BEING
USED TODAY THIS IT'S NOT
PREMATURE IN ANY WAY SHAPE OR
FORM THIS IS EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS USING THE BEST
AVAILABLE SCIENCE TO GET US
THERE. I'M IT JUST SO HAPPENS
THERE'S A LOT OF OTHER USES FOR
LIGHT ARE OTHER THAN EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS BUT WE COULD
SPEND. OUR WHOLE TIME TALKING
ABOUT WALL SUBSIDENCE WHAT IS
THAT GOING TO DO TO OUR WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE WHAT IT YOU KNOW
WHAT- WE HAVE CLIP CORROSION
PROBLEMS THE IF YOU LOOK AT THE
SAN DIEGO AREA. ON YOU HAVE
INVESTMENT IN THAT REGION THAT
THEY'RE THEY'RE ACTUALLY DOING
WHAT OUR FARM OR FREQUENTLY
BECAUSE THEY'RE SEEN AND IS.
ARE CURRENTLY AND- STRUCK OF
THE COST GEOLOGY. ON SUCH A
FREAK BASIS AND AN WE'VE ALL
BEEN FOLLOWING ON THE- DOWN
THERE. ON IT WE DON'T NEED TO
TALK ABOUT WITHOUT FIRE IN THIS
GROUP FROM THE STATE YOU KNOW
FROM THE STANDPOINT OF WHAT
RISKS ARE. AND HOW THIS HELPS.
IT'S NOT. THE REASON WHY I
TALKED ABOUT LINKING WITH OTHER
SETS OF INFORMATION YOU CAN'T
JUST LOOK AT LINE ARE ALONE. IN
A BOX RIGHT IT HAS TO BE USED
IN CONJUNCTION. WITH OTHER
SORTS OF TOOLS TO REALLY GET
THE MOST OUT OF IT AND THAT'S
WHY I GAVE SOME VERY COMMON
SENSE. EVERY DAY SORTS. OF USES
AT THE AT ON THE ARE WOULD BE
WITH WITH ON SET. AND OTHER%
FIXED WING. ON ERR AIRBORNE.
WERE ABOUT A REMOTE SENSING
TECHNIQUES. ON THE COULD BE
TREMENDOUS VALUE WHETHER YOU
LIVE IN A CITY OR WHERE DO YOU
LIVE ON THE COAST BUT WHAT DO
YOU LIVE IN A FORESTED AREA OR
AN AREA PRONE TO FIRE THERE
THERE'S- THE USES. ON OUR OUR
ABSOLUTELY. ON ESSENTIAL FOR
THE ENTIRE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
RESOURCE MANAGEMENT PROTECTION.
OF PUBLIC HEALTH FROM THE
STANDPOINT OF NEXT STEPS I'M
GONNA PASS ON TO MY- IT CAN YOU
ALSO- ADDRESSED THE NOTION OF-
WHETHER- THIS IS TIMELY OR
PERHAPS A LITTLE BIT PREMATURE
I THINK THAT WAS WHAT. ANOTHER
POINT THE ALEJO YEAH I THINK
THAT WAS MY POINT WAS IT'S
NEVER PREMATURE TO BE MOREPREPARED FOR AN EMERGENCY. ON
IN AND I THINK THAT'S THAT'S
REALLY WHAT THIS IS ABOUT AND
THIS IS GOING TO HELP US. IN
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS AND
ABOUTA HUNDRED DIFFERENT WAYS
ON AND THAT'S THAT'S A REALLY
ONE EMPHASIZE THAT PART. ON IN
IT HELPS US ON CLIMATE
ADAPTATION WHICH IS YOU HEARD
FROM THE SECRETARY. IS YOU KNOW
ONE OF THE BIGGEST PRIORITIES
OF THIS ADMINISTRATION IS TO
MOVE FORWARD ON. SO ONE OF THE
KEY PIECES I'D LIKE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT WE GET OUT ON
THE TABLE. IS LIGHT ARE- IS A
NEW BUZZWORD. BUT IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY NEW TECHNOLOGY. IT
IS EXISTED AND BEEN IN ACTIVE
USE FOR A LONG TIME. WHAT'S
CAUGHT UP. IS THE REST OF OUR
COMPUTING POWER. THE
UNIVERSITY'S TRAINING STAFF ON
HOW TO MAKE FULL USE OF IT- THE
ABILITY FOR. US TO STORE
TRANSMIT. A PROCESS PARTICULAR
WITH SOME OF THE MACHINE
LEARNING AND ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE TYPE TECHNIQUES.
TO REALLY DERIVE THE DEEPEST
SETS OF. INFORMATION PRODUCTS
THAT WE CAN FROM THE DATA IT'S
OUR GEOLOGISTS IS- IN THE
DEPARTMENT CONSERVATION
EVERYWHERE THAT THEY CAN LAY
THEIR HANDS ON IT RIGHT NOW
THEY ARE PULLING THIS DATA AND
FOUR LANDSLIDE MAPPING FOR THE
REVIEW OF TIMBER HARVEST PLANS
FOR THE IDENTIFICATION OF FAULT
NOT FAULT AREAS THAT MAY MAY
POSE A RISK. HI IT IS IN VERY
ACTIVE USE RIGHT NOW WHEREVER
THEY CAN LAY THEIR HANDS ON IT
HI AND THERE ARE MANY PORTIONS
OF THE STATE FOR WHICH IT IS
NOT AVAILABLE- THAT- NOW'S THE
TIME I BELIEVE FOR US TO GET
AHEAD OF THAT BALL SO THAT WE
CAN START BUILDING THOSE
INFORMATION PRODUCTS TO MAKE
THOSE DECISIONS MORE
EFFECTIVELY. BUT BEEN
RESPONDING ON THE NEXT STEPS TO
SELF SAY WHATEVER REACTIONS
WILL BE DEBT SO NEXT NEXT STEPS
UP. TRY TO GET TRY TO BRING THE
DATA IN HOUSE SO THAT WE CAN
BUILD THIS PRODUCTS GET THEM
INTO THE DECISION MAKING
PROCESSES TRACK HOW THOSE
DECISION MAKING PROCESSES. ARE
CHANGING SO THAT WE CAN
UNDERSTAND WHAT OUR RETURN ON
INVESTMENT IS FORCE THIS
COLLECTION. AND FORECAST MORE
EFFECTIVELY WHAT THOSE WILL BE
FOR ANY FUTURE COLLECTIONS
INCLUDING THE PHASING THAT MAY
BE NECESSARY. IN ORDER TO- TO
ACCOMMODATE- THE HIGHEST VALUE
FOR REPEAT COVERAGE CYCLES-
ACROSS THE STATE IS HEALTHCARE
BUT I THINK IN A NUTSHELL WHAT
WE'RE SAYING IS WE'RE WILLING
TO WORK WITH STAFF AND WITH THE
LA TO GET THE COMMITTEE THE
INFORMATION THAT THEY NEED.
THANK YOU VERY CONCISE. THIS IS
A TOPIC REMINDS ME A LITTLE BIT
OF- OF- THE DEVELOPMENT OF
LASER TECHNOLOGY MANY DECADES
AGO WHICH I THINK WAS- A FIRST
INVENTED BACK ENOUGH IN THE
FIFTIES BUT IT DIDN'T REALLY-
START TO BECOME BROADLY USED TO
UNTIL THE SEVENTIES AND THEN
THERE WAS AN EXPLOSION OF USES
IN TODAY'S TECHNOLOGICAL WORLD-
LIGHT ARE- ISN'T NEW BUT IT'S
ALSO NOT THAT OLD YET AND-
WE'RE EXPERIENCING NOW I THINK
AN EXPLOSION IS AT AND IT'S
IMPORTANT VEHICLES. EXACTLY
YEAH. OF AND THE- SO IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO GET RIGHT
AND TO- WE ONLY HAVE A LIMITED
AMOUNT OF TIME IN THE BUDGET
PROCESS TO DO THAT I KNOW
YOU'VE GIVEN A LOT OF THOUGHT
SO I'M GLAD THAT CONVERSATION
WILL TAKE PLACE BETWEEN NOW AND
THE- OUT WHEN THIS COMES BACK
WE WILL BE- HOLDING THIS ITEM
OPEN SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE PRESENTATION ON IT- I WILL
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AT- AFTER-
ISSUE NUMBER TWO I DON'T THINK
THAT WAS GOING TO TAKE TOO
LONG- YOU'RE GONNA GIVE ME AN
UPDATE ON US AN UPDATE ON THE-
RELOCATION OF THE-
HEADQUARTERS. AND I WALKED BY
IT TO ALMOST EVERY DAY AS I
COME A BACK AND FORTH FROM- MY
HOME- TO THE CAPITAL SO I DON'T
KNOW THAT THERE IS PROGRESS
BEING THE CLADDING ON THE
BUILDING GO UP. BRING CASH
AGAIN FROM THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY WE'RE
REQUESTING NINE POINT SIX
MILLIONDOLLARS- FOR ALL THE
REQUIRED ELEMENTS. FOR THE
RELOCATION AND TO THE NEW
NATURAL RESOURCES HEADQUARTERS
BUILDING AND ALSO RELOCATING
OUR CHEER THREE DATA CENTER. TO
A NEW LOCATION- THE PROPOSAL AS
THREE ELEMENTS OF THE FIRST
ELEMENT IS- TWO POINT SIX
MILLION FOR THE- TECHNICAL
NETWORKING INVOICE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THE
BUILDING- THE CLERK TOTAL COSTS
FOR THIS IS FIVE POINT THREE
MILLION BUT THE AGENCIES. ARE
ALREADY CONTRIBUTING 50% OF
THAT COST- THE SECOND IS RE
CLOSE RELOCATING ARTS HERE
THREE DATACENTER AND THE COST
FOR THAT IS ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS- THE COSTS
WERE- ESTIMATED BY AN
INDEPENDENT PARTY IN. AND
APPROVED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY. AND THEN FIVE POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
DECOMMISSIONING. THE CURRENT
BUILDING ALL THE- EQUIPMENT AND
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IN THERE
AND THEN MOVING WHAT WE NEED
INTO THE NEW BUILDING- WE
WORKED HARD WITH INVESTMENT
GIVEN BY THE- LEGISLATURE LAST
YEAR TO DID TIES. LEAVE ARE
RIGHT. IN THE MID MIDDLE OF
DOING THAT. THE COST FOR THE
MOVE OUR LOT LESS THAN WHAT
THEY WOULD HAVE BEEN IF WE
ACTUALLY HAD- ALL THAT PAPER TO
MOVE WITH US SO WE'RE REALLY
WORKING TO. CHANGE OUR BUSINESS
PROCESSES SO THAT WERE MOVING
TO A MORE DIGITAL MORE MODERN
WORK SPACE- THROUGH THIS MOVE
TO THE NEW BUILDING. GREAT
THANK YOU LA OUR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. ANY QUESTIONS WILL
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT NOW ON-
ISSUES WANTED TO. IF THERE IS
ANY. OKAY CENTER. CONCISE
PUBLIC COMMENT IS GREATLY
APPRECIATED WELCOME- THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN BLOOM AND- COMMITTEE I
WANT TO SPEAK TO THEM THE LIGHT
UP BY YOURSELF AND- YOU'RE
REPRESENTING MY NAME IS GREG
SUMA I'M THE CONSERVATION
BIOLOGIST FOR A GROUP CALLED
HERE FORCE LEGACY WHERE GROUP
THAT LOOKS IT- HOLD FORCED
CONDITIONS IN THE SIERRA
NEVADA. AND I WANT TO SPEAK TO
LIGHT ARE OF THE ALLIED OUR
ITEM BASICALLY TO SUPPORT- A
LOT OF WHAT IS WAS SAID FIRST
OF ALL- IT'S A NEW TOOL IT'S A
NEW SET OF EYE GLASSES FOR-
NATURAL RESOURCE MANAGEMENT NET
THAT MAY SOUND DIMINUTIVE BUT
IT IS IT BRINGS US INTO THE
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY IN TERMS
OF. IDENTIFYING THE STRUCTURE
OF VEGETATION ON THE GROUND
WHICH IS IMPORTANT WHEN WEAR
IDENTIFYING IN IMPORTANT
COMPONENTS FOR WILDLIFE WHEN
WE'RE LOOKING AT HOW TO- DESIGN
A STRICT NETWORK OF STRATEGIC
FUEL BREAKS ACROSS THE
LANDSCAPE BECAUSE BOTH NATIONAL
FOREST IN AND PRIVATE LANDS IN
STATE OWNED LANDS- AND
PRESCRIPTIONS FOR HOW TO THIN
FORCED ECOLOGICALLY THAT ALSO
PROVIDED FIRE HAZARD- REDUCTION
SO HOW DO WE DO THAT. AND HOW
DOES LIGHT ARE IMPROVE OUR
ABILITY TO DO THAT IT GIVES US.
A THREE DIMENSIONAL VIEW AT A
VERY FINE SCALE THAT ALLOWS US
TO GET DOWN TO ACRE AND SO
BAKER- DESIGNS OF OUR
TREATMENTS. THAT PREVIOUSLY
WOULD HAVE BEEN AN ITERATIVE
PROCESS USING WHAT SOMEONE CALL
I'D ARE WE CAN WE JUMP TO LIGHT
ARE UP LET ME GIVE YOU ONE
SPECIFIC EXAMPLE IN MY CASE.
WORKING WITH THE ELDORADO
NATIONAL FOREST IN THE LAST
THREE YEARS. WORK THAT HAS
STARTED IN- THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA THE ACADEMICS
LOOKING AT- WILDLIFE BEHAVIOR
THIS CASE CALIFORNIA SPOTTED
OWL AND THEN COMPARING THAT TO
NEW LIGHT OUR INFORMATION
THAT'S AVAILABLE. WE HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO OUR S. RESEARCHERS HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO IDENTIFY. AT A SO
BAKER SCALE. THE HIGH CANOPY
TOLD THREE ELEMENTS OF A FOREST
THAT THE SPOTTED OWLS ARE
ABSOLUTELY USING FOR THEIR
NESTING. SO NOW WITH LIGHT ARE
WHERE LIGHTERS AVAILABLE WE CAN
PICK THOSE COMPONENTS OUT. SO
THAT WAS THE RESURGENT TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THAT IS NOW DOWN
SCALED DOWN TO ACTUALLY TRYING
TO GET IT DOWN THE FIELD.
GETTING PRACTITIONERS TO USE
LIGHT ARE WHERE IT'S AVAILABLE
TO FIRST PICK OUT THOSE
ELEMENTS WHERE TIMBER
HARVESTING AND COMMERCIAL
THINNING AND FUEL REDUCTION IS
PLANNED. AND FIND THOSE
ELEMENTS AND CREATE NEW
TREATMENTS AROUND WHERE THOSE
ARE IN A MORE EFFECTIVE AND
EXPEDITIOUS WAY WHICH LASTLY
ALL SAY. THAT IS COMMENSURATE
WITH THE URGENCY THAT WE NEED
WITH WHICH WE NEED TO DO THESE
FUEL HAZARD TREATMENTS. THANK
YOU SO IS GREATLY SUPPORT THIS
AND NOT PREMATURE WE SHOULD GET
IT INTO THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS. GOOD MORNING MR MERGE
THE COMMITTEE UNFETTERED OF ON
THE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY I THINK
GREG JUST BLEW ME OUT OF THE
WATER AS FAR AS LIKE LONG
TESTIMONY. SO KUDOS TO HIM BUT
ALSO DID- EVERYTHING THAT YOU
CAN SET YOUR COMMENTS SHORT TO
KEEP IT SHORT EXACTLY- AS A NON
SCIENTIST YOU KNOW I JUST
REALLY WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THE
BENEFITS OF HAVING THIS LIGHT
OUR DATA FOR THE STATE IN AN
ACCESSIBLE FORMAT. BUT NGOS IN
NON PROFITS IN UNIVERSITIES CAN
ACCESS IS GOING TO BE CRITICAL
FOR MANY THINGS FROM CARBON
ACCOUNTING TO WATER MANAGEMENT.
TO HABITAT CONSERVATION
CONNECTIVITY- BETTER
UNDERSTANDING URBAN TREE CANOPY
AND URBAN AND RURAL AREAS LIKE
THE BENEFITS ARE A MANY FOLD-
AND REALLY WANTED TO STRESS
THAT. WE HAD REALLY GOOD
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
RESOURCES AGENCY WITH MISTER
CASH MISTER GOLDIN OTHERS- THAT
BEEN REALLY HEAVILY INVOLVED IN
DIGGING INTO THE WEEDS OF IT
ALL. AND EVERYTHING THAT WE'VE
HEARD IT HAS HAS REALLY HELPED
US UNDERSTAND BETTER WHAT IS
BEING PROPOSED AND THE
USEFULNESS OF THESE TYPE
INVESTMENTS WOULD LOVE TO SEE
THESE GO FORWARD. WE UNDERSTAND
THAT THE CHALLENGES THE
COMPLICATION IS REALLY BROWN
FUNDING AND OF COURSE. WE WOULD
LOVE TO BE AT THE TABLE TO
OFFER ACCOMMODATIONS ON THE
FUNDING QUESTIONS AS WELL THANK
YOU. ONE GERMAN BLOOM MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. TO THE
PACIFIC FOREST TRUST ALSO VERY
SUPPORTIVE- LETTERS TO
TREMENDOUS ADVANCE IN TERMS OF
OUR ABILITY TO DO THE PLANNING
AS MY COLLEAGUES HAVE ALREADY
SAID. WHICH IMMENSELY USEFUL
AND- WATERSHED RESTORATION WORK
THAT YOU'RE CARRYING MISTER-
MISTER BLOOM- SO IT'S ONE OF
THOSE THINGS WE WISH WE ALREADY
HAD TODAY. SO I WOULD REALLY
URGE US TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
AND THIS BUDGET CYCLE IT'S
ABSOLUTELY REASONABLE TO. HOLD
THE ADMINISTRATION OF THE FIRE
FOR BETTER PLANNING BUT WE
REALLY DO. WISH WE HAD THIS
MOUSE LET'S NOT LOSE ANY MORE
TIME TOWARDS GETTING. THIS TOOL
TO INFORM OUR OUR WORK ON THE
STATE THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
ROBERT GORE FROM MIKE WALKER
GROUP ON BEHALF OF THE KINGS
RIVER CONSERVATION DISTRICT
WITH ONE POINT TWO MILLION
ACRES UNDER MANAGEMENT. KINGS
RIVER INTO EIGHBORING YOU'RE
ADDITION DISTRICTS HAVE BEEN
WORKING FOR THE LAST FIVE YEARS
WITH NASA. ON LIDAR- AS THE
RESULT HAS BEEN TO CREATE A
MINIMUM OF TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND ACRE FEET OF NEW
WATER. THIS HELPS CONTRIBUTE
AND WILL TO A DRINKING WATER
FOR DAX. SO LIGHT OURS IN USE-
WE WOULD LIKE TO HELP WITH THIS
SO PROPOSAL BECAUSE- NOW SAYS
DETERMINE THE EXPERIMENT TO BE
INTERNET AND IT HAS WALKED
AWAY. OF THE OF THE SORT OF
FIND IT IS DESPERATELY NEEDED
TO PRESERVE EXISTING DATA. IN
PROGRAM THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
KIM DELFINO REPRESENTING
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE- WERE
PART OF THE CONSERVATION
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE MET
WITH AND TALKED WITH DEPARTMENT
CONSERVATION RESOURCES AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL.
I THINK IT'S BEEN NOTED- WHAT
THE BENEFITS ARE IT IS LONG
OVERDUE- OUR EXPERIENCE
PARTICULARLY WITH LIGHT ARE A
GOES ALL THE WAY BACK TO THE
USE OF IT. TO MAP OUT VERNAL
POOLS AND CENTRAL VALLEY WAS AN
INCREDIBLE- RESEARCH PROJECT
THAT HELPED US FULLY UNDERSTAND
WHERE POOL WHERE THESE- HABITAT
TYPES ARE AND HOW TO BETTER
MANAGE THEM. AND SO WE SEE
INCREDIBLE VALUE HERE I WOULD
NOTE THAT THIS WAS- THE LOT OF
DISCUSSIONS GOING ON YOUR
PUBLIC SAFETY AND WE DEFINITELY
SEE WHERE THIS INFORMATION
COULD BENEFIT THAT. BUT IT WAS
IDENTIFIED AS PART OF THE
BIODIVERSITY INITIATIVE. AND SO
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION COMING BACK FROM AS
THE RESOURCES AGENCY ANSWERS
QUESTIONS FOR THE LA- TO BETTER
FLUSH OUT HOW. THIS WILL
FURTHER BIODIVERSITY. OF
PROTECTION MEASURES AND ALSO
HOW THIS INFORMATION WILL BE.
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE BECAUSE I
DEFENDERS HAS. SERVED CENTER CA.
INNOVATION AND THESE ARE
BASICALLY DATA DE TORX THAT
WANT THIS INFORMATION AND THEY
SEE FEW POSSIBILITIES. WITH
HAVING THIS INFORMATION MADE
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE AND HOW IT
CAN BE. ACTED LIKE. ARCHERS NOT.
THAT ARE NOT RESOURCES
DECISIONS SO THANK YOU. MORNING
MR CHAIR MEMBERS THE CASF
EXAMPLE THE NATURE. JUST WANT
TO ECHO SOME THE COME TO MY
PREVIOUS COLLEAGUES. REGARDING
OF CERTAINLY FOR THE BUT THE
BENEFITS OF COURSE BUT WE ALSO-
I. WOULD BE REMISS IF WE DIDN'T
MENTION THE POTENTIAL
LEVERAGING OF FEDERAL FUNDS. TO
MAKE THIS A BETTER PROPOSAL
OVERALL THAT PARTNERSHIP
POTENTIAL PARTNERSHIP EXCUSE ME
WITH THE USGS WOULD BE A REALLY
IMPORTANT THING IN PLEDGING US
FEDERAL FUNDS. I THINK IT'S
ALSO WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
QUESTIONS THAT BOTH STAFF AND
LA- HAVE RAISED THE ISSUES THEY
RAISE BUT WE'VE ALSO BEEN
REALLY APPRECIATE OF MEETING
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION AND
WOULD BE CONSERVATION GROUPS
HAVE BEEN MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY-
IT TO ACTUALLY DIG INTO SOME
THESE ISSUES AND QUESTIONS AND
THEY ARE REALLY BEEN VERY
RESPONSIVE TO THE THINGS HAVE
BEEN RAISING SO JUDAS. SUPPORT
THIS. THE APPROPRIATE THINKS
MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME'S
CULTURE MARIST'S I'M WITH THE
U. S. HERE FOR SERVICE SPECIFIC
SOUTHWEST REGION ON THE PROGRAM
MANAGER FOR THE FOR SERVICE FOR
REMOTE SENSING LAB WHERE THE
NERDS THAT ACTUALLY PROCESS THE
LETTER DATA- JUST REAL QUICK-
THERE SOME EFFICIENCIES GAINED.
AS FAR AS PLANNING FUELS
MANAGEMENT FORCE HEALTH
TREATMENTS ACROSS THE
LANDSCAPE- WE HAVE BEEN USING
LIDAR DATA WITH THE FOR SERVICE
FOR ALMOST A DECADE NOW. AND
EVERY YEAR IT'S BECOMING MORE
MORE INTEGRAL FOR PROJECT
PLANNING. IT DOES PROVIDE
DATASKILL THAT'S VERY RELEVANT
TO- FORESTERS AND SO CULTURE IS
WILDLIFE BIOLOGISTS AND FUEL
SPECIALIST AT A SCALE THAT THEY
COMPLAIN PROJECTS AROUND. A FOR
THE MORE THEIR EFFICIENCIES
GAINED WITH FIELDER VIEWS OF
THE- LAND MANAGER CAN ASSESS
WITH THE LIGHT HOURS TELLING
THEM AND DETERMINE WHERE TO
FOCUS FIELD EFFORTS FOR.
PROJECT PLANNING. FOR THE MORE
THE DIGITAL ELEVATION MODEL
CONSISTS WITH THE SAID
ASSESSING SOIL EROSION HABIT
HAS OUR GREETINGS IDENTIFIES
GET ROADS. OKAY LANDINGS IN
DETERMINE THE FEASIBILITY OF
WHERE TO PUT LOGGING SYSTEMS
FOR FORCE HEALTH TREATMENTS-
LASTLY- IT'S BEEN CRITICAL FOR
IDENTIFYING FOR STRUCTURES THAT
ARE ESSENTIAL FOR WILDLIFE
HABITAT. AND THROUGH THE
EXAMINATION A TREE SPATIAL
PATTERNS CAN DETERMINE WHAT HER
AREAS ARE DEVIATED FROM THE
CASH FOR A VARIATION AND WHERE
FOR. RESTORATION TREATMENTS CAN
BE IMPLEMENTED. THANKS FOR TIME.
WE THE SHORTEST ONE OF THEM ON
A WITHOUT A MONEY CAL. SUPPORT
OF THIS. GOOD MORNING JAMIE
GOING TO HAVE CALIFORNIA RELIEF
JUST WANTED TO ECHO THE SUPPORT
FOR THE LIGHT OUR PROGRAM AND
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
SPECIFICALLY AT THIS- TOLL WILL
REALLY HELP US UNDERSTAND- UP
THE TREE CANOPY AND
AVAILABILITY IN URBAN FORESTS
AND- ACROSS THE STATE. THANK
YOU. Q. OUT NO SUPPORT FROM THE
BUILDING. JUST KIDDING. SO
LET'S THAT WE'RE GONNA HOLD
BOTH OF THOSE ITEMS OPEN LET'S
MOVE BACK IN TIME TO THE VOTE
ONLY CALENDAR- AND- I'VE GOT A
MATRIX HERE NOW THAT I THINK WE
CAN WORK WITH IT THIS IS. GIVE
IT THIS IS EVERYBODY. YEAH THIS
IS. ONE MOTION THIS IS ANOTHER
AND THEN THE LAST ONE IS
ANOTHER OKAY DO. I LIKE TO
ENTERTAIN MOTION TO APPROVE
ITEMS ONE THROUGH. THREE SIX.
SEVEN EIGHT OR EIGHT. EIGHT
TWELVE AND SIXTEEN. BLOOM I
FONG NOT LIKE. GARCIA HI MULLIN
PATTERSON. RAY YES. RIVAS. AND
NOW FOR A THERE COULD BE A
MOTION TO APPROVE ITEMS. FOR
FIVE ELEVEN THIRTEEN FIFTEEN
AND SEVENTEEN THROUGH TWENTY.%
BLOOM I FONG AYE GARCIA MULLIN
PATTERSON YES RIVAS. THANK YOU
AND FINALLY A VOTE ON- ITEMS-
MOTION ON SEVEN NINE TEN AND
FOURTEEN. BLOOM HI FONG GARCIA
MULLIN PATTERSON RAY YES RIVAS.
COOL IT WILL I PUT THOSE ITEMS
ON CALL FOR THE- ABSENT MEMBERS
AND THAT TAKES US TO ALL THE
WAY TO ISSUE NUMBER THREE-
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
WELCOME MR BONHAM YOU'VE BEEN
VERY PATIENT THIS MORNING. SO.
BUDGET VERY POORLY. READY WHEN
YOU ARE MISTER BOTTOM. THANK
YOU CHAIR. IT'S TRUE MY NAME IS
CHUCK BOTTOM. AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
YOU'RE OWNING UP TO IT ARE YOU
THIS YEAR. IT'S TAKEN A LONG
TIME. I THINK ISSUE I KNOW
ISSUE THREE IS AN INFORMATIONAL
ITEM. AND I'M APPRECIATIVE THAT
YOU WOULD CAR ABOUT. A FEW
MINUTES FOR ME TO GIVE YOU A
STATUS UPDATE. OF A SPECIAL
PROJECT YOU ASKED US TO
COMPLETE. SO HERE'S MY ONE GOAL.
I WANT TO MAKE THE NEXT TENNIS
MINUTES EXCITING CAPTIVATING
ENERGIZING EVEN THOUGH IT'S
ENTIRELY ABOUT BUSINESS
ANALYTICS AS THAT'S MICHAEL YOU
CAN DO THIS YES. SO YOU MIGHT
ASK YOURSELF WHICH SOUNDS LIKE
THE START OF A SONG WHAT IS
SERVICE BASED BUDGETING. IT
TURNS OUT SERVICE BASED
BUDGETING IS A BUSINESS
DISCIPLINE. IT IS AN ANALYTICAL
APPROACH TO LOOK AT AN
ENTERPRISE AND UNDERSTAND THE
TASKS THE ENTERPRISE DOES THE
LABOR FOCUS FOR THOSE TASKS. IT
FORCES AN ORGANIZATION AROUND
SERVICE AREAS IT'S ITERATIVE.
AND IT ACCOMPLISHES CERTAIN
BUSINESS MANAGEMENT VALUES IT
PROMOTES EFFICIENCIES
TRANSPARENCIES INCLUSIVITY AND
IF DONE WELL IT BUILDS TRUST.
SO YOU HAVE A HAND OUT WITH YOU.
WHICH KIND OF TRACKS THE POINTS
ARE MAKING THIS UPDATE WE WILL
POST IT. ON OUR DEDICATED WEB
PAGE THIS AFTERNOON FOR THE
PUBLIC. SO THERE IS A
MANAGEMENT CONSULTANCY ARENA
AROUND SERVICE BASED BUDGETING.
WE HAVE FOUR GOALS IN THIS
PROJECT YOU'VE GIVEN TO US WE
WANTED TO FIND THE DEPARTMENT
SERVICE STANDARDS WE WANT TO
PROVIDE DETAILED COST ESTIMATES
AND STAFFING REQUIREMENTS ABOUT
THE STANDARDS WE WANT TO
COMPARE OUR CURRENT LEVEL OF
SERVICE TO OUR MISSION LEVEL OF
SERVICE. AND THEN WE WANT TO
ANALYZE OUR REVENUES STRUCTURE
AND ARE FUNDING SYSTEMS. HOW
DID WE GET HERE. IT'S ACTUALLY
A SEVENTY YEAR JOURNEY. I HAVE
REPORT IN MY FILES FROM THE
CONSULTING FIRM BOOZ ALLEN
HAMILTON NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT.
THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE COMMISSIONED A REPORT
TO LOOK AT OUR FINANCING AND
THE REPORT CONCLUDES THE
DEPARTMENT NEEDS TO SECURE
SUSTAINABLE FUND. FAST FORWARD
THE LEGISLATURE'S ACTUALLY
AMENDED THE FISH AND GAME CODE.
SECTION SEVEN TEN POINT FIVE IS
A GOOD EXAMPLE YOU DECLARED IN
THAT CODE SECTION THE
DEPARTMENT IS UNDER FUNDED AND
MUST SECURE SUSTAINABLE FUND.
FAST FORWARD TO THE TWO
THOUSANDS ASSEMBLY BILL
237-620-0010 AND ELEVEN
REQUIRED US TO CREATE A BLUE
RIBBON PANEL TO TAKE A LOOK AT
OUR APARTMENT AND FIGURE OUT
HOW TO BRING IT INTO THE MODERN
ERA. THAT BLUE RIBBON PANEL
PROCESS PRODUCED A REPORT WITH
TWENTY EIGHT RECOMMENDATIONS.
BUT THE HISTORY CONTINUES IN
THE BUDGET ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN YOU TOLD US TO GET
OUR BAND BACK TOGETHER. GO BACK
TO THE BLUE RIBBON PANEL GROUP.
BRING IT FORWARD RECREATED YOU
TOLD US TO GIVE YOU A STATUS
REPORT ON THE EARLIER BLUE
RIBBON RECOMMENDATIONS WE DID
THAT IN OCTOBER TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN. THEN YOU TOLD US TO
COMPLETE MISSION BASED
BUDGETING WE STARTED WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THAT
ENDEAVOR. THEN WE GET TO THE
BUDGET ACT OF TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN. IN THAT BUDGET ACT
OUR DEPARTMENT ACTUALLY GOT A
THIRTY MILLION DOLLAR THIRTY
POSITION. THREE YEAR
AUGMENTATION. ON ONE
CONTINGENCY YOU TOLD US TO
COMPLETE SERVICE BASED
BUDGETING. THIS BRINGS US UP TO
CURRENT TIME. IN THAT BUDGET
ACT YOU GAVE US A SERIES OF
MILESTONES WE'VE HIT ALL THE
TARGET DATES IN STATUTE. WE
HARD TO AVOID IT'S THE NATIONAL
EXPERT IN THIS MANAGEMENT
SPACE. ADVISORY COMMITTEE OF
EIGHTY PLUS PEOPLE INVOLVING
LA- STAFF SUBJECT MATTER AND
BUDGET COMMITTEE STAFF FROM THE
LEGISLATURE. AND A BROAD SWATH
OF OUR COMMUNITY ENGAGED. WE'VE
RE DIRECTED ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY OF OUR SENIOR STAFF OVER
THE LAST YEAR ON THIS
ANALYTICAL WORK. AND THAT
BRINGS US TO SLIDE THREE IN
YOUR HAND OUT. ONE OF THE
THINGS WE DID FIRST. WAS RE
ORIENT OURSELVES AROUND PLAIN
LANGUAGE YOU'LL SEE A SLIDE
THAT SAYS SERVICE AREAS. RIGHT
AFTER WE ARE NOT DOING THIS
ENDEAVOR BASED ON OUR
BUREAUCRATIC DESCRIPTION OF
OURSELVES WE WORKED WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDERS TO IDENTIFY EIGHT
SERVICE AREAS. USING PLAYING
LANGUAGE SO THAT THE DEPARTMENT
CAN UNDERSTAND BETTER WHAT WE
DO. FROM THE DEFINITION OF
THOSE SERVICE AREAS IF YOU'LL
ROLL OVER TO THE NEXT SLIDE
THAT HAS A WARDEN WITH
BINOCULARS. THAT DEFINITION OF
EIGHT SERVICE AREAS ALLOWED US
TO CREATE A ROSTER OF EVERY
TASK WE DO. WE NOW HAVE A
DIGITAL TEMPLATE THE TRACKS.
TWO THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED PLUS
TASKS. BETTER ACCOMPLISHING
THOSE EIGHT SERVICE AREAS FOR
EACH TASK WE ASKED OUR
LEADERSHIP WHY ARE WE DOING IT
BENCHMARK TO A MANDATE OR RULE
OR REGULATION WE IDENTIFIED HOW
MUCH TIME IS SPENT ON EACH OF
THOSE TASKS AND THEN IT HAS LED
US TO THE NEXT ENDEAVOR WHICH
IF YOU ROLL FORWARD IN YOUR
SLIDES. IS TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
THE GAP BETWEEN OUR CURRENT
ABILITIES IN SERVICE LEVEL. AND
THE NEED TO ACHIEVE OUR MISSION
YOU'LL SEE THAT IN THE SLIDE TO
THE LEFT WHERE YOU GET A SENSE
OF. THIS ANALYTICAL PROCESS
ILLUSTRATING THE GAP. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND THERE
ARE MANY WAYS TO RESOLVE THE
GAP PROBLEM. YOU DON'T HAVE TO
JUST ADD POSITIONS. FOR
NECESSARILY PROGRAM FUNDING YOU
CAN TAKE A LOOK AT YOUR
MISSIONS YOUR POLICIES YOUR
MANDATE YOU CAN TRY TO
UNDERSTAND WHETHER SUMMER
OUTDATED AND NEED TO BE
REMOVED. YOU CAN LOOK AT YOUR
OWN PROCESS SEES AND CREATE
BUSINESS EFFICIENCIES. YOU CAN
INCREASE YOUR PARTNERSHIPS WITH
YOUR EXTERNAL. COMMUNITIES TO
REDUCE COST AND BRIDGE THE GAP
YOU CAN ACTUALLY INVEST IN
TECHNOLOGY AND GET A RETURN ON
INVESTMENT THAT MAY BE GREATER
THAN THAT JUST ADDING LABOR.
AND OF COURSE YOU CAN SOLVE
YOUR GAP ISSUE FOCUSING ON
LABOR AS WELL. SO IF YOU GO TO
THE NEXT SLIDE. YOU'LL SEE THAT
WHAT WE HAVE DONE IN A YEAR
LAST YEAR'S WORTH OF ANALYTICAL
WORK WITH THOSE EXTERNAL
ADVISORS. AND THE LAWYER. IS
TAKE THAT TASK REGISTRY OF
THREE THOUSAND. AND TRY TO
QUANTIFY IT FOR THE FIRST TIME
EVER IN OUR DEPARTMENTS HISTORY.
OUR GAPS ACROSS THE SERVICE
AREAS THIS SLIDE REPRESENTS
FROM GREATEST GAP TO LEAST A
DEPICTION OF THAT RAW DATA
SAID. YOU'LL SEE THE GREATEST
GAPS THE CURRENT SPECIES AND
HABITAT CONSERVATION. AND
PERMITTING ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION. SO WHAT HAPPENS
FROM THERE. WELL THE NEXT SLIDE
SKETCHES OUT A FEW OF THE
ONGOING EFFORTS. WE ARE SITTING
ON THE BIGGEST BEST MOST
VALIDATED DATA SAID WE'VE EVER
HAD IN OUR DEPARTMENTS HISTORY
ABOUT OUR STAFFING AND LABOR
RELATED TO OUR MISSION. BUT
ADDITIONAL THINGS WE WILL BE
DOING IN THE UPCOMING YEAR
INCLUDE. Q. A IN QC ON THAT
DATA TO PERPETUALLY REFRESHES.
INCLUDE BUILDING THE DIGITAL
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT THIS IS A
TOOL AVAILABLE EVERY YEAR GOING
FORWARD TRAINING ALL OF OUR
EMPLOYEES THAT THIS IS OUR NEW
BUSINESS AS USUAL BUDGETING
TOOL TO INTERFACE WITH THE LA
US INTERFACE WITH FINANCED
INTERFACE WITH YOU AT THE
COMMITTEE LEVEL. TO DEAL WITH
IN CORY'S FROM OUR STAKEHOLDERS.
AND ALSO TO START UNPACKING OUR
REVENUE SOURCES AND
EXPENDITURES IN A PRETTY
COMPLICATED BUDGET MOST WOULD
SAY ONE OF THE MORE COMPLICATED
BUDGET. AND STATE GOVERNMENT.
BUT I WANT TO END WITH THE
STORY. THAT'S MORE THAN JUST
THIS BUSINESS ANALYTICS IF YOU
COULD GO BACK TO THE SLIDE
THAT'S THE PICTURE OF. TWO
BIRDS WITH A FISH STUCK IN
BETWEEN. EACH YEAR WE RUN A
CONTEST WE PICK A PHOTO THE IS
THE BEST PHOTO OF WILDLIFE
ACTION. THIS IS THE PHOTO I
PICKED FIRST EARS DIRECTOR.
BECAUSE WHEN I LOOKED AT IT I
THOUGHT. YOU'VE GOT TO BIRDS
WENT FLYING IN AN OPPOSITE
DIRECTION EACH WITH ITS TALONS
IN A BIRD. STUCK IN THE MIDDLE
AND I THOUGHT THAT'S LIKE LIFE
IN OUR DEPARTMENT. STUCK IN THE
MIDDLE. BUT THEN I THOUGHT MORE
ABOUT IT LAST NIGHT WHAT WHY DO
WE FIND ARE STILL STUCK IN THE
MIDDLE ON MANY THINGS MY SENSE
IS IT'S BECAUSE OUR MISSION IS
ABOUT NATURE. AND IT'S A NATURE
THAT EXIST IN A POPULATION OF
FORTY MILLION PEOPLE THAT'S
GOING TO FIFTY MILLION. AND
THIS NATURE IS EVERYTHING IT'S
B. EASE IT'S BUTTERFLIES IT'S
WHALES IT'S MOUNT LINES IT'S
KELP FOREST. AND WE VIEW OUR
MISSIONS AS PRESERVING THIS
LAND THIS WATER IN THIS
WILDLIFE AS PART OF A THRIVING
ECONOMY. THEY'RE INTERDEPENDENT
THEY'RE NOT MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE
WITH IT'S A IT'S A FUTURE IT'S
A NATURE OF SIX HUNDRED AND
FIFTY BIRD SPECIES TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY MAMMAL SPECIES. SEVENTY
FRESHWATER FISH SPECIES A
HUNDRED MARINE FISH AND MARINE
MAMMAL SPECIES WE HAVE SIX
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED TAX- OF
PLANTS IN THIS STATE TWO
THOUSAND OF WHICH ARE FOUND NO
WHERE ELSE IN THE WORLD. IT'S A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY NINE THOUSAND
SQUARE MILES ALMOST FIVE
THOUSAND LAKES HUNDRED SEVENTY
FIVE MAJOR RIVERS AND STREAMS
AND ELEVEN HUNDRED MILE
COASTLINE AND THE GREAT OCEAN
OFF OUR SHORE. THAT IS WHY
PEOPLE HAVE COME HERE. THAT IS
WHY PEOPLE CONTINUE TO COME
HERE. IT'S OUR DESERT'S ARE FAR
STAR MEADOWS ARE KELP FAR STAR
WORKING AGRICULTURAL LANDS ARE
RANGE LANDS. IT'S WHAT FUELS
CALIFORNIA BEING THE FIFTH
GREATEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD
IT'S HEADING TO NUMBER ONE.
THAT'S HOW WE SEE OUR MISSION
AT THE DEPARTMENT. IT'S A
NATURE THAT'S INCLUSIVE FOR ALL
OF THAT IN ALL PEOPLE. IN THE
SERVICE BASED BUDGETING
EXERCISE IS A THING THAT IS
HELPING US WITH THE YOU. TAKE
OUR DEPARTMENT INTO A BETTER
FUTURE. A MORE EFFICIENT
GOVERNMENT FUTURE AND A
PRESERVATION OF THAT NATURAL
WEALTH. AND THAT'S KIND OF IN A
NUT SHELL AT THE BROADEST LEVEL
WHY THINK SERVICE BASED
BUDGETING IS IMPORTANT AND AT
THE NARAL LEVEL AN UPDATE ON
WHAT WE'VE ACCOMPLISHED TODAY.
THANK YOU- WE ARE THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY BUT WE'RE NOT
HEADING FOR NUMBER ONE THAT
MIGHT BE PROBLEMATIC. GOOD AS
PERHAPS THE GOOD TO GOAL. I AM
WONDERING IF- YOU- SINCE YOU'RE
KIND OF OUR ROLE HERE- COULD TO
MOVE INTO THE NEXT MOVE INTO
ISSUE NUMBER FOUR AND TO. HELP
US UNDERSTAND TO. AT THINK A
FRANKLY DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS GOING TO HAVE TO WEIGH IN
HER BECAUSE I'M NOT SURE HOW
MUCH OF IT AS- DO YOU KNOW
WHERE. WHERE THIS ALL IS COMING
FROM BUT- TO JUST T. THIS UP A
LITTLE BIT. I WAS GONNA SAY WE
THOUGHT WE HAD A DEAL LAST YEAR
THERE ACTUALLY WAS A DEAL THAT
WAS CUT ON- THE BCP FOR THE-
HABITAT CONSERVATION FUND
SHIFT- AND- IN THIS. YEAR'S
BUDGET SOMETHING NEW HAS BEEN
PROPOSED AND- SO THE
FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION IS WHAT
HAPPENED THAT DEAL. CHAIR IF I
COULD START YEAH. LET ME SET
THE STAGE ON THE CURRENT BUDGET
PROPOSAL BUT MAKE SURE I
CONNECTED TO THE LAST AGENDA
ISSUE. AND THEN I'M A TURN
ABOUT BECAUSE THE FINANCE FOR
THE MORE DIFFICULT PARTY A
QUESTION. WHAT YOU HAVE IN
FRONT OF YOU. IS IT I THINK AN
EXCITING SUBSTANTIVE PROPOSAL.
IT TAKES THE WORK I JUST
DESCRIBED. WHILE REALIZING WE
HAVE A BIGGER BOLDER STILL TO
COMPLETE SERVICE BASED
BUDGETING DYNAMIC WE KNOW
ENOUGH RIGHT NOW BASED ON OUR
EXTERNAL ADVISORS AND THE DATA.
TO PROPOSE SOME REALLY SMART
SURGICAL INVESTMENTS THAT HAVE
HIGH RETURN ON INVESTMENT FOR
CALIFORNIA IT'S SO IN MY MIND
THE SUBSTANCE IS SOLID. AND
IT'S A PROPOSAL OF AN
AUGMENTATION OF THIRTY EIGHT
POINT NINE MILLION. AN
ADDITIONAL FIFTY EIGHT
POSITIONS AND THE CONTINUANCE
OF THAT PRIOR LIMITED
AUGMENTATION. WHAT I THINK
YOU'RE ASKING ABOUT IS THE HOWL
ONE WOULD DO THAT FINANCING
INVESTMENT WHICH TRIGGERS AS
YOU KNOW A COMPONENT OF LIFE
FUNDS SWAP FOR A PORTION OF
THIS GENERAL FUND FROM THE
HABITAT CONSERVATION FUND WHICH
DIRECTS MONIES TO THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD. AND INSTEAD
THAT AMOUNT OF MONEY TO OUR
DEPARTMENT. MAKING THE
CALCULATION WHICH I THINK IT'S
CREDIBLE. YOU COULD POTENTIALLY
GET GREATER RETURN ON
INVESTMENT THROUGH PROGRAM
INVESTMENT AT OUR DEPARTMENT.
GIVEN THE WILDLIFE CONSERVATION
BOARD HAS A BALANCED BUDGET.
AND USES THAT EIGHTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR SMALL ISOLATED
GRANTS AROUND THE STATE THAT'S
THE LOGIC THAT'S THE QUESTION
YOU'RE GETTING AT LET ME TURN
TO MY COLLEAGUE AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO TAKE
IT MORE DIRECTLY. A THIRD- I'VE
NEVER DEPARTMENT FINANCE AND SO.
AS THE DIRECTOR BONTA KIND OF
IDENTIFY THE THROUGH STATE
BUDGET DATA WITH- PRELIMINARY
GAPS THAT WE FOUND WE LOOKED AT
WHAT CAN WE DO TO START
ADDRESSING SOME OF THOSE
PRELIMINARY GAPS ACKNOWLEDGING
THERE'S STILL SOMEWORK TO BE
DONE ON SERVICE STATE BUDGETING
HAS SO THIS PROPOSAL PROVIDES
ADDITIONAL AND YOU ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND INVESTMENT. WE'RE
CLOSING CONTINUATION OF THE
PREVIOUSLY LIMITED TERM GENERAL
FUND INVESTMENT BUT WE'RE ALSO
LOOKING AT INTERNALLY WHERE CAN
WE LOOK AT OUR EXISTING
RESOURCES- AND PRIORITIZE THOSE
AS WELL AS LOOKING AT THE
HABITAT CONSERVATION FUND AND
HAVING DISCUSSIONS WITH ALL THE
CONSERVATION BOARD WE'VE
IDENTIFIED FOR THOSE PURPOSES
THAT THE HABITAT CONSERVATION
FUND CAN BE USED. THERE'S
APPROXIMATELY THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR STILL
AVAILABLE FROM PREVIOUS BOND
FUNDS- DIFFERENT FUND SOURCES-
AND PREVIOUSLY AUTHORIZED-
HABITAT CONSERVATION FUND-
MONEY THAT HAVEN'T BEEN AWARDED
YET THEY'RE STILL A GOOD AMOUNT
OF FUNDING AVAILABLE TO THE
WILDLIFE CONSERVATION FOR THESE
RELATED GRANTS AND AS PART OF
PROP ONE SEVEN. RECALL THAT.
THE DAY BETWEEN PROP NINETY
NINE REVENUE AND THIRTY MILLION
BE- PROVIDED BY THE GENERAL
FUND AS A PART OF AYE I DON'T I
DON'T THINK YOU'RE GETTING THE-
A TO THE HEART OF MY QUESTION
LAST YEAR DURING THE BUDGET
PROCESS THERE WAS A VERY
CAREFULLY- NEGOTIATED
COMPROMISE THAT EXTENDED THE
SUNSET DATE FOR THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION FUND RIGHT. I
EXCUSE ME THAT HABITAT
CONSERVATION FUND. HI AND THAT
IS BEING UNDONE IN THE CURRENT
BUDGET PROPOSAL. SO WHAT I ATE
MY FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION IS. IF
THERE'S A DEAL THAT'S CUT. DOES
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FEEL LIKE
A IT CAN JUST ARBITRARILY BE-
UNDONE BECAUSE THAT'S THE WAY
IT FEELS TO ME AND I THINK TO-
BUDGET STAFF- WE HAVE TO BE
ABLE TO. NEGOTIATE IN GOOD
FAITH WITH ONE ANOTHER THERE
MAY BE VERY VALID REASONS FOR
ON DOING THIS BUT IT'S A DEAL
AND IF IT'S GONNA BE UNDONE IT
OUGHT TO BE ON DONE BY BOTH
SIDES OF THE DEAL SO IF YOU
COULD RESPOND TO THAT SPECIFIC
ISSUE I'D APPRECIATE IT. YES I
THINK THE ONE THING ON THE IN
TERMS THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
AT BEING PROPOSED HERE AS
THOUGH WE ARE ARE NOT BUILDING
TO SUNSET THE HABITAT
CONSERVATION FUND THE HABITAT
CONSERVATION FUND GETS REVENUES
FROM BOTH PROP NINETY NINE AND
THE GENERAL FUND. THE HABITAT
CONSERVATION OF WILL CONTINUE
RECEIVING REVENUE FROM PROP
NINETY NINE SO THAT'S GOING TO
CONTINUE TO GO INTO THAT POND-
IS JUST THE PORTION THAT'S
BEING SON CITED IF THE GENERAL
FUND PORTION AND AGAIN- YOU
KNOW THIS IS OUR PROPOSAL BUT-
ONLY A PARTIAL ABROGATION OF
THE DEAL. CHAIR IS THAT
ACCURATE. WHAT I WOULD SAVE
WE'RE PROPOSING IS STILL WE
WILL CONSIDER WITHIN THE
SPIRITS OF- WHAT THE USES ARE
IN TERMS OF SUPPORTING THE
PARTITION WALL LIFE FOR THEIR-
EFFORTS- WITH EFFICIENCY IN
PERMITTING FOR RESTORATION
PROJECT. ACKNOWLEDGING THERE IS
STILL SIGNIFICANT OF FUNDING
AVAILABLE FOR THOSE PURPOSES
AVAILABLE FOR THE CAUGHT
HABITAT ONSERVATION FUND
WITHIN THE WALL AYE
CONSERVATION BOARD. WHICH
CHAPLAIN MATH MANNER JECT OF
COURSE. I VERY MUCH NOTE YOUR
QUESTION AND UNDERSTAND IT. I
FULLY EXPECT PUBLIC SPEAKERS
WILL ALSO EXPECT. SUPPRESSED
FRUSTRATION I KNOW THIS I. ALSO
REALIZE THE RECOMMENDATION IS
TO HOLD THE ITEM OPEN. WE HAVE
DAYS AND WEEKS AHEAD OF US AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO ENGAGING WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WITHIN THE ADMINISTRATION AND
YOU AND THE RELEVANT BUDGET
COMMITTEES ON THIS GOING
FORWARD. A YEAR A CHARMER
MISTER BONNER. I HAVE NO DOUBT
THAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE
CONTINUING CONVERSATIONS ON- ON
THIS ITEM I THINK IT'S- I DID
THAT THE ISSUE THAT I'M
IDENTIFYING I THINK IS AN
IMPORTANT ONE BECAUSE IT
AFFECTS THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THE BRANCHES- LET'S
HEAR FROM THE LA- ON THIS. AND
THE- IF THERE'S NO QUESTIONS
FROM THE DIS WILL THEN MOVE TO
PUBLIC COMMENT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RACHEL EHLERS WITH THAT
ALEJO OUT SO THAT THE PROPOSAL
BEFORE YOU HAS THREE COMPONENTS
THE ONE WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT IS THE ONGOING NEW
ONGOING FUNDING ON NINETEEN
MILLION THAT WOULD BE SHIFTED
IN GENERAL FUND- I THINK OUR
ADVICE TO HEAR IS THAT IT
REALLY IS A WEIGHING OF TRADE
OFFS OF WHAT ARE YOUR GENERAL
FUND PRIORITIES AND WHAT ARE
YOUR CONSERVATION PRIORITIES
OBVIOUSLY ADOPTING THE- AND GOT
THERE THERE'S CLEARLY IN NEED.
AT THE AD DEPARTMENT FISH AND
WILDLIFE WE THINK THOSE THE
INITIAL RESULTS OF THE SERVICE
BASE BUDGET HAVE REVIEW HAVE
HIGHLIGHTED THAT SO DO YOU VIEW
THERE BEING A GREATER NEED AT
FISH WILDLIFE VERSES WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD DO YOU
BELIEVE THERE NEEDS AT BOTH AND
THEREFORE WHEN APPROPRIATE
ADDITIONAL GENERAL FUND. DO YOU
WANT TO WAIT ANOTHER YEAR UNTIL
WE HAVE MORE RESULTS YOU KNOW
IT'S REALLY WE DON'T HAVE AN
EASY ANSWER FOR YOU ON THIS ONE
IT'S REALLY WAITING THAT TADE
OFFS FOR THE OTHER TWO
COMPONENTS- FOR THE ONE TIME
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
GENERAL FUND BASIC BASICALLY
FOR EQUIPMENT PURPOSES THAT
PURCHASES. WE THINK THAT IS
JUSTIFIED BY THE DEPARTMENT
AND- WOULD RECOMMEND APPROVING
THAT PIECE AND THEN THE FINAL
PIECE THERE. ADMINISTRATION IS
PROPOSING APPROVING NOW TWENTY
THREE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
BUDGET YOUR PLUS ONE FOR THE
FUNDING SHORTFALL THAT WILL
EMERGE THERE AFTER THE THREE
YEARS A FUNDING EXPIRES WE
THINK IT'S PREMATURE TO APPROVE
THAT NOW WE WOULD RECOMMEND TO
FOR THAT DECISION. UNTIL NEXT
YEAR WHEN YOU HAVE THE FULL
RESULTS OF THE SERVICE BASE
BUDGET REVIEW AND CAN
UNDERSTAND ALL OF THE DIFFERENT
REVENUE THE DEPARTMENT HAS
AVAILABLE. BERMAN FINANCE CITY.
CONTENT YOU TEAR BLOOM AMBER
MORNING SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS
ARE MILLION WITH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- I'D LIKE TO SAY THE
ADMINISTRATION REMAINS
COMMITTED TO ADVANCING THE
DEPARTMENT'S ABILITY TO MEET
ITS MISSION. THE THREE YEAR
APPROPRIATION THAT STARTED IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN SUPPORTS
A- THAT HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED AS
HAVING THE LARGEST- SERVICE
GAPS. IN THE PRELIMINARY DATA
FOR THE SERVICE BASED
BUDGETING. AND SO IT IS TRUE
THAT THE FUNDING IT DOES NOT
EXPIRE UNTIL NEXT YEAR. BUT
AUTHORIZING PERMANENT FUNDING
IN THIS PRESENTS BUDGET- WILL
ALLOW FOR A CONTINUOUSLY
COMPREHENSIVE MULTI YEAR
ACCOUNTS. OF PROJECTED GENERAL
FUND SPENDING. AND FURTHERMORE
THE ADMINISTRATION BELIEVES- IT
IS APPROPRIATE TO PROVIDE THE
DEPARTMENT WITH CERTAINTY. WITH
PLANNING AND THE RETENTION OF
STAFF FOR IT THAT IT WHOM- IT
HAS HIRED- TO PERFORM THE ADD
ACTIVITIES. FUNDED BY THIS
APPROPRIATION. THANK YOU. ALL
VERY LAUDABLE GOALS MR BONTA
I'D LIKE A CHANCE TO JUST SELL
IT A LITTLE BIT MORE. WITH SOME
SPECIFIC EXAMPLES. THE THIRTY
EIGHT MILLION I THINK AND I
HAVE TO MAKE IT QUICK THAT'S AS
WE ARE UNDERSTOOD THE THIRTY
EIGHT MILLION U. SPLIT INTO YOU
CAN SPLIT INTO. TWO ASPECTS
THERE'S TWENTY MILLION ONE TIME.
WE WANT TO MODERNIZE OUR
HATCHERIES BY EIGHTEEN
EXHORTING FACILITY MACHINES
FORTY THREE NEW TRUCKS THAT'LL
MAKE SURE WE CAN GET FISH MORE
SAFELY WITH LOWER LABOR COST
OUT FOR ANGLERS. WE WANT TO
MODERNIZE OUR WATER CONVEYANCE
SYSTEM AND SWITCH ALL DIESEL
PUMPS TO SOLAR ARRAYS. AND THAT
WILL REDUCE OUR OWN EMISSIONS
AND AUTOMATE OUR WATER DELIVERY
TO KEEP WETLANDS WEDDED FOR
WILDLIFE AND FOR DUCK HUNTERS.
WE WANT TO BUY ONE NEW PLANE WE
HAVE SEVEN PLANES SIX OF THEM
DATE THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES.
HAVING A PLANE AVAILABLE WITH
MODERN CONFIGURATION WILL ALLOW
US TO MONITOR THE OCEAN KEEP
OUR EYES ON WHALES AS THEY'RE
MIGRATING AND HELP AVOID
COMMERCIAL FISHING GEAR. THAT'S
TWENTY MILLION ONE TIME THE LA-
RECOMMENDS I THINK THAT IT'S A
WISE INVESTMENT. THEN YOU GET
TODAY EIGHTEEN POINT SIX THAT
HAS THE CONTROVERSY AROUND THE
FUNDS WORSE. THAT WOULD GO INTO
THREE PROGRAM AREAS. YOU HEARD
SECRETARY CROWFOOT ABOUT HIS
BIO DIVERSITY INTEREST WE WOULD
PUT SEVEN PEOPLE AND ONE POINT
TWO NINE NINE MILLION ENDED UP
BY A DIVERSITY WE OWN A MILLION
ACRES. WE ARE NOT DOING WELL
ENOUGH MAKING THOSE LANDS
AVAILABLE TO DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND INTRODUCING
OURSELVES TO ALL OF CALIFORNIA
WE WANT TO DO THAT WE WANTED TO
CLIMATE ASSESSMENTS ACROSS ALL
OUR LANDS. WE OWN LANDS ALONG
THE COASTAL STRIP THAT IF WE
RESTORE THEM IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENT WE CAN
CREATE AT SEA LEVEL RISE BUFFER
USING OUR LANDS. THE NEXT
CATEGORY CUT GREEN TAPE. WE
NEED TO DO MORE RESTORATION
PROJECTS FASTER SOONER AT
GREATER SCALE AND OFTEN WE
INHIBIT THE DOING OF THEM WITH
OUR OWN PERMITTING REQUIREMENTS
WE'RE GOING TO CREATE A TEAM OF
FIFTEEN PEOPLE. LAWYER GRANT
MAKER ACCOUNTING CONTRACTING
PLANNER WE'RE GONNA PUT HIM IN
THE NORTHERN PART OF CALIFORNIA
FROM SAN FRANCISCO TO THE
OREGON BORDER WITH TIMBER WITH
CINEMA COUNTY WATER AGENCY AND
WITH TRIBES AND CONSERVATION
GROUPS WE ARE GOING TO
ACCELERATE THE PACE OF
RESTORATION TO BRING SAM BACK.
LAST ISSUE. I SEE THE PROGRAM.
WE PUT THIRTY ONE PEOPLE
UNHEARD OF. IMPROVEMENT FIRE
DEPARTMENT AND TEN MILLION
DOLLARS INTO OUR SEATS PROGRAM
THE CALIFORNIA ENDANGERED
SPECIES ACT. WE HAVE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY ANIMALS AND
PLANTS THAT ARE PROTECTED UNDER
STATE LAW THAT GENERATES ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED PERMITS A YEAR WE
HAVE TO DEAL WITH JUST IN THE
LAST EIGHTEEN MONTHS WE'VE GOT
ANOTHER DOZEN PETITIONS TO LIST
SPECIES. AND WE HAVEN'T EVEN
STARTED TO DO. HOW DO YOU GET
HIM OFF THE LIST AND HOW DO YOU
DO RECOVERY. THESE FIFTEEN
PEOPLE WON'T LET US DO THAT FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN MY CAREER AT
THE DEPARTMENT. SO WITH THAT I
APPRECIATE THE EXTRA MINUTES.
THANK YOU FOR THAT ADDITIONAL
AMOUNT OF DETAIL QUESTION.
RIGHT LET'S SOME WITH PUBLIC
COMMENT. IT WAS MORNING OR
AFTERNOON AT THIS POINT- CAN
DELFINO REPRESENTING DEFENDERS
OF WILDLIFE I'M I'M JUST GONNA
START WITH WHAT WE'RE
SUPPORTING RIGHT NOW BECAUSE
THAT'S QUICK- WE ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE ONE TIME
FUNDING THAT. THAT IT'S BEEN
PROPOSED HERE WE ARE SUPPORTIVE
OF THE EXTENSION OF THE THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS THAT IS A
CONTINUATION OF SORT OF THE
DEAL THAT CAME TOGETHER THAT
LAUNCHED INTO THE SERVICE BASED
BUDGETING EFFORT. HOWEVER AS
IT'S ALREADY BEEN DISCUSSED OUR
BIG CONCERN RIGHT NOW IS- THE
DELETION OF THE- SUNSET DATE I
AND ESSENTIALLY THE ELIMINATION
OF THE HABITAT CONSERVATION
COUNTRY TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
AND ALSO THE FUN SHIFT OF
HABITAT CONSERVATION FUND
MONEY. TO OF EIGHTEEN POINT
NINE MILLION TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE TO FIND
WHAT ARE EXTREMELY LAUDABLE
PROGRAM SO LET ME JUST START
FIRST OF ALL WE DO NOT HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH WHAT THEY'RE
PROPOSING TO FIND WITH THE
EIGHTEEN POINT NINE MILLION AS
SOMEONE WHO WORKED ON
ENDANGERED SPECIES ISSUES. FOR
TWENTY FIVE YEARS THE
DEPARTMENT IS LONG OVERDUE IN
GETTING THE STAFFING- FOR THE
ENDANGERED SPECIES PROGRAM THEY
HAVE A FULL TIME AT THE
DEPARTMENT RIGHT NOW JUST THE
FULL TIME PEOPLE ONLY DOING
DANGER SPECIES MY UNDERSTANDING
FIVE PEOPLE FOR THE ENTIRE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THAT'S
RIDICULOUS SO WE THINK THAT
THERE'S DEFINITELY AND OF A
STRONG CASE TO BE MADE FOR WHAT
THEY'RE PROPOSING TO FIND THE
PROBLEM IS FUND SOURCE BECAUSE
AS YOU WELL NOTED LAST YEAR A
DEAL CAME TOGETHER TO EXTEND
THE HABITAT CONSERVATION FUND
FOR TEN MORE YEARS. TO WRITE
THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
OF GUARANTEED FUNDING FOR
CONSERVATION IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT IS MONEY THAT
GOES TO STATE PARKS THAT'S
MONEY THAT GOES TO OCEAN THE
COASTAL CONSERVANCY TAHOE
CONSERVANCY LOCAL PARK DISTRICT
GRANTS AND A CHUNK OF MONEY THE
EIGHTEEN POINT NINE TO THE
WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD.
WHO USES THAT MONEY AND
SOMEONE'S WELL SMALL GRANTS
AROUND THE STATE WELL THOSE ARE
MONIES THAT ARE SPECIFICALLY
IDENTIFIED FOR MOUNTAIN LION
HABITAT CONSERVE. FOR INLAND
WETLANDS- ACQUISITION
CONSISTENT WITH STATES
OBLIGATION. PART AS PART. FOR A
LOT FAT WHAT'S YOUR VISION AND-
VALLEY PRO IMPROVEMENT ACT FOR
RIGHT CARRYING HABITAT. WE
DIDN'T GO DOWN THIS PATH OF
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE TO GET
INCREASED FUNDING. IF IT'S
GOING TO TURN OUT THAT THEY
WOULD ESSENTIALLY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WOULD
ESSENTIALLY RAID ANOTHER FUN
SOURCE. AND SHIFT THAT MONEY
OVER THAT'S YOU KNOW ROBBING
PETER TO PAY PAUL. SO WE WILL-
WE BELIEVE THAT THE DEAL WAS A
DEAL LAST YEAR THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE SHOULD BE REJECTED.
BECAUSE IT WOULD ESSENTIALLY
GOT OUT THE FULL THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR THAT WE BELIEVED
WAS GOING TO BE GOING TO THE W.
C. B. AND THEN IT SAYS. THE DIP
IN THE BEEN IT DOES NOT PROVIDE
GUARANTEED FUNDING BECAUSE ONCE
THE HABITAT CONSERVATION FUND
IS ELIMINATED. AND GOES AWAY.
THAT BECOMES NOW GENERAL FUND
MONEY SO WHATEVER ADDITIONAL
AUGMENTATION TO GO TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE. THAT'S GENERAL FUND
MONEY AND AS WE ALL KNOW THAT
MONEY DISAPPEARS. ANY TIME
THERE'S AN ECONOMIC DOWNTURN
THAT IS NOT CERTAIN FUNDING AT
ALL FOR THE DEPARTMENT. SO WE
BELIEVE THAT THE PROPOSAL
REALLY VIOLATES THE SPIRIT OF
THIS SERVICE BASED BUDGETING
EXERCISE THAT WE'VE GONE A
LONG. AND IS REALLY
DISAPPOINTING TO US THAT THIS
IS HOW THE ADMINISTRATION WANTS
TO PROPOSE. ACTUALLY PROTECTING%
ITS BIODIVERSITY FOR THAT
REASON WE WOULD URGE THAT YOU
HOLD OPEN. THE W. STUDY- BC P.
FOR THE DEPARTMENT AT THIS
POINT UNTIL WE CAN WORK THROUGH
THE FUND SOURCE. OF FOR THAT
EIGHTEEN POINT NINE MILLION
DOLLARS OF REALLY IMPORTANT
PROGRAM THANK YOU. MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JENNIFER
FEARING HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE MOUNTAIN LION FOUNDATION- I
WANT TO START BY JUST PUBLICLY
THANKING DIRECTOR BERMAN AND
HIS TEAM FOR THEIR SWIFT AND
PROTECTIVE RESPONSES OVER THE
PAST FEW WEEKS- TO HELP. US PUT
THE STATE ON A PATH TO
DECREASING MOUNTAIN LION
MORTALITY AND TO ADVANCING NEW
LEGAL PROTECTIONS FOR MOUNTAIN
LIONS- AT NOT LAND ON NATION
WAS THE ORIGINAL PROPONENTS. OF
PROP ONE SEVENTEEN PASSED BY
VOTERS IN NINETEEN NINETY THAT
CREATED THE HABITAT
CONSERVATION FUND AND THE
THIRTY YEARS OF THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS OF YOUR FUNDING THAT.
WAS SET ACCORDING TO THE
PROPOSITION TO EXPIRE THIS YEAR
THAT LAST YEAR AS WE'VE ALL
DISCUSSED WAS AGREED TO BY THE
LEGISLATURE IN ADMINISTRATION
TO BE EXTENDED FOR ANOTHER TEN
YEARS. WE AGREE THAT THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE SHOULD
BE- REJECTED FOR THE REASONS
THAT CAN MADE BUT ALSO FROM A
LEGAL PERSPECTIVE THAT LANGUAGE
OF THE PROPOSITION REQUIRES
THAT AMENDMENTS. FURTHER THE
PURPOSE AND INTENT. OF THE
INITIATIVE WHICH TAKING THIS
MONEY AWAY- A IT DOES NOT DO.
SECONDLY IT ONLY AUTHORIZES AN
EXTENSION WHICH HAPPENED LAST
YEAR OR REPEAL. OF THE SUNSET
NOW THAT THE LANGUAGE IS WHAT
IS TODAY THANKS TO THE CHANGES
LAST YEAR IT'S SIMPLY NOT
AUTHORIZED- IT TO MAKE A CHANGE
THAT ELIMINATE. THAT FAMILY
PERSPECTIVE. AND FINALLY IT
SEEMS CLEAR THAT IN A BEST CASE
SCENARIO WITH THE- PREVIOUS
THINGS I SAID WORK PROBLEMATIC
YOU THIS WOULD TRIGGER A FOUR
FIFTHS VOTE- THRESHOLD WHICH IS
REQUIRED BY. THE INITIATIVE SO
WE- HAVE A SERIOUS SERIOUS
LEGAL CONCERNS ABOUT WHAT'S
BEEN PROPOSED TRAILER BILL-
WITH REGARD TO THE B. C. P. AS
A LONG TIME- ADVOCATE I WAS
INVOLVED WITH THE AB TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY SIX- STAKEHOLDER-
PROCESS INVESTED HUNDREDS AND
HUNDREDS OF. HOURS PART OF THAT
PROCESS THE DECADE AND IT. HIT
FOR TO. WITHIN THE SERVICE
BUDGET EFFORT WE CERTAINLY
HEART. BY THE DEPARTMENTS
EMBRACE OF THAT PROCEDURE AND
SO FAR THE RESULTS HAVE
YIELDED- EVIDENCE THAT'S SEE
VERY CONSISTENT WITH OUR OWN
EXPERIENCE THAT HAS BEEN RE
IMPOSSIBLE TO SUBSTANTIAL A
CREDIBLE EIGHT. MAKE OF A CASE
HERE IN THE LETTER. FOR
ADDITIONAL FUNDING SO. WE
CONSIDER IT AN OVER ARCHING
PRIORITY THAT HE SERVICE BASE
BUDGET LEAD TO NOTHING SHORT OF
A TRANSFORMATION. IN THE WAY
THAT WE COMMIT TO SUSTAINABLE
FUNDING FOR FISH AND WILDLIFE
PRIORITIES. AND WHILE THE BCP
INCLUDE SEVERAL IMPORTANT
PROPOSE INVESTMENTS NOTABLY FOR
THE CEASE A REVIEW IN RECOVERY
PROGRAMS WHICH IS A TRACK
MOUNTAIN LIONS ARE VERY MUCH ON
AT THIS MOMENT. WE KNOW THIS IS
JUST THE START- WE NEED AN
INCREASE IN INVESTMENT IN
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING TO
RECONNECT HABITATS AND DECREASE
VEHICLE COLLISIONS WE NEED TO
EXPAND WILDLIFE LAW ENFORCEMENT
CAPACITY. AN INCREASE CO
EXISTENCE STRATEGIES AND
PROGRAM SO WE'RE DEEPLY HOPEFUL
THAT WE ARE ON THE PRECIPICE OF
REAL TRANSFORMATION AT A
CRITICAL MOMENT IN THE
DEPARTMENT'S HISTORY. AND SO
THAT THE IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT
THE LEGISLATURE THE
ADMINISTRATION AND STAKEHOLDERS
ARE ALL ALLIES IN DEVELOPING
THAT VISION THANK YOU. MORNING
IN HIS CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M FURTHER ALONG ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA NATIVE
PLANT SOCIETY AS WELL AS
CALIFORNIA TROUT. AND TRAVEL
LIMITED. I WOULD LIKE TO JUST
THE LINE COMMENTS MADE BY-
MISTER FINO BEHALF DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE I AM VERY MUCH.
CONCERNED ABOUT THE- THE
REVERSION ON THE EXTENSION OF
THE H. C. F. LOOK FROM LAST
YEAR- IN PARTICULAR WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT- YOU KNOW AS AS
MENTIONED STATE BECAUSE THE
CONSERVANCY GETS- FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY FROM THAT FUND
AS WELL AS STATE PARKS GETS
FOUR POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY FROM THAT FUND. WHICH
UNDOING OF THE EXTENSION WOULD
ABSOLUTELY MAKE IT EASY FOR
THAT MONEY TO GO. INTO OTHER
PURPOSES IN THE GENERAL FUND-
THE REAL THE GREAT CONCERN
THERE IS THAT THE H. C. F.
DOLLARS DON'T HAVE THE SAME
LIMITATIONS THAT BOND DOLLARS
DO. I GUESS ABSOLUTELY W. CITY
DOES HAVE A LOT OF BOND. MONIES
AVAILABLE TO THEM BUT AS WE ALL
KNOW IN THIS COMMITTEE IN
DISCUSSIONS WE HAD LAST YEAR.
THAT'S VERY LIMITED YOU CAN'T
DO A LOT OF THE PROGRAM BEING
AN ADDITIONAL ACTIVITIES THAT
WE WANT TO SEE AND CONTINUE TO
SEE. AN A PARTICULAR AS IT
RELATES TO THE STATE PARKS
FUNDING- ABSOLUTELY WE ARE
THERE WE WANT TO BE AS
SUPPORTIVE AS WE CAN BE. FOR
ALL THE THINGS THAT ARE
PROPOSED TO BE FOR AND IN THE-
BUDGET PROPOSAL. ON INCLUDING
THE TWENTY MILLION ONE TIME.
THE ONGOING GENERAL FUND AND IN
THIS CASE THE TRAVERSE BIT YOU
KNOW WE WOULD BE HAPPY TO
SUPPORT GENERAL FUND GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION FUND- I THINK WE
CAN GET CREATIVE ON ON TRYING
TO IDENTIFY ADDITIONAL FUNDING-
THAT BECAUSE WE ALSO. AGREE
THAT EVERYTHING THAT WAS LISTED
IN THERE IS ARE THINGS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT SHOULD BE DOING AND
CONTINUE TO DO AND AUGMENT
AUGMENTING THEIR STAFF IS GONNA
BE CRITICAL TO FOR THEM TO
ACHIEVE THOSE OBJECTIVES- SO
FOR ALL THOSE REASONS- WE
OPPOSE. THE X. THE
EXTINGUISHMENT OF THE OF THE
EXPANSION OF HDF- BUT
ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR ALL THE TINGS THAT
ARE OUTLINED IN THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL THANK YOU. WELL LET ME
DOWN A WITHOUT A CAL. WILL BUT
WE WILL LIKE TO ALIGN
OURSELVES- WITH THE COMMENTS OF
THE PREVIOUS THREE SPEAKERS- WE
WANT TO SEE A RESILIENT
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
YOU WANNA SEE RESILIENCY. AND
WILDLIFE THAT WE HAVE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. BUT WE CANNOT BE
DOING THAT AT THE EXPENSE OF.
ACTUALLY PUTTING PROJECTS ON
THE GROUND THAT CREATE HABITAT.
THAT CREATE OPEN SPACE- IN
PARKS IN AND AREAS THAT WE
THINK. WE NEED AROUND THE
STATE. THE DIRECTOR SAID SO
HIMSELF HE WANTS TO SEE A
DEPARTMENT THAT. IS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. UNFORTUNATELY
WHAT WE SEEN OUR LEADS FROM
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS THAT.
IT'S EASIER TO SUPPLY A LOT OF
THE MONEY THAT. WOULD JOB BE
FUNDING- NATURAL RESOURCES IN
EXCHANGE FOR MONTHS RIGHT AND
WE LIKE ONES WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE BONDS BUT THAT'S DREADED
TRADITIONALLY HOW WE'VE BEEN
PAYING FOR NATURAL RESOURCES I
THINK THAT WE NEED TO TAKE A
HARD LOOK AT US TO WE NEED TO
CHANGE THAT MINDSET ESPECIALLY
WITHIN DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
IS HOW THEY- WHEN THEY CHOOSE
TO. THINK OF NATURAL RESOURCES
THEY THEY WANT TO PLAY. NATURAL
RESOURCES WITH A CREDIT CARD IN
A VERY EXPENSIVE MONEY AND WE
THINK THAT WE SHOULD BE DOING
AND THINKING IT ABOUT THIS SO
MUCH DIFFERENTLY THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN JAMIE GO ON
BEHALF OF LATINO OUTDOORS WE
WANNA ECHO MANY OF THE COMMENTS
THAT WE WERE JUST PREVIOUSLY
MADE AND WE SHARE MANY OF THE
SAME FRUSTRATIONS WITH THE FUN
SHIP FROM H. C. F. BUT THAT
BEING SAID WE DO WANT TO
EXPRESS THAT- THE YEAR. FUNDING
FOR EDUCATION AND OUTREACH THAT
IS PROPOSED IS SOMETHING THAT
WE THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
ESPECIALLY AS IT RELATES TO
REACHING OUT TO DIVERSE THAT'S
A COMMUNITY. AND MAKING
SHOULDN'T COMMUNITIES IN MAKING
SURE THAT THERE IS AWARENESS
ABOUT BIODIVERSITY AND CLIMATE
RISKS AND WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
RESOURCES TAKEN OR OTHER
RESOURCES FOR THOSE KINDS OF
ACTIVITIES THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
LOOK AT FACTS ABOUT THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY WE'VE OBVIOUSLY
BEEN VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
SERVICE BASED BUDGETING
PROCESS. AND STAKEHOLDER GROUP
AS WELL BUT WE ALSO WE THINK
IT'S YOU HAVE TO BE IS ON THE
RIGHT TRACK BUT YET THEY'RE
STILL A LOT OF WORK TO DO. I
THINK. YOU KNOW WE CERTAINLY
SUPPORT ADEQUATE FUNDING FOR
CFW BUT THE- TENSION ALL SHIFT
OF HCF IS TO COMPLETELY
UNACCEPTABLE. YEAH I THINK
CHAIR BLOOM HAS IT RIGHT YOU
KNOW IF THE DEAL HAS BEEN
STRUCK WITH THE LEGISLATURE IN
ADMINISTRATION DOES THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCE FEEL IT CAN
ARBITRARILY BE AND DONE. I
PERSONALLY BELIEVE THE ANSWER
IS NO AND I THINK THAT WE WILL
CERTAINLY SUPPORT ADEQUATE
FUNDING- FOR TO GET W. BUT NOT
BY USING A CF AND APPRECIATE
YOU ALL- KEEPING THIS ITEM OPEN
WE ALSO CONTINUE DEPRECIATE THE
BILL TO WORK WITH- THE
DEPARTMENT- AS WE SORT OF TRY
TO FIGURE THIS PARTICULAR SHOUT
THANK YOU. THE MORNING PAUL
MASONS THAT FOREST TRUST ALL
DISASSOCIATE MYSELF ALL THE
PRIOR COMMENTS WHICH REALLY OF
SAID MUCH WITH THE NEEDS TO BE
SAID. AND SIMPLY ADD THAT THE
IDEA THAT WE WOULD FIND. THE
ABILITY OF THE DEPARTMENT TO
MEET SOME OF THEIR CORE
STATUTORY AND PUBLIC TRUST
RESPONSIBILITIES. BY CUTTING
ONE OF THE FEW STABLE SOURCES
OF CONSERVATION FUNDING IS JUST.
UNACCEPTABLE THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS THAT RAN WITH
THEIR AND READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PROFESSIONAL
SCIENTIST WE SUPPORT THE
PROPOSAL IN AS MUCH AS A
PROVIDES FIFTY EIGHT NEW
POSITIONS FORTY ONE OF WHICH
OUR STATE SCIENTIFIC POSITIONS
POSITIONS ARE SORELY NEED FOR
THE DEPARTMENT TO WHAT TO DO
THEIR JOB AND WE CERTAINLY HOPE
THAT WHEN YOU REACH AN
UNDERSTANDING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION IN THE LEAD THAT
YOU INCLUDE THOSE FIFTY EIGHT
POSITIONS- IN WHATEVER
AGREEMENT YOU REACH. THANK YOU.
HELLO MORNING CAMINO BEHALF THE
PENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT AND SAVE THE REDWOODS
LEAGUE. ALSO TO REITERATE THE
COMMENTS MADE BY SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES ABOUT A CONCERN
ABOUT THE DIVERSION OF THE
HABITAT CONSERVATION FUND THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING PUBLIC OURS
WITH ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE
FUND- ONE ECHO THE COMMENTS. IN
AROUND CONCERNS ABOUT THE
HABITAT CONSERVATION FUND
SHIFT- SINCE CAME ALREADY USE
THE ANALOGY I WAS GONNA USE OF
ROBBING PETER TO PAY PAUL ALL
USE A DIFFERENT ONE IT. FEELS
LIKE WE WERE BEING PRESENTED
WITH A FALSE CHOICE YEAR IN
ENVIRONMENTS MANY WE HAVE TO.
THERE'S SOME HAVE A CHOICE
BETWEEN THE ECONOMY OR THE
ENVIRONMENT. WE KNOW WE CAN DO
BOTH I THINK IN THIS CASE WE
KNOW WE CAN DO BOTH WE CAN HAVE
A ROBUST. WELL STAFF WILL
RESOURCE DEPARTMENT TO CARRY
OUT ITS MISSION. THE WAY WITH
INTENDED AND WE CAN HAVE
FUNDING FOR THE PROJECTS THAT.
THE A TF HAS FUNDED OVER THE
YEARS SO. HOPEFULLY WE CAN COME
UP WITH- RESOLUTIONS OF ISSUE.
WE OPPOSE THE SHIFT. OF THIS
THE DIVISION OF A SUNSET
MISSION. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING MARK SMITH ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA WATERFOWL
ASSOCIATION WRESTLING WATER
DISTRICT WILL ASSOCIATE
OURSELVES WITH THE COMMENTS
PREVIOUSLY MADE ON H. C. F. DO
FEEL COMPELLED TO SHORTLY TALK
ABOUT THE GENERAL FUND BUDGET
ISSUE I APPRECIATE ONE.
BRINGING THAT ISSUE UP- I THESE
ARE PUBLIC TRUSTVALUES. ARE
NATURAL RESOURCES IN OUR
ENVIRONMENT AND WE DO NEED TO
SPEND MORE GENERAL FUND REVENUE
ON THEM. WORKING WITH MY
CLIENTS THIS YEAR TO INCREASE
HUNTING LICENSE FEES IN ORDER
TO HELP FUND PROGRAMS OF THE
DEPARTMENT. THE USER COMMUNITY
WILL CONTINUE TO PAY. BUT THE
REALITY IS WE CAN'T DO IT ON
OUR OWN. BUDGETS HAVE BEEN
GOING UP SIGNIFICANTLY THEY
WENT UP FIFTY BILLION DOLLARS
UNDER GOVERNOR BROWN SLEATER
SHIP ALONE. AND WE WERE
DEBATING FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
TO FUND THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE. EIGHT IF WE CAN'T
FIND THE WAY TO FUND THE
DEPARTMENT. WHEN WE HAVE THE
SURPLUS REVENUES AND CREATE AN
ONGOING REVENUE SOURCE FOR
THEM. IT'S SHAMEFUL FOR ALL OF
US THE ADVOCATES THE
LEGISLATURE THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE EVERYBODY. WE SHOULD BE
MAKING THESE INVESTMENTS THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING STEVE WALL
COMING OF THE CALVARY TAL
ALLIANCE RUSTLER SHARE CONCERNS
WITH THE CHANGE THE HAVE A
CONVERSATION. HABITAT
CONSERVATION FUND- SINCE THAT
DATE CHANGE SO. THANKS LAST BUT
NOT LEAST MARKETS TO MAKE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICTS TACKLE
ALL THE COMMENTS OF THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKERS. POST THE FUN
SHIFT SUPPORT THE MISSION OF
WHAT THE FUNDING WOULD BE FOR
BY WE DON'T WANT TO SEE MY TAKE
AWAY FROM HABITAT CUTS RESPONSE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. YOU
THOUGHT YOUR LIFE EVEN LEAST.%
DECK USED TO REPRESENTING THIS
YEAR BUSINESS COUNCIL WANTED
OUR LINE MY- COMMENTS WITH A
LOT OF THE COLLEAGUES IN REJECT
THE BUDGET TRAILER BILL. WHICH
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS AND
THANK YOU FOR THE PRESENTATIONS
ISSUE THREE WAS INFORMATIONAL
ONLY ISSUE FOR WERE HOLDING
OPEN AND WE WILL NOW- THANK YOU
AND MOVE ON TO DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES. WE'RE IN A DO
ISSUES FIVE AND SIX. RELATING
TO THE- NEW RIVER IMPROVEMENT
PROJECT IN THE TIJUANA RIVER
PROJECT. GOOD MORNING THE
MORNING. WELCOME THANK YOU-
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
CARLA NAME IS- AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES I AM PLEASED TO
BE HERE TO PRESENT THE
DEPARTMENT'S REMAINING BUDGET
PROPOSALTO YOU AND TO PROVIDE
THE SUBCOMMITTEE- WITH
RESPONSES TO YOUR QUESTION
SHOULD YOU HAVE ANY. IT'S AN
EXCITING TIME TO BE- DEEPLY
INVOLVED IN WATER RESOURCES
MANAGEMENT IN CALIFORNIA- WE DO
SO IN PARTNERSHIP WITH MANY
MANY LOCAL WATER DISTRICTS
FLOOD CONTROL AGENCIES NEWLY
FORMED SUSTAINABLE GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT AGENCIES ADMIRER
MENTAL GROUPS ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE GROUPS AGRICULTURAL
GROUPS AND I SAY THAT BECAUSE
IT REALLY TAKES A PARTNERSHIP
IN CALIFORNIA TO MANAGE WATER-
AND ENSURE THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE A SECURE
WATER SUPPLY INTO THE FUTURE. I
WANT TO START- BY PRESENTING IT
USED FIVE AND SIX TOGETHER IF I
COULD THEY DO HAVE SOME
SIMILARITIES IN THAT THEY ARE
BOTH CROSS BORDER WATER
TREATMENT. OF PROJECTS AND
OTHER QUESTIONS ON BOTH OF THEM
ABOUT ON GOING OPERATIONAL
COSTS. THE NEW RIVER
IMPROVEMENT PROJECT REQUESTS
TWENTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS-
TEN MILLION FROM THE GENERAL
FUND- AND- TWENTY EIGHT MILLION
FROM PROP SIXTY EIGHT TO DIVERT
TREAT AND RE WATER A NATURAL
RIVER COURSE. THE CITY OF
CALEXICO HAS COMMITTED TO
PROVIDING ONGOING OPERATIONS
AND MAINTENANCE FUNDING FOR THE
FACILITIES UP KEEP. THE TIJUANA
RIVER PROJECT IS SIMILARLY A
PROJECT TO CAPTURE POLLUTION.
THROUGH A SERIES OF
SEDIMENTATION AND DETENTION
BASINS TO REDUCE THE VOLUME OF
CONTAMINATED WATER TRASH AND
SETTLEMENT INTO THE TIJUANA
RIVER VALLEY ESTUARY. THE
BUDGET REQUEST THIRTY FIVE
MILLION IN GENERAL FUND FOR
THIS SERIES OF PROJECTS. THE
LA- HAS RAISED THE CONCERN OVER
ONGOING OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE COSTS OF THESE
FACILITIES AND I HAVE WITH ME
TODAY ERIC JARVIS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AGENCY WHO IS HERE
TO SPEAK TO THOSE ISSUES- IN
PARTICULAR SO ERIC I'LL- TURN
IT OVER TO YOU. THANK YOU
DIRECTOR NAME IT'S GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR SO MY MEMBER RIVAS
FOR THE RECORD JARVIS KELLY PA-
HAVE. ONE TO START WITH- A YOU
KNOW AS YOU KNOW THE NEW RIVER
IN TIJUANA RIVER- AS WELL AS
THE CANYON'S ADJACENT. ARE
POLLUTED WATER BODY SO THIS
BEGAN AS A WATER QUALITY ISSUE-
WHICH IS YOU KNOW IS IN THE
PURVIEW OF THE STATE MUTUAL%
WATER BOARDS AND SO I JUST.
WANTED TO RECOGNIZE IS A
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT BETWEEN
THE NATURAL RESOURCES WATER
RESOURCES AGENCY AND CAL EPA-
BUT BECAUSE THE SOLUTIONS
PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR
INVOLVED WATER INFRASTRUCTURE%
CONSTRUCTION. HE W. R. AS THE
IS IT THE EXPERT IN THAT AREA
AND SO WE'LL BE WATCHING
CLOSELY- HAS THESE PROJECTS
MOVE FORWARD. UP ALL ALL SHE TO
DIRECTOR HIM TOUCHED ON SEVERAL
HOURS BUT WHAT I WILL SAY IS
WHEN THE GOVERNOR AND BUILDING
JANUARY TEN BUDGET- HE
HIGHLIGHTED MANY AREAS THAT
NEED OUR ATTENTION SPECIFICALLY
RECOGNIZING THE SCALE AND%
IMMEDIACY. OF OUR CLIMATE
PROBLEM AND THE NEED TO
DRAMATICALLY INCREASE AND
LEVERAGE INVESTMENTS- THE NEW.
ANTI WANT TO REVERSE THE
NOTABLY BUT WE NEED TO BE- WE
NEED TO BE COMMITTED TO THIS
EFFORT AND SO- THE GOVERNOR'S
COMMITTED TO TACKLING LONG
STANDING CHALLENGES WON OR
SHARED BORDER WITH MEXICO. HE'S
ALSO COMMITTED TO FOSTERING NEW
OPPORTUNITIES TO BUILD BI
NATIONAL PARTNERSHIPS WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES ACROSS MEXICO IN
BAJA CALIFORNIA AND BAJA SIR-
YOU MAY RECALL LAST DECEMBER
THE GOVERNOR SIGNED THE
COMMISSION OF CALIFORNIA'S MO
MEMORANDUM OF UNDERSTANDING.
THIS SYMBOL YOU FURTHER ENABLES
US TO PARTNER WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES AT THE FEDERAL STATE
AND MUNICIPAL LEVELS IN MEXICO
JUST STREAM ON OUR ABILITY TO
ADDRESS SURE CHALLENGES INTO A
BRACE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
COLLABORATION. POLLUTION
CHALLENGES OF THE NEW IN
TIJUANA RIVERS IN ADDITION TO
AIR QUALITY MOBILITY
TRANSPORTATION OVERALL FORSMAN
CHALLENGES ARE HIGH PRAIRIE HI.
ALREADY AREAS THIS
COLLABORATION AND ARE AT THE
VERY HEART OF THE PRINCIPLES.
WITHIN THEM YOU. I'M AS AS THE
I WILL THAT WON'T AND CONTINUE
ON DESCRIBE THE- TO PROVOKE
UNLESS YOU HOUSES INSTRUCTOR
NAY ATTACHED IT. BUT QUICKLY I
JUST ONE TO HIGHLIGHT.
IMPLEMENTING THE NEW RIVER AND
TWO ONE RIVER- PROJECTS- OR-
CRITICAL IN OUR KEY STEP TO
SUPPORTING A GREENER AND
CLEANER RIVER THROUGHOUT
IMPERIAL COUNTY PARTICULARLY ON-THE RIVER AS IT FLOWS TOWARDS
THE SALTON SEA. AND WELL WE
HISTORICALLY LOOK TO FEDERAL
RESOURCES GETTING UP AT-
SUBCOMMITTEES QUESTION OR
HISTORICALLY LOOK TO FEDERAL
RESOURCES TO ASSIST WITH
POLLUTION REDUCTION ALONG THE
BORDER ALMOST EXCLUSIVELY BY
THE GOVERNOR HAS CHAMPIONED OUR
SUPPORT FOR REGIONAL AND LOCAL
CAPACITY TO ACHIEVE
IMPROVEMENTS AND WATER QUALITY
TO PROTECT CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES AND ARE VALUABLE
COASTLINE PARKS AND NATURAL
RESOURCES FROM MOSCOW ON ONE
WASTE DISCHARGES SO. WE GOT
ABOUT THE TEARS UP OVER THEM-
AND WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
SPECIFIC QUESTION. HELLO THANK
YOU ARE WE DON'T QUESTION THE
MERITS OF THESE PROJECTS
THERE'S VERY SEVERE POLLUTION
ISSUES AND- SOMEBODY NEEDS TO
DEAL WITH THEM AND SO WE THINK
AYE THE STATE THAT NEEDS TO
PLAY A ROLE IN THE PARTNERSHIPS
TO ADDRESS THEM I THINK THE ONE
CONCERN WE DO RACES AROUND THE
TIJUANA RIVER PROJECT-
CONSTRUCTING THESE PROJECTS
WOULD. HAVE INVOLVE ONGOING
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE
WHENEVER WE CONTRACT PROJECTS
AND PRETTY SIGNIFICANT LEVEL
SIX POINT FIVE MILLION ANNUALLY
SO THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
INCLUDES FUNDING TO COVER THOSE
COSTS FOR THE FIRST TWO YEARS
BUT DOESN'T ADDRESS HOW THEY
WOULD BE COVERED IN THE OUT
YEARS SO WE THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT INFORMATION FOR YOU
ALL AS YOU'RE CONSIDERING
MAKING THIS INVESTMENT AND-
BUILDING THESE PROJECTS HOW
WILL THEY BE MAINTAINED IN THE
FUTURE WILL IT BE UP TO THE
STATE. TO CONTINUE ADDRESSING
THOSE SIGNIFICANT OUT GIPSON OF
SO NO THAT WHEN YOU MAY THESE
TO. AT AND HAVE A PLANS THAT
THEY ARE MAINTAINED AND
OPERATED IN THE FUTURE SO WE
WOULD JUST RECOMMEND- BEFORE
YOU APPROVE THAT TIJUANA RIVER
PROPOSAL IMPACT ARE THEY GET A
PLAN FOR ADMINISTRATION OF
THOSE COSTS WILL BECOME. IN
YEAR'S AND THEIR WILL BE STATE
RETURN. FOR THE RECORD THERE
HAVE BEEN LOCAL IDENTIFIED
COVER THE GOING SO WE FEEL
COMFORTABLE THAT ONE GREAT THE
GOOD. WAY TO APARTMENT CONNECT
AND PERHAPS YOU COULD ADDRESS
THAT ISSUE OF ALL MY OWN
FUNDING. SURE BRYAN FULLER A
FINANCE JUST A NOTE THERE
DISCUSS HAPPENING ABBOTT LOCAL
STATE FEDERAL AND- TO SECURE
GOING ON. IN A IT'S FUNDING.
AND THE MINISTRATIONS COME. TO
NOT STARTING CAN. ON THIS
PROJECT. UNTIL THE ONGOING
OPERATIONS ME IN SPENDING
FUNDING AGREEMENT IS IN PLACE.
AND ALL OF THAT WERE OPEN TO.
AT INCLUDED- DISCUSSING
POTENTIAL PRISON LANGUAGE IN
THE IN THE BUDGET ACT AM. TO
PLACE PRINTERS ON THE FUNDING
UNTIL AT THAT FUNDING AGREEMENT
IS IN PLACE. THAT'S GOOD TO
HEAR THANK YOU. AND THEY ARE
QUESTIONS ALRIGHT LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S ANY PUBLIC COMMENT.
CHECKING MY WATCH STILL GOOD
MORNING A GERMAN BLOOM- MEMBERS
THE COMMISSION I AM
REPRESENTING A BILL OF THIS
FINISH WELL IT'S GOING. WILL
DO- I REPRESENT THE CITY
CALEXICO AS ITS ASSISTANT CITY
MANAGER PREVIOUS TO THAT SINCE
TWO THOUSAND SIX I SERVED AS
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALEXICO IN YOUR RIVER
COMMITTEE. THE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION THAT COSPONSORED
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN SEVENTY NINE.
SOME BUILT IN SEVENTY NINE IS-
PRETTY MUCH THE REASON WE'RE
HAVING THIS CONVERSATION TODAY-
AS A RESULT THE TECHNICAL
ADVISORY COMMITTEE WAS
COMPRISED IN WHICH WE BROUGHT
THE COMMUNITY. AND THE
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES FROM THE
THREE LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT TO
THE TABLE- AS YOU KNOW AND IF
YOU'VE READ IN YOUR MATERIAL-
THIS PLAN SPEARHEADED RESOURCES
TO BE DESIGNATED FOR THE
PROJECTS NOT ONLY ONE PROJECT.
BUT ALL THE PROJECTS IDENTIFIED
IN THE FIVE FACES OF THE PLAN A
PLAN THAT WAS ADOPTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA MEXICO BORDER
RELATIONS COUNSELING TWENTY
TWELVE- AS A RESULT OF THIS.
AND GIVEN THE SEVENTY FIVE
YEARS OF A PUBLIC HEALTH THREAT
CONCERNS THAT IMPERIAL COUNTY
RESIDENTS HAVE EXPERIENCED AS A
RESULT OF THE RIVER- WE HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO COME TOGETHER. AND
IT WAS RIGHTFULLY MENTION RIGHT
NOW IN THE PREVIOUS COMMENTS-
THERE IS A MEMORANDUM OF
UNDERSTANDING BETWEEN THE
IMPERIAL IRRIGATION DISTRICT
THE CITY OF CALEXICO AND THE
COUNTY OF IMPERIAL. TO TAKE
CARE OF THAT- IN AN EXPENSES
THAT WILL BE DERIVED FROM THE
THREE INFRASTRUCTURE COMPONENTS
IDENTIFIED IN THE PLAN FOR THE
CALEXICO REACH THAT MO YOU TOOK
PLACE OCTOBER THIRTIETH OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. INSTEAD DATE
WE'VE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE IMPLEMENTED
NOT ONLY. EVERYTHING IDENTIFY
IN THE STRATEGIC PLAN
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE COLLECTS
EACH WE ARE SO AHEAD IN THE
GAME IN WHICH WE ARE ALREADY
COMPLETED WITH THE ENGINEERING.
AND PLANNING OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE COMPONENTS
IDENTIFIED THE PLAN WHICH WILL
SEGUE. INTO THE LONG LONG
AWAITED NEW RIVER PARKWAY. THAT
WILL BENEFIT FOUR HUNDRED IN
THE WEST AT A CLUB TO GO THAT
AT THE YOU RIVER ESTHER BACK.
AT SAID I WANTED TO PROVIDE A-
TO THE CAN. THAT ON BEHALF OF
THE NEW RIVER IMPROVEMENTS
STRATEGIC PLAN WE HAVE THINGS
TAKING CARE OF AN IMPERIAL
COUNTY. THANK YOU FOR THOSE
COMMENTS SINCE YOU'RE- FROM THE
AREA AND THIS SAYS- YOUR
BACKYARD CAN YOU JUST GIVE US A
VERY VERY QUICK SYNOPSIS OF. OF
WHAT YOU EXPERIENCE- IN TERMS
OF POLLUTION THERE BECAUSE
THAT- WE HAVEN'T REALLY HAD AN
IN DEPTH- OPERATIVE SO HEAVILY
ON THAT BUT IT'S WORTH
REMINDING OURSELVES WHY THIS
ISSUE IS SO IMPORTANT. COMPARED
TO THE TO WANNA RIVER- ISSUE.
WE ARE IN THE SOUTHEASTERN
CORNER AND IMPERIAL COUNTY
BOARDING WITH MEXICO- SINCE
NINETEEN FORTY FIVE THIS HAS
BEEN CONSIDERED A PUBLIC HEALTH
THREAT- THAN YOU RIVER RUNS IN
FROM MEXICO CALLIE BACK
CALIFORNIA. INTO CALEXICO
WORKING ITS WAY TO THE SONG SEE
THE PROBLEM HERE THAT WE HAVE
IS THAT- GROUND ZERO IS
CALEXICO AS THE MAJORITY OF THE
CONTAMINANTS COMING IN THROUGH
THE WTER WAY FOR THROUGH OUR
CITY. I THINK WORK ITS WAY TO
SOME SEE. ARM THERE HAVE BEEN
QUALITY DATA THAT WE'VE USED
PREVIOUSLY TO BRING LIGHT TO
THE ATTENTION AS HOW THIS IS A
PUBLIC HEALTH THREAT- THERE'S
ALSO BEEN- NOW WITH THE BY IN-
FIRST- THROUGH AB TEN THIRTY
NINE. AND THEN THROUGH THE
POLICY INITIATIVES WHERE WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO CREATE SHOVEL
READY PROJECT. WHICH IS WHAT Q.
UNITY MEMBERS HAVE BEEN
ADVOCATING FOR DECADES I SAID
THIS IS FOR ME I'M GETTING A
DIRECT. IT'S BRINGING THE
PROPER STAKEHOLDERS OF WHICH
MANY OF THEM REPRESENT CAL. IN
THE COUNTY. GOOD MORNING MR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE BUT A
LOT OF THEM ON BEHALF OF US
SOON- ALSO BY MENTIONING THAT
WE'VE ACTUALLY BEEN ABLE TO
SPEND SOME TIME IN THE IMPERIAL
VALLEY THANKS TO- INVITATIONS
EXTENDED BY MR GARCIA WHEN IT
WAS HER EARLY READ TO. TAKE
OFFERED FOR OTHER OTHER-
SCHEDULING ISSUES. AND REALLY
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT AND THANK YOU
FOR ASKING THAT QUESTION ABOUT
THE PUBLIC HEALTH IMPACTS TO
LOCAL COMMUNITIES. YOU KNOW AS
A CAR. AN ORGANIZATION
DEDICATED TO OCEAN
CONSERVATION- ACCESS TO THE
OCEAN IS NOT SOMETHING THAT IS
PRIMARY TO THAT COMMUNITY IN
THE- BOB IS A WATER OF THE NEW.
AND THE SALTON SEA. TO BODIES
OF WATER THAT THAT WE KNOW ARE
EXTREMELY POLLUTED. AND
EXTREMELY- AND ACCESSIBLE OR
SHOULD BE AN ACCESSIBLE FROM
PUBLIC HEALTH STANDPOINT. BUT
WE DO KNOW THAT COMMUNITIES
STILL UTILIZE THEM. AND I THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT I WILL ALSO
ASSOCIATE MY COMMENTS WITH THAT
WILL BE MADE BY AND- FOLKS FROM
EDF AN AUDUBON. AND SAYING THAT
THE NATURAL HABITAT BENEFITS TO
THESE PRODUCTS ARE ALSO-
LAUDABLE- BUT PRIMARILY WANT TO
FOCUS ON THE FACT THAT THESE
COMMUNITIES ARE BEING IMPACTED
NOW. WANTING TO SEE THE FUNDING
MOVE NOW IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT- UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE IS THE UNEASE- FROM FROM
FOLKS ABOUT. YOU KNOW WANTED TO
ENSURE THAT IS PROPER OWN THEM
AND WE HAD THIS DISCUSSION-
MANY. AND WE GET IT- LEADING
THE FOLLOWING LOOSES GOING TO
BE REALLY IMPORTANT YEAH THANK
YOU. RICHARD ARM ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNTY OF IMPERILING IN
SPIRIT OF TIME I LIKE TO
ASSOCIATE OUR COMMENTS.
ABSOLUTELY WITH THOSE OF THE
CITY OF CALEXICO WE AGREE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY WITH WHAT THEY
WHAT THEY SET UP HERE- ON
NOVEMBER FIFTH OF LAST YEAR THE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
DECLARED A LOCAL EMERGENCY FOR
THE RIVER BECAUSE OF THE RAW
SEWAGE- IN AND THE DANGER TO
FOLKS HEALTH. AND WE'VE BEEN
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION SINCE SENSE
WE'RE VERY APPRECIATIVE. OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL HERE
OF THE TWENTY EIGHT MILLION.
VERY PRIEST OF OUR LEGISLATIVE
DELEGATION MISTER GARCIA MISTER
WEST OF FOR THEIR EFFORTS ON
THIS. AND WHOLEHEARTEDLY
SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL. GOOD
MORNING PUBLIC OURS WAS A VERY
MENTAL DEFENSE FUND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT AND THE- FUNDING
REQUEST FOR THE NEW RIVER
PROJECT. TO ADDRESS THE PUBLIC
HEALTH IMPACTS ANNOUNCE THE
WATER QUALITY IMPACTS OF THE
SALTON SEA. THANK YOU. EARNED
OVER ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF
SAN DIEGO AND THE PORT OF SAN
DIEGO BOTH IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE
SIX AND THE TIJUANA RIVER. ONE
OF THE MEAT ON A WITHOUT AMONG
CALIFORNIA ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MESS THAT MEASURE. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MORE
TOP ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
SAN DIEGO WE ALSO ARE IN
SUPPORT OF ISSUE SIXTY ONE A
RIVER VALLEY THANK YOU. THANK%
YOU VERY MUCH OF BOTH OF THESE
ITEMS WILL BE HELD OPEN- AND-
WILL PROCEED NOW WITH ISSUE
SEVEN- SUSTAINABLE GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM SEGMENT.
THANK YOU- I'D LIKE TO INVITE-
TO THE TABLE ATARI MAGAZINE YOU
SHE'S THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES- OVERSEEING-
SUSTAINABLE GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT ACT IMPLEMENTATION.
AS YOUR ANALYSIS- POINTS OUT
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL REQUESTS
NINE POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS
IN GENERAL FUND. FOR STAFFING
AND THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS FROM
THE GENERAL FUND FOR GRANTS TO
THE NINETEEN GROUND WATER
BASINS THAT ARE CRITICALLY OVER
DRAFTED. AND ARE BEGINNING
IMPLEMENTATION OF THEIR LOCAL
GROUND WATER SUSTAINABILITY
PLANS. OF THE DEPARTMENT WAS
HAS BEEN IN RECEIPT OF. OF THE
GROUND WATER PLANS FOR THOSE
CRITICALLY OVER DRAFTED BASINS
OF THE DEADLINE WAS JANUARY
THIRTY FIRST- EVERYONE
SUBMITTED WHICH IS GREAT WE'VE
OPENED A PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD-
ONE THAT- CLOSES ON APRIL
FIFTEENTH. AND ANOTHER THAT
CLOSES ON MAY FOURTH AND ARE.
STARTING TO RECEIVE PUBLIC
COMMENTS FROM VARIOUS
STAKEHOLDERS- AS TO THE
EFFICACY OF THOSE PLANS. I WILL
BE CLEAR THAT ONCE THOSE PLANS
ARE SUBMITTED TO THE DEPARTMENT
THE DEPARTMENT HAS A TWO YEAR
PERIOD TO RENDER AT A JUDGMENT
ON THEIR ADEQUACY. BUT OF THOSE
GROUND WATER MANAGEMENT
AGENCIES BEGIN IMPLEMENTING
THOSE PLANS RIGHT AWAY. OF THE
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS THAT WE
HAVE IN OUR BUDGET REQUEST I
WOULD BE MADE AVAILABLE TO EACH
OF THE CRITICALLY OVER DRAFTED
BASINS. TO SUPPORT PLANNING AND
PROJECT IMPLEMENTATION NEEDED
TO ADDRESS BROADER ECONOMIC
IMPACTS OF SIGMA IMPLEMENTATION.
THE PROPOSAL INCLUDES A ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO
BE PROVIDED TO THE LOCAL A
LOCAL AGENCY LEADING THE BASINS
OVERALL EFFORT FOR THE PURPOSE
OF IDENTIFYING THESE POTENTIAL
ECONOMIC DISRUPTIONS- IN
EXPLORING WAYS TO ADDRESS THEM.
LOCAL GROUND WATER AGENCIES
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO COORDINATE
WITH THE OVERLAYING COUNTY TO
ENSURE THAT THESE EFFORTS ARE
CONSISTENT WITH COUNTY PLANNING
AND OTHER PERMITTING
REQUIREMENTS. WE ARE AWARE OF
THE LA USE RECOMMENDATION- TO
LEGISLATIVELY PROVIDE SOME
ADDITIONAL DIRECTION REGARDING
THE FUNDING FOR PROPOSED LOCAL
ASSISTANCE AND WE ARE GLAD TO
WORK WITH YOU ALL IN. THE
COMING WEEKS TO MAKE SURE
DOLLARS ARE ARE FOCUSED ON THE
RIGHT KINDS OF ACTIVITIES THE
STAFF COMMENTS ALSO REFERENCE A
CONCERN FROM THE ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COMMUNITY. ABOUT THE
ADEQUACY OF LOCAL GROUND WATER
PLANTS IN ADDRESSING IMPACTS TO
DRINKING WATER WELLS. D. W. R.
SHARES THOSE CONCERNS ABOUT
IMPACTS TO DRINKING WATER WELLS
AND WE ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE
LOWERING OF GROUND WATER LEVELS
AFFECTS ALL ELEMENTS OF SIGMA'S
PRIORITIES DEGRADED WATER
QUALITY SUBSIDENCE SEA WATER
INTRUSION AND DEPLETION OF
INTERCONNECTED SURFACE WATERS.
DO YOU HAVE YOU ARE IS REQUIRED
TO REVIEW THESE GROUND WATER
SUSTAINABILITY PLANS FOR THEIR
ABILITY TO ADEQUATELY ADDRESS
THESE IMPACTS THE PLANTS NEED
TO IDENTIFY THE IMPACTS OF
CONTINUED GROUNDWATER DEPLETION
AND HOW THOSE IMPACTS AFFECT
ALL BENEFICIAL USES AND HOW
THOSE- IMPACTS ARE ADDRESSED
THROUGH THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THOSE PLANS. OUTSIDE OF THE
SPECIFIC REGULATORY
REQUIREMENTS OF SIGMA THE STATE
OF SEVERAL PROGRAMS THAT
INTERFACE WITH GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT INCLUDING SAFE
DRINKING WATER EFFORTS WATER
STORAGE PROJECTS AND
CONSOLIDATION OF SMALL WATER
SYSTEMS. AND WITH THAT ALL.
TURN IT OVER TO ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE. THANK YOU
BEFORE WE GO TO LA- IF YOU
COULD- JUST BE A LITTLE BIT
MORE SPECIFIC ABOUT THE- HOW-
THE DEPARTMENT WILL. INTEGRATE
INTO ITS- PLANNING ON ON- ON
THIS THE CONCERNS OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE-
ORGANIZATIONS THAT YOU JUST
REFERENCED AT IF YOU COULD JUST
ADD SOME SPECIFICITY TO THAT I
THINK THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL
SURE YOU BET MAYBE ALSO A FEW
WORDS AND THEN TURN IT OVER TO
MS ROBBINS ANY- WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE COMMUNITY
WATER CENTER AND LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL AND OTHER ENTITIES THAT
HAVE BEEN RAISING THESE
QUESTIONS THEY HAVE- VERY
HELPFULLY PROVIDED A- I WOULD
CALL AND I'D B<c.cyan> T</c>
MITIGATING IMPACTS ON TO. QUELL
DOMESTIC WELL IMPACTS AS A
RESULT OF SIGMA IMPLEMENTATION
AND THEY POINT OUT A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT ISSUES THAT ARE- MAY
BE PROBLEMATIC IN THE PLANS
THAT THE DEPARTMENT HAS
RECEIVED SOME OF IT RELATES TO
QUALITY OF DATA- SOME OF IT
RELATES TO- REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS FOR- MONITORING OF
SIGMA IMPLEMENTATION INTO THE
FUTURE- ALL OF THESE THINGS ARE
UNDER CONSIDERATION BY THE
DEPARTMENT AS WE EMBARK ON THIS
TWO YEAR REVIEW PERIOD- AND WE
ANTICIPATE. MULTIPLE COMMENTS
ON OTHER TOPICS THAT GET AT
THIS ISSUE OF WHAT REPRESENTS
ADEQUATE NEGATION OF IMPACTS TO
BENEFIT USES THAT WOULD BE
REQUIRED BY THE AND STEM CELL
IS RISING YOU HAVE FEW EXAMPLE
OF MAY ELUCIDATE THE REVIEW
THIS TOP THAT WOULD BE VERY
HELPFUL CERTAINLY A GOOD
MORNING- REMEMBER. I TURNER
NEED TO BE DIRECT THE WAY
MANAGEMENT FOR THE DEPARTMENT
WATER. AND I HOW RECKONING THAT
HAD JUST EXPLAINS- REALLY WHAT
IS A VERY KIND OF TECHNICAL
ASPECT OF REVIEWING THESE PLANS
AND HOW WE'RE TRYING TO WEAVE
INTO- INTO THAT TECHNICAL
REVIEW. THE REAL- REAL TIME
ISSUES THAT ARE OF CONCERN FOR
MANY OF THE STAKEHOLDERS AND A
LOCAL WATER MANAGERS OUT WHAT
WE WILL BE NEEDING TO DO- IS
NOT ONLY LOOK AT THOSE PLANS
OURSELVES BUT WE WILL BE TAKING
INTO ACCOUNT THE PUBLIC
COMMENTS THAT ARE PROVIDED TO
US AND IT IS ISSUES LIKE THOSE
THAT ARE RAISED HERE. TODAY BY-
CERTAIN ADVOCACY GROUP THAT WE
REALLY I GENUINELY APPRECIATE
BECAUSE IT ALLOWS US TO HAVE-
KIND OF AT THE SAME TIME THAT
WE'RE REVIEWING THE PLANS WE
HAVE THE ABILITY TO ADDRESS
BROADER POLICY LEVEL
DISCUSSIONS. AT THAT NEED TO
HAPPEN IN SUPPORT OF MOVING
FORWARD WITH THIS ABLE GROUND
WATER MANAGEMENT. OF THE
DEPARTMENT WHEN WE ARE
REVIEWING THE PLANS SHOULD WE
GET TO A POINT. THAT WE
RECOGNIZE THIS UP PLAN HAS ALL
OF THE COMPONENTS THE
FUNDAMENTAL COMPONENTS TO BE AN
ADEQUATE PLAN FOR REACHING
SUSTAINABILITY IN A TWENTY YEAR
PERIOD PER THE REGULATIONS IN
THE LAW. WE WILL ALSO RECOGNIZE
THAT ALL THESE PLANS ARE NOT
GOING TO BE PERFECT AND SO THEY
WILL NEED CORRECTIVE ACTIONS
AND RECOMMENDED ACTIONS ON THE
PART OF DEPARTMENT AND IT IS
THROUGH THAT- ASKED. OF THE
REVIEW AND HOW WE'RE
INTERACTING WITH GROUND STING A
BILL AGENCIES THAT WE CAN
BETTER TARGET. THE WORK NEEDS
TO BE. TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
EACH MINUTE LOCAL BILL IS BEING
IS A PROPERLY IT SING THE
BENEFICIAL YOU. IT WILL VERY BY
BASIN- AGAIN THE BASIN- ISSUES
ARE VERY UNIQUE. AND THEREFORE-
THAT'S WHY THE LOCAL-
MANAGEMENT STRUCTURE THAT CIGNA
PROVIDED- IT REMAINS A CENTRAL
TENANT SO OUR JOB IS TO REALLY
HELP. THEM ADDRESS THE ISSUES
THAT THEY HAVE. THANK YOU- DID
YOU WANT TO ADD I WOULD ADD-
EVER SO BRIEFLY THAT- WE ARE
COORDINATING WITH THE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD- ON
ISSUES OF WATER QUALITY
PARTICULARLY AROUND. THE SB TWO
HUNDRED AND FUNDING THAT THEY
HAVE AVAILABLE TO SOLVE CLEAN
DRINKING WATER PROBLEMS IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY- SO THAT WE CAN
ENSURE THAT- THE OBLIGATIONS AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL ARE. ARE BORN
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND AREN'T
WORSENING CONDITIONS- THAT SB
TWO HUNDRED FUNDING WAS
DESIGNED TO ADDRESS SO IT'S
GOING TO BE AN ONGOING
CONVERSATION THAT WILL NEED TO-
PRESENT HERE AT THE LEGISLATURE
OVER TIME AS WE START TO SORT
OUT- WHAT SEGMENT SIGMA
IMPLEMENTATION LOOKS LIKE ON
THE GROUND. THANK YOU- I DON'T
HAVE TO TELL YOU- THAT WHERE AN
INFLECTION POINT WHEN IT COMES
TO. A CLEAN AND SAFE DRINKING
WATER AND A CLEANING UP SOME OF
THE- STANDING. WATER QUALITY
ISSUES THAT WE HAVE AROUND THE
STATE. WE OWE IT TO THE PUBLIC
WHO HAVE BEEN- WAITING FOR
DECADES FOR THIS MOMENT TO
ARRIVE TO GET THIS RIGHT AND-
SO I APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS
BUT OF. WANT TO ADD THAT
CONTEXT TO THEM BECAUSE I THINK
THIS IS JUST SO IMPORTANT LA-
YOU'VE BEEN PATIENT WILL HAVE
TO GO HEAD- THANK YOU THAT SO
OBVIOUSLY SIGMA IS A HUGE
PRIORITY FOR THE STATE AND IS
AT A REALLY CRITICAL PERIOD OF
ITS IMPLEMENTATION RIGHT NOW
WITH THESE- INITIAL- BASINS
COMING IN AND SUBMITTING THEIR
PLAN SO WE THINK THAT THE
DEPARTMENT'S REQUEST FOR NINE
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS TO.
HELP SUPPORT AND DO THOSE IS
JUSTIFIED WOULD RECOMMEND
ADOPTING THAT AS DIRECTOR
NEMETH MENTION FOR THE THIRTY
MILLION AND LOCAL ASSISTANCE WE
WOULD RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
ADOPT SOME LINKAGE BUT SOME
PARAMETERS AROUND THOSE FUNDS
AND SPECIFICALLY TO ENSURE THAT
THERE USED FOR PUBLIC BENEFIT
AND NOT PRIVATE BENEFIT. AND
THAT THEY ARE USED TO FURTHER
THAT ACTIVE IMPLEMENTATION OF
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
PLANS AND NOT- OTHER TYPES OF
PROJECTS THAT MAY BE OUTSIDE
THE SCOPE OFREALLY STATE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR IMPLEMENTING
SEGMENT. THANK YOU- DEPARTMENT
FINANCE- ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA
HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN WILL TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE ND- OF-
A DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES- IS RIVAS DID YOU
HAVE A QUESTION OR COMMENT YEAH
I JUST HAVE A FEW COMMENTS I'VE
YOU KNOW KNOWING THAT WE JUST
RECENTLY APPROVED- POSITIONS
THAT DID OF YOU ARE TO
IMPLEMENT SB THREE OH SEVEN. UP
LAST YEAR- WHICH I WAS A CO
AUTHOR I THINK WE SHOULD HAVE A
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE NEED TO DO
ADDITIONAL OVERSIGHT OVER
PROPOSALS THE SEEK TO EXTRACT
WATER FROM DESERT FIRES- YOU
KNOW THEY'RE OUT I KNOW THERE
WAS A COMMENT IN HERE ABOUT-
FUTURE GROUNDWATER TRANSFER
PROJECTS. IN LINDA HAZARDS AND
I WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE. IN
MINISTRATION AND THE DEPARTMENT
TO LOOK AT ADDITIONAL NEED TO
PROVIDE OVERSIGHT. OF PROPOSALS
THAT ONE EXTRACT WATER FROM
MARK DESERT- SO THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO ME- BUT I HAVEN'T
ANOTHER QUESTION YOU KNOW. HOW
DO YOU THINK WE CAN- I
IMPLEMENT SIGMA IN A MANNER
THAT MAKES FRONT LINE
COMMUNITIES MORE DROUGHT AND
CLIMATE CHANGE RESILIENT. IT'S
A GOOD QUESTION AND SIGNAL
REALLY IS ABOUT- HELPING
CALIFORNIA MANAGE BETTER-
THROUGH DRY PERIODS SO AS-
SECTOR CROWFOOT MENTIONED-
MAYBE AN HOUR OR SO AGO- THAT-
THE SITUATION AROUND WATER
BASINS IS THE RESULT OF DECADES
OF ESSENTIALLY PUMPING DURING
DRY TIMES BUT NOT REFILLING
WHEN IT'S WET AND THAT IS
FUNDAMENTALLY THE OBJECTIVE OF
SIGMA TO BRING THOSE GROUND
WATER BASINS INTO BALANCE ND
SO WE DO IN CALIFORNIA- DURING
DRY TIMES. OF MOST OF CAL
DEPENDS ON GROUND WATER TO-
MAKE THEIR COMMUNITIES- MEET
THEIR COMMUNITIES WATER NEEDS
AND THEIR LOCAL ECONOMIC NEEDS
AND THAT'S GOING TO CONTINUE
INTO THE FUTURE AND THAT'S NOT
A BAD THING WE JUST NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE. THE
ACTIONS READY ESPECIALLY-
DURING DRY TIMES TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE PUTTING THAT WATER-
WERE RECHARGING THOSE GROUND
WATER BASINS AND REFILLING THAT
ACCOUNT IF YOU WILL SOME OF
THOSE KINDS OF PROJECTS THAT
WE'RE LOOKING MOST INTENSIVELY
AT OUR MANAGING FLOOD WATERS IN
A DIFFERENT WAY. AND THE AND IS
INVOLVED IN EXTENSIVE STUDIES-
PILOT STUDIES IN CERTAIN PARTS
OF THE STATE WHERE WE ARE
ASSESSING SOIL CONDITIONS WE'RE
ASSESSING- FLOOD CONDITIONS
WITH VARIOUS ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT
CLIMATE CHANGE TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT KIND OF LOCALIZED
CONVEYANCE PROJECTS MIGHT BE
HELPFUL. I'M IN THIS. THE
RECHARGE OF RAP WATER BASINS
WHEN WE HAVE A REALLY WET
HYDROLOGY COMING THROUGH THE
STATE. GREAT CAST I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- I THINK WHAT I'LL
ASK YOU TO DO NOW ON ISSUES
EIGHT THROUGH ELEVEN THIS. GIVE
US A- A THUMBNAIL SKETCH ON ON-
EACH OF THOSE- STAFF HASN'T-
IDENTIFIED ANY PARTICULAR
ISSUES WITH THIS WILL BE ABLE
TO. TAKE VOTES TO A UP THE
PROOF- AND THEN WILL- MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT. CERTAINLY ISSUE
EIGHT HYDRO METEOROLOGY AND
SURFACE WATER OBSERVATIONS THIS
PROPOSAL REQUEST SIX MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE GENERAL FUND
AND ELEVEN POSITIONS TO SUPPORT
THE HYDRO METEOROLOGY AND
SURFACE WATER OBSERVATIONS
PROGRAMS WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
OF WATER RESOURCES. THE
DEPARTMENT IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
MAINTAINING TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY REMOTE WEATHER STATIONS
THAT PROVIDE CRITICAL
INFORMATION FOR FLOOD EMERGENCY
RESPONSE AND WATER SUPPLY
FORECASTING. THE SIX MILLION
DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUNDS
PROVIDE STAFFING RESOURCES AND
EQUIPMENT TO ENHANCE SURFACE
WATER MONITORING BY RE
ACTIVATING OR UPGRADING
EXISTING MONITORING STATIONS
WERE INSTALLING NEW STATIONS TO
ADDRESS KNOWN INFORMATION GAPS.
THE OBSERVATIONS BY THESE
MONITORING SITES ARE
INCREASINGLY CRUCIAL TO SMART
WATER MANAGEMENT CALIFORNIA
GIVEN CLIMATE IMPACTS ON OUR
HYDROLOGY AND OUR NEW
IMPERATIVE TO BRING GROUND
WATER BASINS INTO BALANCE I
THINK THAT'S PROBABLY
SUFFICIENT CELEBRATE FORCE. A
AND ON THE ISSUE NINE. ISSUE
NINE- FLOOD MANAGEMENT SUPPORT.
SUBCOMMITTEE STAFF HAS
REQUESTED THAT WE DISCUSS
ACTUALLY ISSUES NINE TEN AND
ELEVEN TOGETHER AS THEY ALL ARE
COMPLEMENTARY GREAT- LET ME
NOTE- THE IMPORTANT COOPERATIVE
COMPONENT OF THESE PROPOSALS.
FLOOD MANAGEMENT IN CALIFORNIA
IS A SHARED RESPONSIBILITY
AMONG STATE FEDERAL AND LOCAL
AGENCIES D. W. R. HAS GENERAL
FLOOD MANAGEMENT
RESPONSIBILITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND A MORE SPECIFIC ROLE
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY. WHILE
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS HAS BEEN
MADE IN RECENT YEARS OUR
STATE'S EXPOSURE TO FLOOD RISK
REMAINS A SUBSTANTIAL THREAT TO
PUBLIC SAFETY INFRASTRUCTURE
AND OUR ECONOMY. THESE
PROPOSALS SUPPORT THE DELIVERY
OF LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL
FLOOD AND MULTI BENEFIT
PROJECTS THAT ARE NECESSARY TO
MEET THE STATE'S OBLIGATIONS TO
MAINTAIN AND OPERATE FLOOD
CONTROL INFRASTRUCTURE. ISSUES
NINE AND ELEVEN ARE RELATED AS
ISSUE NINE WOULD PROVIDE A
EIGHT HUNDRED FIFTY THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO SUPPORT
THREE POSITIONS THAT ARE VITAL
TO THE PROJECT WORK. THAT WOULD
BE FUNDED BY THE FORTY THREE
MILLION DOLLAR IN GENERAL FUND
PROPOSAL A PROPOSED UNDER ISSUE
ELEVEN. THESE POSITIONS WOULD
PLAN PRIORITIZE AND MANAGE
PROJECTS AS WELL AS PREPARE OUR
SECRET DOCUMENTS. THE FORTY SIX
MILLION DOLLAR IN GENERAL FUND-
IN ISSUE ELEVEN WOULD SUPPORT
THE AMERICAN RIVER WORK
UNDERTAKEN IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE ARMY CORPS OF ENGINEERS.
AND THE SACRAMENTO AREA FLOOD
CONTROL AGENCY. THE FUNDING
WILL SUPPORT THE CONSTRUCTION
OF LEVY IMPROVEMENT MEASURES
FOR THE EAST LEVY OF THE
SACRAMENTO RIVER DOWNSTREAM OF
THE AMERICAN RIVER. SEVERAL
OTHER LEVY AND A ROAD IN
CONTROL PROJECTS IN THE
AMERICAN RIVER SYSTEM. AND THE
WIDENING OF THE SACRAMENTO
WE'RE AND BYPASS TO DELIVER
MORE FLOOD FLOWS INTO THE YOLO
BYPASS. AS THE SUBCOMMITTEE
AGENDA NOTES THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS ALREADY
COMMITTED MORE THAN ONE AND A
HALF BILLION DOLLARS TO THESE
PROJECTS. THE REQUESTED FUNDING
HERE IS- THE STATE CONTRIBUTION
TO THAT EFFORT GREAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH LA- ANY COMMENTS.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ANYTHING
FURTHER. IS THERE- ARE THERE
ANY COMMENTS ON THIS SAYS THERE
ARE A. IS A WE HAVE TO LEAVE
BEFORE CUT PUBLIC COMMENT. YOUR
OWN OKAY ALL RIGHT LET'S TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT TO ON ISSUES
FIVE THROUGH ELEVEN. THAT'S
RIGHT WE TOOK FIVE AND SIX OF
SEVEN THROUGH ELEVEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON ROBERT CORPS FROM THE
QUALCOMM GROUP ON BEHALF OF
SACRAMENTO MENTAL AREA FLOOD
CONTROL AGENCY WEREN'T STRONG
SUPPORT WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
THE HAVE YOU ARE FOR DECADES ON
THIS AS WELL AS CONGRESSMAN
MATT SO WE- ARE WE THINK IT'S A
GOOD IDEA TO LEVERAGE ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION. I THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS
JONATHAN NELSON WITH THAT
COMMUNITY ONE OR SUTTER ON ITEM
SEVEN WANT TO START- BY
EXPRESSING APPRECIATION TO
DIRECTOR NY MATH. ON W.
DIRECTOR RATHER ZENI AND REALLY
OUR ENTIRE TEAM- BECAUSE WE'VE
HAD SEVERAL CONVERSATIONS NOW
AND YOU'VE REALLY OPEN YOUR
DOORS TO US AND WE APPRECIATE
THAT- AND WOULD ALSO LIKE TO-
FOLLOW UP- AT A DIFFERENT TIME
ON THE LA- PUBLIC. OUTREACH
MATTER- WHICH WE- I WOULD LIKE
TO BE HELPFUL ON- BUT WE'RE
HERE TODAY- TO SOUND THE ALARM
THAT BASED ON. THE GS PIECE OR
GROUND WATER SUSTAINABILITY
PLANS THAT WE REVIEWED- AND THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND THE CENTRAL
COAST- THAT. THESE JUST
PEACEFUL SEVERELY NEGATIVELY
IMPACT ACCESS TO SAFE WATER FOR
MORE NOBLE COMMUNITIES UNLESS
COURSE CORRECTED BY. OTHER
DEPARTMENT A AND THE STATE
WATER BOARD AS PART OF YOUR
CHEST PEER REVIEW PROCESS. I'M
MORE FUN. WE ARE REAL CONCERNED
IF THESE PLANS. ARE RUBBER
STAMPED. OUT AS A IS THAT
IMPLEMENTATION OF SIGMA WILL
UNDERCUT THE PROGRESS OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE HAVE MADE. ON ACCESS TO
SAFE WATER EVEN JUST LAST YEAR
AND SO FOR EXAMPLE- JUST TO
GIVE YOU. A SENSE OF WHAT WE'RE
SEEING- CLEAN WATER ADVOCATES
ESTIMATE THAT OVER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS. WILL BE
IMPACTED. ARE POTENTIALLY
LOSING WATER- BASED ON HOW THE
MINIMUM THRESHOLDS HAVE BEEN
THAT. I AND THESE ARE BASED ON
ONLY REVIEW OF JUST SEVEN.
CENTRAL VALLEY GS PEAS. WE DO
WANT TO BE HELPFUL TO THE
DEPARTMENT AND THE WATER BOARD
SO WE WILL BE SENDING AND- WILL
COMMENT LETTERS- WITH EXTENSIVE
ANALYSIS. LEASES MUCH KNOX'S
CAN DO. WITH OUR- AWAY. OUT OF
THE ATTACKS. TO LOW INCOME IT
IS A- WHAT ABOUT THE PLANS
THAT. WE ARE RIPPING. WHAT
ABOUT THOSE COMMUNITIES. IN
THEIR ACCESS TO SAFE WATER. AND
WE'RE ALSO LOW AT. QUANTITY AND-
WE ARE NOT LOOKING FOR QUALITY
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO DO THAT BUT WE ARE
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT WATER
QUALITY IMPACTS AS WELL. TO ARE
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES SO TO
CLOSE WE NEED THE DEPARTMENT
AND THE STATE WATER BOARD TO
REVIEW EVERY PLAN- AT FOUR AND
ASK THE QUESTION OF HOW WILL
THIS PLAN. IMPACT BOTH WATER
QUANTITY AND QUALITY FOR
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES- BUT
WITHIN THAT GSA AND IF THE
STATE DOES NOT ASK THOSE
QUESTIONS AND THEN PLAN.
ACCORDINGLY WE BELIEVE THAT WE
WILL UNDER CUT IN A REALLY
MAJOR WAY THE PROGRESS E'VE
MADE ON SAFE WATER. OF LAST
YEAR THANK YOU ALL. GOOD
AFTERNOON MICHAEL CLAIBORNE
WITH LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR
JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY AND
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE COMMENT- NIGHT ECHO A
LOT OF THE COMMENTS THAT WERE
JUST MADE BY JONATHAN NELSON
ABOUT THE GOOD MEETINGS THAT
WE'VE HAD WITH. DIRECTOR NEMETH
AS WELL AS CHAIR ASK ABOUT THE
STATE WATER BOARD. AND WE KNOW
THAT THEY'RE TAKING THESE
ISSUES ABOUT IMPACTS OF SIGMAR
AND EFFECTIVE IMPLEMENTATION OF
SAME- ON DRINKING WATER
RESOURCES VERY SERIOUSLY- MORE
WORKING WITH AND REPRESENT
COMMUNITIES THAT WERE THE FIRST
TO SEE WELLS GO DRY DURING THE
LAST DROUGHT. I'LL BE THE FIRST
TO SEE WILD GOT DRY DURING THE
NEXT DROUGHT AND- AS IS MORE
PERTINENT TODAY THE COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE CONTINUED TO SEE WELL
JUST GO TRY EVEN AFTER THE LAST
ROUTE ENDED. BECAUSE OF OVER
PUMPING OF GROUNDWATER
RESOURCES. SO WHAT WE'RE ASKING
FOR TODAY IS ASSURANCES JAZZ
PIECE WILL EFFECTIVELY REVIEWED
WE'VE SEEN SOME REALLY. POOR
GRAY SO THE BILL PLANS EIGHT AS
AN EXAMPLE ONE AND ARE ALLIES
CHAU TO UP. EIGHTY OF DOMESTIC
WELLS IN THE PLAN YEAH WOULD GO
DROP BY IF WATER TABLES FELT
THE LEVEL THAT THE PLAN WAS TO
ALLOW. THE RESPONSE FROM THE
BEST P. U. S. ARE THE GSA'S WAS
AS IT'S NOT 80% IT'S ONLY ABOUT
50% AND- ANYWHERE IN THAT RANGE
IS COMPLETELY UNACCEPTABLE. SO
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR IS
FUNDING TO MAKE SURE THE CAN.
CONTINUE TO BE AGED IN THIS
PROCESS. THAT THEIR INFORMATION
ABOUT IMPACTS ARE. FULLY
OPERATED. AS WELL AS FUNDING
FOR X. THAT ARE GONNA BETTER
THIS IS COMMUNITY. AND IS ONE
MORE JUST THE RESOURCES IN A
ASSURANCE THAT DATA R. AS TO
HAVE THE RESOURCES IT NEEDS TO
EVALUATE THESE PLANS FULLY AND
EVALUATE IMPACTS ON DRINKING
WATER. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON NOW- PUBLIC GARCIA
WITH ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND
AND ALSO- MAKING COMMENTS ON
BEHALF OF THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY. CYCLE YOU HAVE THE
WEEK- FIRST OFF I I'LL START
ECHO WHAT OTHERS HAVE SAID WE
REALLY APPRECIATE. THE WORK TO
DEPARTMENT IS DOING AND RECENT
MEETINGS WE HAD IN THEIR
APPROACH TO THE REVIEW OF
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
PLANTS- YEAH WE'RE REALLY
ENCOURAGED BY. THE STEPS ARE
TAKING TO DEAL WITH FIRST DAY
WISH OF WORK THAT'S COMING HAS
COME AT THEM. AND ALONG THOSE
LINES WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
NINE POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS
YOU KNOW OUR STAFFING
AUGMENTATION FUNDING. THAT'S
PART OF THE REQUEST- YET JEREMY
SAID RIGHT INFLECTION POINT AND
SAFE DRINKING WATER WERE ALSO
AN INFLECTION POINT ON GROUND
WATER MANAGEMENT. AND INCITING
THIS IS A REAL YOU KNOW SIGMA
IS REAL NOW WE NEED TO. YEAH
IT'S TO THE- DEPARTMENT GETS I
DON'T ENVY THAT POSITION THERE
AND BUT THEY HAVE TO GET THE
STEP UP AND READ THESE PLANTS
AND- YOU KNOW I LIKE
DEFICIENCIES. EGGS AND ALONG
WITH. COLLEAGUES JUST EMPHASIZE
ON SAFE DRINKING WATER WE SHARE
THAT CONCERN THAT. SOME OF
THESE DRAFT PLANS ARE SHOWING
YOU KNOW A CONTINUE DECLINING
GROUND WATER LEVELS. WHICH IS
REALLY UNACCEPTABLE FOR THE BIG
THE COMMUNITIES THAT. ARE
DEPENDING ON ON THAT RESOURCE.
SAVING IS. HOPE THAT YOU'RE AT
REQUEST THAT THE DEPARTMENTS IN
THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD REALLY TAKEN AYE
TO THAT ISSUE AS A REVIEW THESE
PLANS IN THE COMING MONTHS IN
NEXT YEAR'S. THE PART OF THE
BUDGET REQUEST IS THE THIRTY
MILLION AND WE'RE REALLY PLEASE
ALSO TO SEE THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND BEING
ASKED FOR FOUR OF THE VARIETY
OF ACTIVITIES ASSOCIATED WITH
SIGNAL WE THINK IT'S NECESSARY
NEEDED PARTICULAR AT THIS
MOMENT- INDIA THEIR EARLIER
EXCHANGE BETWEEN SECRETARY
CRAWFORD AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PATTERSON ABOUT. KIND OF THE
ECONOMIC PAIN THAT. IS
POTENTIALLY WILL OCCUR IN THE
VALLEY SO WE THINK THE STATE
DEFINITELY HAS A ROLE TO PLAY
HERE AND IT'S MAKE INVESTMENTS
TO GET OUT AHEAD OF THAT. YOU
HAVE A- OR ALSO APPRECIATE THE
MENTION THE GROUND WATER
TRADING- IN THE B. C. P. AND
OTHER SOME CONCERNS AROUND THAT
BUT WITH SOMETHING WE SUPPORT
WE THINK IT'S AN IMPORTANT
TOOL. TO DEAL WITH THE
LIMITATIONS ON SUPPLY. WE WOULD
YOU KNOW OF SUBMIT BATES YOU
KNOW THE IDENTIFYING BEST
PRACTICES FOR GROUND WATER
TRADING PROGRAM. THAT ADDRESSES
THE NEEDS OF COMMUNITIES AND
THE ECOSYSTEM IS REALLY
IMPORTANT- SO WE DON'T DO.
TRADING OF AS WE'VE SEEN IN THE
PAST BUT WE DO IT IN A BETTER
WAY THAT IS. NOT HAVING ADVERSE
IMPACTS ALL THAT'S IT YOU
ANOTHER ONE AGAIN SIR CONCERN I
GUESS WITH THE THIRTY MILLION
IS WHAT WE LIKE TO SEE MORE
DETAIL ON ECONOMIC MITIGATION
PLANNING SOUNDS LIKE SOMETHING
WE NEED- BUT I'M NOT TOTALLY
SURE WHAT IT IS AND I YOU KNOW
I'LL GO FURTHER SAY NOT. I YOU
WITHALL DUE RESPECT TO THE
APARTMENT ORDER RESOURCES I
THINK THE TEAM IS GREAT BUT
IT'S I DON'T KNOW THAT THAT'S
OUR CORE EXPERTISE IS SORT OF
WHAT'S ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
IMPACTS HERE SORRY I THINK JUST
CONTINUE THAT DIALOGUE ABOUT
WHAT WHAT'S OUR ACTIVITIES THE
DEPARTMENT REALLY REALIZES. WE
NEED TO INVOLVE EMPLOYER
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT OR OTHER
SORT OF EXPERTISE WITHIN STATE
GOVERNMENT HERE. AND THEN I.
TWO FINAL POINTS A THE THIRTY
MILLION I WOULD IMPLORE THEY TO
BE SPENT ON ACTIVITIES THAT WE
DON'T CURRENTLY HAVE OTHER
RESOURCES FOR WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT GROUND WATER RECHARGE
PROJECTS I THINK THERE'S SOME
BOND FUNDS AVAILABLE FOR THAT
AND WE SHOULD EMPHASIZE ON THE
GREAT THING ABOUT GENERAL FUND
IT'S FLEXIBLE YOU CAN DO ABOUT
OTHER THINGS YOU CAN'T DO WITH
BOND FUND SERVICE IDENTIFY
THOSE ACTIVITIES- IN IN A LOT
YOU YOUR ONE DO YOU ITEM MIGHT
BE STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT WERE
SAYING- DEFICIENCIES AND
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT. IN A
DRAFT USP SO THAT MIGHT BE
SOMETHING THE DEPARTMENT COULD
CONSIDER FUNDING I THINK WOULD
HELP WITH ECONOMIC MITIGATION
ISSUES ASSOCIATED WITH
IMPLEMENTING SIX. SO ALL THAT
SAID THANK YOU AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
DIALOGUE WITH THE DEPARTMENT
COMMITTEE. WHICH CHAIR MEMBERS
PAT RAN WITH THEIR AND READING
ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING THE
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS IN
CALIFORNIA GOT. SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
SPECIFICALLY THE NINE MILLION
DOLLARS- AND THE NEW POSITIONS-
THAT ARE PROVIDED FOR IN IT
EIGHTEEN OF WITCHER ENGINEERING
POSITIONS- WE BELIEVE THESE
POSITIONS WERE ONLY HELP THE
DEPARTMENT IN THE STATE-
ACHIEVE THEIR GROUND WATER
SUSTAINABILITY GOALS THANK YOU.
STACEY SOLOMON SUSTAINABLE
CONSERVATION OF WE WOULD LIKE
TO ASSOCIATE OURSELVES WITH
COMMENTS PREVIOUSLY MADE AND
WITH THE OBSERVATIONS OF LA-
AND STAFF CONCERNING THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE DRINKING
WATER ISSUE AND PARTICULARLY
THE SHALLOW WELLS. OF WE THINK
THAT THIS IS THIS IS A
POTENTIAL CATASTROPHE AND WE
FEEL THAT THERE ARE THINGS THAT
CAN BE DONE AND SHOULD BE DONE-IN ORDER TO AVOID THAT. I
APPRECIATED THE DIRECTOR. OF
REFERRING TO RECHARGE-
RECHARGES SOMETHING MY
ORGANIZATION HAS BEEN SERIOUSLY
INVOLVED WITH FOR A LONG TIME.
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO BE- IT
WORKING IN COLLABORATION WITH
THE W. R. ON PROJECTS ON ON
THAT ISSUE- AND WE THINK THAT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. IT'S
POINTED OUT THAT THAT- A NUMBER
OF THE GS PEAS THAT HAVE COME
IN. OUR OUR- RELY HEAVILY ON
THE IDEA OF RECHARGE AS A WAY
TO DEAL WITH THE IMPACT OF
SEQUENCE LIMITATION. WE DON'T
THINK RECHARGES IS A PANACEA WE
THINK IT'S AN IMPORTANT
ELEMENT. I AND WE SUPPORT THE
IDEA OF TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
INCLUDING. TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
TO GSA'S AT ARE INTERESTED IN
DOING RECHARGE ABOUT HOW BEST
TO DETERMINE WHERE THAT STUFF
ON HOW THAT'S. A NUMBER OF THE
JESUS PIECE WITH LOOKED AT SO
FAR IS A- SERIOUS OF LACK OF
EMPHASIS ON WATER QUALITY AND
THAT THE WATER QUALITY ELEMENTS
OF THE JEWS PEAS ARE ARE
SERIOUSLY LACKING AND ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE FEEL IS VERY
IMPORTANT IF RECHARGE IS GOING
TO BE AN IMPORTANT PART OF
IMPLEMENTATION WHICH WE FEEL IT
SHOULD IS THAT THERE ARE WATER
QUALITY DIMENSIONS TO RECHARGE
THAT CAN BE BOTH OUT THERE CAN
BE BOTH BENEFITS AND
SIGNIFICANT IMPACTS. AND SO ONE
OF THE PLACES WHERE WE HOPE TO
SEE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROVIDED IS NOT JUST SIMPLY IN
THE MECHANICS ARE THE HIDE OF
GETTING WATER INTO THE GROUND
THROUGH OF FLOOD WATER- READER
VERSIONS AND OTHER PROGRAMS BUT
ALSO TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
WATER QUALITY IMPACTS OF
RECHARGER FULLY UNDERSTOOD
BEFORE GSA'S ACTUALLY EMBARK IN
THE IN IN IN IMPLEMENTING THEM.
THANK YOU. ONE OF THEM IT ON A
WITHOUT A BUNCH CALIFORNIA- WE
WOULD LIKE TO A LEARNING THEIR
COMMENTS- WITH THOSE OF OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE COMMUNITY
ALLIES AND- AND- ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE FUND THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY. WE WHOLLY SUPPORT-
BOTH- ASKS OF THE NINE POINT.
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS AND THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS ONE THING THAT
WE WOULD ASK IN THE STAFFING
CAPACITY IS FOR THE DEPARTMENT
TO CONSIDER- TO HAVE. SOME OF
THAT STUFF LOOK AT THE IMPACT
ASSOCIATED WITH PRIVATE MANAGE
WETLANDS AND PUBLIC WETLANDS AS
WELL AS THEY DO THE REVIEW
PROCESS THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ADAM CAN UNITS ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES JUST
WANT TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR
ITEM SEVEN- YOU KNOW THE
SEGMENTATION SUCCESSFUL
IMPLEMENTATION IS A KEY
PRIORITY FOR AQUA- WE JUST WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
DEPARTMENT HAS THE RESOURCES
THEY NEED TO ENSURE ITS-
SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENTED. STAND
SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT WERE
RAISED- PREVIOUSLY- SET SOME
PLANS MAY BE INADEQUATE- WE
JUST HOPE THAT- THE DEPARTMENT
IS A LOT OF THE TIME TO MAKE
THAT ASSESSMENT- FOR EACH PLAN
ON A CASE BY CASE BEFORE WE-
NECESSARILY START COMMENTING ON
THE- THE- ANALYSIS OF THE
DEPARTMENTS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SO THAT BRINGS UP PUBLIC
COMMENT TO CONCLUSION WE HAVE.
FOR ITEMS TO VOTE ON WE COULD
TO- DO A- A SINGLE MOTION ON
ISSUES EIGHT NINE. TEN AND
ELEVEN. THANK YOU HI FONG
GARCIA MULLIN PERSON RAY YES
RIVAS. WE WILL- HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL VOTES FOR A
PERIOD OF TIME AND- YOU ARE
FREE TO GO. THAT'S A CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS MAKE SURE THEY-
KNOW THAT THEIR ATTENDANCE HERE
TO VOTE IS REQUESTED. AND TO
FOLLOWING A SUITABLE PERIOD OF
TIME WILL BE A JOURNEY. IT WILL.
THIS CALL.
AND THE. BECAUSE OF.
ISSUES OF SOME. ON. AB ONE. ONE
YEAH. OPTIONAL OKAY YEAH.
CERTAIN HOW HIGH BUT- BUT BUT
IT'S EASY TO FIND YEAH BUT-
YEAH. I. FINE. YEAH YEAH YEAH
YEAH. SAME HERE. SO I THINK
THEY WERE.
IS REYES WILL LET
YOU- ADD ON NOW THANKS FOR
COMING BACK UP. FOR ISSUES
EIGHT THROUGH ELEVEN CURRENT
FOCUS THREE ZERO CARE VOTING
HIGH. GRASS HI. CURRENT VOTE AS
FOUR ZERO WE HAVE SUFFICIENT
BUT THE ITEMS OUT. TO THE ONE
WE WILL WAIT A COUPLE MORE
MINUTES TO SEE IF ANYBODY ELSE
ARRIVES. OKAY GREAT THAT WAS
EASY THANKS FOR COMING BACK.
BOB. WE RESERVE. YEAH YEAH OKAY.
YEAH OKAY. OKAY WHAT. WHAT IS.
HELLO. OKAY. IT WAS JUST WHICH.
THIS IS CURE. YOUR BOSS. OKAY.
YEAH. JUST MISTER HERE THIS IS
NOT HAPPENING- SO I JUST
CONFIRM PATTERSON IS NOT AS
MUCH OF A PROBLEM. I'M TAKING.
YOU WILL. YEAH SO I THAT THAT
THAT OKAY. YEAH HI GUEST LOG
WITH THE ROOM YEAH IT'S REALLY.
THIS POLICIES. IF I HAVE EVER.
NOT A BAD DISAGREED DOWN. SURE
AB OKAY THAT WAS FOR I
APPRECIATE I THINK YOU GOT MOST
OF THE ONLY ONES YOU GET WHERE
THE YEAH. OKAY JUST DON'T YOU
KNOW SOMETHING PEOPLE. WANT TO
BE THERE HEARD AND OF THAT WILL
COME. YEAH IF YOU'RE TO KNOW
YOU'RE YEAH PART OF THE GAS IN
ORDER MAKE. WE ARE ADJOURNED.
JUST THESE ARE.